WE WILL CALL THE.
ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE TO ORDER.
AND I WOULD LIKE TO ASK ALL IN
ATTENDANCE FOR A MOMENT OF
SILENCE.
IN HONOR OF THE MEMORY. OF
FORMER UC REGENT MONEY REESE SO
WILL HAVE A MOMENT OF SILENCE
THANK YOU
.
THANK YOU.
SO GOOD AFTERNOON I WANT TO KNOW
THAT ASSEMBLY MEMBER MARK STONE
HAS BEEN APPOINTED TO REPLACE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. LEVINE FOR
TODAY'S HEARING.
ALSO THAT FILE ITEM EIGHT.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TO FORTY
EIGHT HAS BEEN PULLED BY THE
AUTHOR AND WILL NOT BE HEARD.
PLEASE NOTE THAT THE GENERAL
GUIDELINE FOR BUILDS HEARD IN
THIS COMMITTEE IS TO ALLOW
TESTIMONY.
TWO WITNESSES FOR SUPPORT TWO
WITNESSES FOR THE OPPOSITION TO
SPEAK FOR TWO MORE MINUTES EACH.
.
WE DON'T HAVE A QUORUM YET.
NOPE SO WE WILL BEGIN AS A
SUBCOMMITTEE.
AND I BELIEVE THAT THE FIRST
AUTHOR.
MISS MELENDEZ FILE ITEM FIVE.
BILL NUMBER TWENTY EIGHTY ONE.
YOU HEAR.
ALRIGHT WELCOME
.
WELL THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
AND MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
I AM HERE.
TWO PRESENTS TO YOU COMING
ONLINE MATERIALS OUT HERE AB
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE.
THIS IS THE CAMPUS FREE SPEECH
BILL.
NEARLY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY YEARS
AGO THIS COUNTRY BECAME THE
BIRTHPLACE OF THE FREE WORLD
THAT WORLD WAS BUILT UPON THE
REVOLUTIONARY IDEA THAT ALL
PEOPLE ARE CREATED EQUAL. AND
WITH CERTAIN INALIENABLE RIGHTS
THE CHIEF AMONG THOSE RATES OF
COURSE BEING FREEDOM OF SPEECH.
UNFORTUNATELY IN CALIFORNIA WE
HAVE SEEN A BIT OF A CHANGE IN
THAT PERSPECTIVE THE PLACE THAT
ONCE PRIDED ITSELF AS THE LAND
OF FREE EXPRESSION. HAS
ABANDONED THOSE VALUES FOR
INTOLERANCE
WE DO NOT HAVE TO LOOK MUCH
FURTHER THAN WHAT IS HAPPENING
ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
TOO MANY STUDENTS CONSISTENTLY
FEAR SPEAKING THEIR MINDS
BECAUSE COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES HAVE FAILED TO
UPHOLD AND PROTECT THEIR RIGHT
TO DO SO.
THEY HAVE BEEN HARASSED THEY
HAVE BEEN BEATEN THEY HAVE BEEN
ASSAULTED BY OTHER STUDENTS FOR
BEING PART OF A PARTICULAR CLUB
OR HAVING A CERTAIN OPINION.
COURT YARDS IN GYMNASIUMS HAVE
BEEN DAMAGING EVEN LET ON FIRE
SIMPLY BECAUSE SOME STUDENTS
DON'T HAVE THE EMOTIONAL
MATURITY TO LISTEN TO THE
OPINION OF ANOTHER THE HAPPENS
TO DIFFER FROM THEIRS.
STUDENTS HAVE BEEN SILENCED BY
THEIR OWN PROFESSORS
THE VERY PEOPLE WHO SHOULD BE
MENTORING THEM ENCOURAGING. FREE
THOUGHT AND EXPRESSION.
AND THE RESPONSE OF THEIR
COLLEGES ADMINISTRATORS HAS BEEN
THAT THE BARD STUDENTS FROM
INVITING SPEAKERS THAT OFFENDS
THEIR PEERS.
I.
I HAVE FIVE CHILDREN ONE OF THEM
IS A COLLEGE.
FRESHMAN.
I SEND MY KIDS TO COLLEGE
BECAUSE
IT'S A PLACE OF HIGHER LEARNING
AND I WANT THEM TO LEARN MORE.
ABOUT THE WORLD IN PARTICULAR
ISSUES NOT CONTINUE TO HEAR THE
SAME THINGS THAT THEY ARE READY
BELIEVE THIS AS PART OF THE
PROBLEM I THINK WE HAVE. WITH
OUR COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES AS
WE ARE KEEPING THESE YOUNG
PEOPLE IN A BUBBLE IN ALLOWING
THEM TO ONLY HEAR THE THINGS
WITH WHICH THEY AGREE AND I
THINK THAT IT'S.
A GREAT TRAGEDY THAT IS TAKING
PLACE IN CALIFORNIA.
UP STUDENTS HAVE BEEN LEFT
HELPLESS IN OF TURNED A BLIND
EYE TOWARD. THEIR FENDERS AND
THEY HAVE TURNED A GOD GIVEN
INALIENABLE RIGHT INTO A FOUR BY
FOUR FOOT SQUARE THAT IS CALLED
A SAFE SPACE.
I'M MRS AMERICA LAST TIME I
CHECKED BE ENTIRE COUNTRY IS A
SAFE SPACE.
I AM ASKING YOU TO SUPPORT THE
CAMPUS FREE SPEECH ACT TODAY TO
PROTECT THE FIRST AMENDMENT
RIGHT OF EVERY CALIFORNIAN EVERY
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE STUDENT I
KNOW MISTER CHAIRMAN YOU COME
FROM EDUCATION BACKGROUND I'M
CERTAIN. THAT YOU CAN.
SYMPATHIZER PERHAPS EMPATHIZE
WITH THE STUDENTS WHO ARE
FEELING THAT THEY ARE NOT
ALLOWED TO BE HEARD.
IN THAT THERE IS AN EFFORT TO
SILENCE THEM THAT IS THE POINT
OF EDUCATION IS IT NOT IS TO
ALLOW PEOPLE. TO EXPAND THEIR
KNOWLEDGE BE ON A VERY VERY
SMALL AREA THAT THEY EXISTED
WHEN THEY START COLLEGE.
AT THIS BILL WILL CREATE AN
OFFICIAL FREE SPEECH POLITICS
POLICY UNIVERSITY SHALLOT DOT
I STRONGLY AFFIRM THE IMPORTANCE
OF FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION ON
CAMPUS IT WILL PREVENT.
ADMINISTRATORS FROM
DISINTEGRATING SPEAKERS BECAUSE
THEY DIPS DISAGREE WITH THAT
SPEAKERS BELIEFS.
AND IT WILL REQUIRE UNIVERSITIES
TO DEVELOP DISCIPLINARY
SANCTIONS FOR ANYONE WHO
INTERFERES VIOLENTLY. WITH THESE
FREE SPEECH RIGHTS
IT WILL REQUIRE STUDENTS TO BE
INFORMED OF THE FREE SPEECH
POLICY AT THEIR FRESHMAN
ORIENTATION IN REQUIRE EACH
UNIVERSITY SYSTEM. TO CREATE A
FREE SPEECH COMMITTEE THAT WILL
ISSUE A YEARLY REPORT TO THE
PUBLIC TO THE GOVERNOR INTO THE
LEGISLATURE. ON HOW FREE SPEECH
IS BEING HANDLED ON CAMPUS.
IT WILL PREVENT INSTITUTIONS
FROM CHARGING IT STUDENTS
OUTRAGEOUS SECURITY FEES FOR
THEIR EVENTS AN OUTLAW FREE
SPEECH ZONES ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
COLLEGES AND UNIVERSITIES IN
CALIFORNIA NEED TO BE HELD TO A
HIGHER STANDARD AND PROTECTING.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT RIGHTS THEY
NEED TO FOSTER THE EXPRESSION.
IN THE FREEDOM OF SPEECH FOR
ALL STUDENTS NOT HINDER IT IN
HERE TO TESTIFY TODAY IN SUPPORT
OF THIS MAGNIFICENT BILL WHICH I
HOPE YOU'LL BE SUPPORTING. IS
JIM MANLEY FROM THE GOLDWATER
INSTITUTE OF PACIFIC LEGAL
FOUNDATION AS WELL AS NOW WE
THOMAS FROM THE BERKELEY COLLEGE
REPUBLICANS WITH THAT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. JIM KNOW WE'D WHO WANTS TO
GO FIRST.
GENDO THINK OF OF THE THING YOU
THE LEGAL THAT CLOSER TO.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS
THE WE ANNOUNCE THE MODEL POLICY
THAT THIS BILL IS BASED ON AT
THE END OF JANUARY LAST YEAR AND
THREE DAYS LATER UC BERKELEY WAS
ON FIRE BECAUSE MY YET OPPOSITE
BEEN SCHEDULED SPEAK THEIR.
THIS WAS WRITTEN AS AND A
NATIONAL POLICY TO ADDRESS THE
CAMPUS FREE SPEECH CRISIS.
CALIFORNIA HAS UNIQUELY SHOWN
WHY IT IS NECESSARY FOR THE
LEGISLATURE TO STAND IN FIRM
SUPPORT OF FREE EXPRESSION ON
CAMPUS.
WE WE DON'T THE WHOLE POINT OF
HAVING FOR FREE SPEECH
PROTECTIONS IN THE CONSTITUTION
IS TO PROTECT IDEAS THAT ARE
UNPOPULAR. WE DON'T NEED A FIRST
AMENDMENT FOR IDEAS THAT WE ALL
AGREE WITH WE NEED TO PROTECT
MINORITY VIEWS NOT EVEN AND
ESPECIALLY WHEN THOSE VIEWS ARE
REPULSIVE TO MOST PEOPLE.
I'D.
THE IT AND WE LOSE OUT IF WE
SILENCE OPINIONS THEY'RE WRONG
BECAUSE WE LOSE WHAT MILL CALLED
THE CLEARER PERCEPTION AND
LIVELIER IMPRESSION OF TRUTH
PRODUCED BY ITS COLLISION WITH
ERROR.
THAT'S WHAT WE MEAN BY RESTORING
FREE EXPRESSION AS A LIVING
TRADITION ON CAMPUS AND THAT'S
WHAT ABOUT THIS BILL A. B.
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE ACCOMPLISHES.
THE POLICIES WORKING IN
WISCONSIN WHERE THE REGIONS HAVE
ADOPTED IT ITS WORKING IN NORTH
CAROLINA WHERE THE LEGISLATURE
ADOPTED AT. AND WOULD MAKE
CALIFORNIA ITS COMMITMENT TO
FREE EXPRESSION STRONGER.
AND IT WOULD NOT RESULT IN ANY
OF THE PROBLEMS SUGGESTED BY
THAT THE COMMITTEE ANALYSIS.
IT'S A NICE STATE FUNDING ONLY
FOR UNIVERSITIES THAT IGNORE
WHAT THE LEGISLATURE HAS SAID
ABOUT THE IMPORTANCE OF FREE
EXPRESSION.
AND IT ELIMINATES ONLY ARBITRARY
FREE SPEECH ZONES AND SO UP FOR
EXAMPLE PIERCE COLLEGE IN LOS
ANGELES WERE STUDENT WAS.
DISCIPLINE FOR HAND OUT COPIES
OF THE CONSTITUTION BECAUSE HE
WAS NOT IN THE DESIGNATED%
POSTAGE STAMP SIZE FREE SPEECH
ZONE.
AND SEVEN STATES HAVE ALREADY
GOTTEN RID OF THESE THESE FREE
SPEECH ZONES THAT RESULT IN
NEEDLESS LITIGATION. I END AND
EXPENSIVE. THAT LITIGATION IN
ORDER TO TO PROTECT THAT THE
SIMPLE RIGHTTO HAND OUT A
CONSTITUTION OR HAVE OR HAVE A
DISCUSSION.
IT ALLOWS
SCHOOLS TO CHARGE STUDENT
SECURITY FEES.
BUT IT DOES NOT ALLOW THOSE
SECURITY FEES TO BE BASED ON THE
VIEWPOINT OF AN INVITED SPEAKER
AND THAT IS BLACK LETTER
CONSTITUTIONAL LAW ALREADY. BUT
AS WE'VE SEEN IN CALIFORNIA IT
IT IS ROUTINELY IGNORED OR. TO
BE TERRIBLE MISUNDERSTOOD BY
ADMINISTRATORS AND AGAIN RESULTS
IN ME LISTEN EXPENSIVE
LITIGATION
BUT THIS BILL WOULD PREVENT.
THE BILL DOES NOT PREVENT
ADMINISTRATORS FROM CANCELING
EVENTS FOR LEGITIMATE CONCERT
SECURITY CONCERNS BUT IT DOES
PREVENT. ABOUT CANCELING EVENTS
BECAUSE THE ADMINISTRATION
DISAGREES WITH THE VIEWPOINT OF
THE SPEAKER OR BECAUSE THE
ADMINISTRATION THINKS THAT. THE
COMMUNITY WILL HAVE A STRONG
REACTION TO THE SPEAKER THOSE
ARE UNCONSTITUTIONAL REASONS FOR
FOR CANCELING A SPEECH.
AND AND THIS BILL DOES NOT
ALLOWED THOSE REASONS TO BE THE
REASONS THAT THE ADMINISTRATION
POINTS TO.
AND OF COURSE
THE BILL BALANCES RELIGIOUS
LIBERTY WITH FREE SPEECH RIGHTS
AS THE CONSTITUTION REQUIRES US
TO DO BY PUTTING BOTH THOSE
RIGHTS IN THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
SO IT IN SOME THE BILL IS
DESIGNED TO PROTECT FREE SPEECH
FOR EVERYONE FOR INVITED
SPEAKERS.
PROTESTERS WHO WANT TO PRESENT
AN ALTERNATIVE VIEWPOINT.
AFTER YOU WERE KNIFE WE FIND
OURSELVES ON CAMPUS HAVING A
HEATED DISCUSSION.
THAT IS WHAT THE UNIVERSITY
EXPERIENCE IS ABOUT IT'S ABOUT A
BATTLE OF IDEAS AND THAT'S WHAT
THIS BILL TRIES TO PROTECT.
AYE WELL BEFORE I BEGIN MY BRIEF
REMARKS AT FIRST LIKE TO EXPRESS
MY APPRECIATION TO COMMITTEE FOR
THE OPPORTUNITY REPRESENT THE
CONCERNS OF MY PEERS.
I'M NOT EXAGGERATING WHEN I SAY
THAT FREE SPEECH IS ON LIFE
SUPPORT AT UC BERKELEY.
THE GENESIS OF THE FREE SPEECH
MOVEMENT HAS SINCE DISINTEGRATED
INTO AN AYE LOGICAL ECHO CHAMBER
WITH THOSE WHO CONSERVE YOUR
POINTS.
ARE STOCKED HARASSED AND
SOMETIMES EVEN BEATEN AS A
CONSERVATIVE STUDENT AT UC
BERKELEY I HAVE BEEN CHASED I'VE
BEEN PUNCHED I'VE BEEN STOCK
HAVE BEEN SPAT ON WALL ON
CAMPUS.
AND OTHER CONSERVE SCENES HAVE
EXPERIENCED THE SAME TREATMENT
VERY FEW RECENT HEADLINES FROM
LOCAL NATIONAL AND INTERNATIONAL
MEDIA OUTLETS.
SHOCKING MOMENT WHEN TWO MEN
VICIOUSLY ATTACKED THE TRUMP
SUPPORTER A MEMBER OF THE
BERKELEY COLLEGE REPUBLICANS
WHILE HE WALKED TO CLASS AND
BERKELEY THIS WAS CAUGHT ON
VIDEO. VANDAL CULTURE BEHEADING
LYNCHING OF BERKELEY COLLEGE
REPUBLICANS PROTESTERS RUSHED
BERKELEY COLLEGE REPUBLICANS
THIS WAS ALSO CAUGHT ON VIDEO ON
CAMPUS. ANONYMOUS GROUP PLANS TO
DOC'S BERKELEY COLLEGE
REPUBLICANS AND THEIR AND THEIR
CAREERS.
THESE ARE JUST A FEW OF THE TAXI
OF EXPERIENCE ON CAMPUS I DO NOT
FEEL SAFE ON MY OWN CAMPUS. AND
REGARDLESS OF OUR POLITICAL
DIFFERENCES I HOPE THAT WE CAN
AGREE THAT VIOLENCE INTIMIDATION
SHOULD NOT REPLACE DEBATE AND
DISCOURSE.
HOWEVER AYE AYE I DID ONLY
EXPERIENCE RESISTANCE FROM
STUDENTS BUT ALSO THE
UNIVERSITY.
WHEN MY ORGANIZATION THE
BERKELEY COLLEGE REPUBLICANS
ATTEMPTED TO HOST CONSERVATIVE
SPEAKERS AT UC BERKELEY.
OUR GOAL WAS SERVE BY STUDENTS A
PERSPECTIVE AN OPPORTUNITY HERE
PERSPECTIVE THAT'S USUALLY NOT
HEARD IN UC BERKELEY CLASSROOMS.
ULTIMATELY AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THREE EVENTS WERE CANCELED DUE
TO RIOTS OR THREATS OF THEM.
ON FEBRUARY FIRST TWENTY
SEVENTEEN LEFT WING ANARCHISTS
IN BERKELEY BEAT INNOCENT
BYSTANDERS IN THE STREETS.
SET FIRES LOOTED SMALL
BUSINESSES AND CHASE MEMBERS OF
MY ORGANIZATION AND INCLUDING
MYSELF. THIS WAS THE SCENE WHEN
A PROM CONSERVATIVE COMMENTATOR
WAS SET TO SPEAK AT UC BERKELEY
BUT WAS ULTIMATELY SHUT DOWN
THROUGH VIOLENT MEANS.
IT'S CLEAR TO US THAT NIGHT THAT
ONLY FAIR VIEW POINTS MAY BE
HEARD ON CAMPUS WITH NO
MEANINGFUL OPPOSITION. OR
CHALLENGE PERMITTED AND THAT THE
FAILURE TO ADDRESS THE ISSUE OF
CAMPUS FREE SPEECH COULD LEAD TO
BYSTANDERS BEING ATTACKED.
ON APRIL TWELFTH TWENTY
SEVENTEEN ORGANIZATION HAVE TO
CANCEL A SPEAKING ENGAGEMENT
FEATURING CONSERVE COMMENTATOR.
DAVID HOROWITZ DUE TO POTENTIAL
PROTEST UNIVERSITY PLACED A
THREE PM CURFEW A TIME IN WHICH
MANY STUDENTS RANK CLASS.
AND ALSO SITES LOCATION AS MORE
THAN A MILE AWAY FROM THE CENTER
OF CAMPUS IT WAS BUSSING
DISTANCE.
WERE ALSO STRONGLY ENCOURAGED
NOT TO PUBLICIZE OUR OWN EVENT.
ON TOP OF AN ALREADY SO HAPPY
SECURITY FEE OF NEARLY SIX
THOUSAND DOLLARS WHO ARE FAT P.
PAID MORE. IF YOU WANT TO INVITE
MEMBERS OF THE COMMUNITY.
GIVEN THE NUMBER OF UNREASONABLE
RESTRICTIONS ARE VAN.
WE COULD NOT AFFORD AND HOUSING
MISTER HARTLEY IT'S.
THIS WAS OUR SECOND EVENT
CANCELED DUE TO RESTRICTIONS AS
A RESULT OF POTENTIAL PROTESTS.
OUR VENT IN APRIL TWENTY
SEVENTEEN WITH NEW YORK TIMES
BESTSELLING AUTHOR AND CULTURE
WAS UNILATERALLY COUNCIL BY THE
UNIVERSITY. FIRST EVENT WE
PARTNER WITH THE NONPARTISAN
GROUP BRIDGE CAL THROUGHOUT THE
CONCERT PERSPECTIVE. FOR THEIR
SPEAKER SERIES ON IMMIGRATION
THE LIBERAL VIEWPOINT WAS
REPRESENTED BY MARIE ACHIEVE US
SAY THE FORMER WHITE HOUSE
DEPUTY CHIEF OF STAFF TO BILL
CLINTON.
HOWEVER THE UNIVERSITY ONCE
AGAIN IMPOSE THE.
A SERIES OF ON RESULT
RESTRICTIONS ARE SCHEDULED
EVENT.
HOWEVER IT WAS DURING A MEETING
WITH CAMPUS POLICE AND
ADMINISTRATION THAT WE LEARNED
ABOUT AN UNWRITTEN POLICY THAT
WOULD APPLY TO EVENTS WITHOUT
OUR KNOWLEDGE.
INDEED THE UNIVERSITY HAD BEEN
ARBITRARILY IMPOSING
RESTRICTIONS ON OUR OFFENSE
UNDER THE BACKDROP OF AN
UNWRITTEN CONCEALED POLICY KNOWN
AS THE HIGH PROFILE SPEAKER
POLICY.
THIS POLICY WAS LIKELY APPLY TO
OUR SPEAKER WILMER MARIA ATROPOS
IN VINCENTE FOX. THE FORMER
PRESIDENT MEXICO IN ART BILLY
HIGH PROFILE SPEAKER WAS IT THE
SPEAK WELL PAST THREE PM CURFEW.
AND INVENTORS NEAR THE CENTER OF
CAMPUS.
IT'S CLEAR THAT LIB LIBERAL
VIEWPOINTS ARE PRESENT WITHOUT
RESTRICTIONS WILL THE UNIVERSITY
PLACE. ATHLETE IN ESCALATING
SERIES OF RESTRICTIONS ON OUR
EVENTS.
THE HIGH PROFILE SPEAKER POLICY
INSURES THAT THE UNIVERSITY
OFFICIALS CAN PICK AND CHOOSE
WHICH SPEECH TO PERMIT. AND THEN
JUSTIFY THEIR A LIVE EVENT
CENSORSHIP BY POINTING TO THEIR
UNWRITTEN AND UNCONSTITUTIONAL
POLICY. TO MAKE MATTERS WORSE
THIS POLICY WITH HASELY CHANGED
NEARLY EVERY WEEK.
ULTIMATELY AFTER MASSIVE POLICE
PRESENCE THE DAMAGE CULTURES
PROPOSED SPEAKING DATES THE ANTI
FASCIST OTHER LEFT WING GROUPS A
NACHO IN FACT BERKELEY ANTI FOR
RELEASE IN OP ED STATING THAT
HAD NO PLANS TO DISRUPT AND
COLTER'S EVENT.
THE EVENT WAS CANCEL AS RESULT
OF UNSUBSTANTIATED AND VAGUE
SECURITY CONCERNS THAT WHICH
LEAD TO UC BERKELEY REFUSING TO
PROVIDE A VENUE. ALSO KNOWN AS
THE HECKLER'S VETO WHICH IS
BARRED BY SUPREME COURT
PRECEDENT.
AND TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE HOSTED
CONSERVES COMMENTATOR BEN
SHAPIRO. INITIALLY THE UNIVERSE
INFORMED US THAT THEY HAD NO
SPACE AVAILABLE FOR MR SHAPIRO
TO SPEAK AND BUT AFTER THE MEDIA
REPORTS. A THE UNIVERSITY RACKS
WE FOUND A VENUE.
ADDITIONALLY LAST MINUTE
RECEDING WITH KIND HALF BECAUSE
OF CHARLOTTESVILLE IN BECAUSE
THE UNIVERSITY FEAR THAT SOMEONE
MAY TRIP FROM THE UPPER SEATING
AREA. I ASK UNIVERSITY WHAT
CHARLES WILL HAVE TO DO IT
MISTER SHAPIRO IF THE UNIVERSITY
HAD TO HAD SLASH SITTING IN HALF
WHEN JUSTICE THAT MY OR.
PRESIDENT CLINTON AND CENTER
SANDERS SPOKEN THAT SAME EXACT
VENUE. THAT MINISTRATION EVER
ANSWER MY QUESTIONS.
WE HAVE SINCE FILED A LAWSUIT
AGAINST THE UNIVERSITY THE
RECENT RECENTLY THE JUDGE AGREED
THAT THE UNIVERSITY'S POLICY WAS
UNCONSTITUTIONAL. ULTIMATELY
EVERY TIME THE UC IMPOSES ON
COSTUMES UNCONSTITUTIONAL
RESTRICTIONS EXPOSE THE UC
SYSTEM TO LEGAL LIABILITY.
LOSSES CONSUME TAXPAYER DOLLARS
THAT CAN BE INSTEAD USE AYE
DUCATION.
IN CONCLUSION THIS IS ONLY MY
EXPERIENCE AT UC BERKELEY BUT
I'VE SEEN THE STICKER ON OTHER
YOU SEE CANCERS AS WELL. EVERY
GREAT FOR CALIFORNIA TO BE THE
VANGUARD OF PRESERVING FREE
SPEECH ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES
IT IS IMPORTANT TO GUARANTEE
FREE SPEECH NOW FOR TODAY.
AS IT IS CONSERVANCY BEING
SUPPRESSED TODAY BUT TOMORROW
CAN BE ANYONE.
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES AND.
IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY CLEANERS.
SEEM NINE.
ANY COMMENTS.
IT'S QUIRK SILVA.
I'M I'M GONNA TAKE THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS ISSUE UP
BECAUSE I DO THINK IT ISN'T
ISSUE OF TOPIC. ON FOR THE LAST
REALLY ALMOST TWO YEARS.
I WOULD AGREE WITH YOU THAT FREE
SPEECH SPEECH HAS BEEN.
.
IN THE CENTER OF DISCUSSIONS
WHAT WHERE I WOULD DISAGREE. IS
UP.
UNLIKE SOME OF YOUR INFORMATION
FOR BERKELEY I THINK FREE SPEECH
IS A LIVE IN LA WELL I MEAN AS
WE SEE I THINK PART OF IT IS THE
LOCATION. I MEAN BERKELEY IS NO
ONE TO BE VERY VERY PROGRESSIVE
BUT IN MY HOME CITY OF FULLERTON
CALIPHATE FULLER TEN THEY INDEED
DID CLOSED UP MY LOW YOU
NOVELISTS.
AND THAT TOO CAME WITH.
A LOT OF CONCERN BUT THE WAY
THEY HANDLED THAT WAS TO HAVE.
HIS SPEAKING VENUE ONE A PART OF
THE CAMPUS ON ANOTHER PART OF
THE CAMPUS TO ALLOW OTHERS TO
SET UP THEIR BOOTHS TO GIVE OUT
INFORMATION AND SO FORTH. IT DID
COST A LOT IN SECURITY BUT AGAIN
OF ONE OF THE THE SITUATIONS OF
WE TURNED IT AROUND AND INSTEAD
OF SAYING IT WAS A CONCERT OF
THE. CONSERVATIVE A CONSERVATIVE
SPEAKER IT MIGHT BE A MORE
PROGRESSIVE OR EVEN SOME US A
SPEAKER LIKE. VINCENTE FOX WOULD
HAVE THE OFFICES SO IN ESSENCE
ORANGE COUNTY.
WOULD BE MUCH MORE IN LINE WITH
WHAT YOU WOULD CONSIDER I THINK.
A A.
SUPPORTING A SAY MILO.
AND THEN THERE WOULD BE OTHERS
WHO THINK THAT IS NOT
APPROPRIATE SO AN EXAMPLE IS
TONIGHT IN THE FULLERTON CITY.
UP COUNCIL THEY WILL BE HEARING.
ABOUT DONE SANCTUARY CITIES.
THIS IS OBVIOUSLY VERY
CONTROVERSY ALL WE ALREADY KNOW
AND ARE SEEN PEOPLE ON BOTH
SIDES MOBILIZE TO BE ABLE TO
STATE THEIR VIEWS NOW HOW THAT
WILL BE HANDLED IN THAT COUNCIL
CHAMBER. OF WHETHER THEY CAN
HOLD UP A SIGN WHERE THEY CAN
YELL OUT THOSE ARE ALL PROTOCOL
DEPENDING ON EACH COUNCIL BUT
WE'VE SEEN THAT THIS IS TAKING
OFF IN ORANGE COUNTY. AND PEOPLE
ARE BEING BUSTED ON BOTH SIDES
SO YOU MAY HAVE A SOME OF VERY
IF YOU WANT TO CALL A NEO*.
OR VERY MUCH
A PORT OF AGAINST ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND THEN YOU MIGHT
HAVE OTHERS BUT IT'S ALL HOW WE
REFER TO THESE.
DESCRIPTIONS BECAUSE YOU
MENTIONED THE STUDENTS AT.
.
BERKELEY SO IF THE FASCISTS LEFT
WELL SOME OF THOSE STUDENTS OR
STUDENTS JUST LIKE YOU AND IT'S
ALL HOW WE PHRASE THINGS IN AND
WE ARE IN A VERY VERY POLARIZED.
OF.
SCENARIO IN OUR COUNTRY NOW MORE
THAN WE EVER HAVE BEEN.
BUT I CAN EVEN TELL YOU AS A
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER IN FULLER
TOMORROW IS FOR EIGHT YEARS. IN
OUR FARMERS MARKET WHEN I WANTED
JUST TO PASS OUT UP PIECE OF
LITERATURE RELATED TO MY
CAMPAIGN THE COUNCIL SAID I
COULDN'T.
NOW THIS IS IN A PUBLIC VENUE SO
OVER AND OVER I'VE HAD THE
REVERSE THE VET
WHICH IS. UP WILL LET YOU COME
HERE AND DO THIS BUT YOU CAN'T
DO THAT I THINK. MANY WAYS ON
BOTH SIDES OF THE AISLE WE HAVE
SOME REALLY REALLY GOOD EXAMPLES
OF HORRIBLE BEHAVIOR THAT UP
REALLY MAKES BOTH SIDES OF. THAT
WHETHER IT'S BURNING OR FIRES AT
WORK OR ATTACK WE CAN SEE THAT
ON BOTH SIDES I KNOW WATCHING
THINGS LIVE. ONE I'VE SEEN IF
YOU WANT TO CALL MORE
PROGRESSIVE PEOPLE.
ENGAGE IN A. NAME CALLING
VIOLENCE THAT'S THE LAST THING I
WANT TO SEE AND I'M SURE THAT'S
THE SAME THING WHEN YOU'VE WON
TRUMP WAS DOING HIS BIG
POLITICAL SPEECH IF YOU SAW
SOMEBODY PUNCH SOMEONE I DON'T
THINK YOU FELT LIKE HEY THAT
REPRESENTS US. SO I.
I DO THINK FREE SPEECH IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD
CONTINUE TO UP MAKE SURE THAT
ALL OF US CAN ENGAGE CHEN BUT.
.
WHEN WE LOOK AT THE SCENARIOS
CAL STATE FULLERTON IS MY PRIME
EXAMPLE WHERE THERE WAS A LOT
OF.
I GUESS CHATTER AND CONCERN
THAT THAT PRESIDENT AGREED TO UP
LET THAT SPEAKER COME AND
BECAUSE OF THE CONCERN THAT WERE
PARAMETERS THAT WERE SET UP.
THAT AND ENDED UP LEADING THE
EVENT TAKE PLACE WITHOUT A SOME
OF THE CONCERNS AND I THINK
BERKELEY WAS THE EXAMPLE OF WE
DON'T WANT TO SEE THAT HAPPEN.
SO JUST SOME COMMENTS. A MISTER
CHAIRMAN IF I MAY MAKE SOME.
I MAKE A RESPONSE THROUGH YOUR
PLEASE GO AHEAD OKAY.
SO.
YOUR I THINK THE EXAMPLE THAT
WAS PRESENTED WITH RESPECT TO
THAT THAT THE CITY COUNCIL
MEETING.
WHILE INTERESTING DOESN'T HAVE
ANYTHING TO DO REALLY WITH WHAT
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT HERE TODAY
OR THIS BILL I'M NOR DOES IT
HAVE ANYTHING TO DO WITH. WHAT
SOMEONE IS ALLOWED TO DO WHEN
THEY'RE CAMPAIGNING ON WHAT
THEY'RE NOT ALLOWED TO DO THAT'S
IT THAT'S A SEPARATE ISSUE THAT
WE CAN CERTAINLY DISCUSS ANOTHER
TIME BUT I THINK?
YEAH AND YOU LEAD WITH THE FACT
THE YOU.
UNDERSTAND THAT FREE SPEECH IS
INDEED.
.
UNDER ATTACK AT MANY OF OUR
COLLEGE CAMPUSES WHICH WE DO NOT
WANT I MEAN CAN YOU IMAGINE IF.
HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE THE
RULES WERE PUT INTO PLACE THAT
IF YOU COULD NOT SAY ANYTHING
THAT WAS OFFENSIVE TO SOMEONE
ELSE YOU COULDN'T HAVE WITNESSES
COME MEN. WHO WERE OFFENSIVE TO
THE MAJORITY MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE? WE WOULD NEVER GET
ANYTHING DONE. RIGHT THIS IS
IT'S.
WE'RE GROWN UPS NOW AND COLLEGE
STUDENTS EVEN THOUGH WE'RE STILL
PAYING THE BILLS FOR THEM.
THEY'RE STILL GROWN UPS RIGHT
THERE YOUNG ADULTS AND THERE
COMES A POINT IN TIME WHERE THEY
NEED TO BE ABLE THEY NEED TO
UNDERSTAND. THAT THEY HAVE TO
LISTEN TO WHAT THE OTHER SIDE
HAS TO SAY THEY DON'T HAVE TO
AGREE WITH THAT BUT THAT'S THE
REAL WORLD AND IF WE CONTINUE TO
PUT THEM IN THIS BUBBLE.
WHERE WE SAY NO NO YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LISTEN TO THAT SPEAKER
IN WERE NOT GOING TO ALLOW
ANYONE ELSE TO HEAR THAT OTHER
SPEAKER EITHER BECAUSE THERE IS
A SMALL GROUP OF YOU? WHO'S
DECIDED TO PROTEST THIS.
THEN WHAT ARE WE TEACHING THESE
KIDS GOD FOR BID THEY END UP IN
THE LEGISLATURE HERE AND DECIDE
THAT THEY JUST CAN'T LISTEN TO
THAT THEY CAN'T LISTEN THAT
PERSON THEY CAN'T HEAR THAT
SPEAKER YOU CAN'T BRING THAT
WITNESS. WE'RE DOING A GREAT
DISSERVICE TO OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
BITE BY DOING THIS AND I THINK
IT'S GREAT THAT YOU FEEL THAT
THE UNIVERSITY IN YOUR DISTRICT
IS DOING A WONDERFUL JOB OF
HANDLING THIS. BUT I AM TELLING
YOU THAT PARENTS ACROSS THE
STATE ARE TELLING ME THAT THAT
IS NOT THE CASE
THERE'S ONE WITNESS HERE TODAY
WHO ACCUSE TESTIFIED TO THAT
THERE WERE MANY MORE WHO WOULD
LINE UP BEHIND HIM TO SAY THAT'S
NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING.
THERE IS SOME SPEAKERS COMING TO
SOME OF THESE COLLEGES THAT I
DON'T. AGREE WITH.
BUT THAT'S WHAT YOU DO WHEN
YOU'RE GROWING AND LEARNING YOU
LISTEN YOU'LL PLEASE TRY TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT THE OTHER SIDE
HAS TO SAY. MAYBE YOU CAN FIND
SOMETHING YOU IT BE YOU AGREE
WITH THEM ON. MAYBE NOT BUT YOU
HAVE TO LISTEN.
IT'S THE REAL WORLD SO I'M I
DON'T.
YOU KNOW I'D MAYBE WE'LL HAVE TO
AGREE TO DISAGREE.
BUT I JUST WANTED TO MAKE SURE
I HAD AN OPPORTUNITY TO TO
RESPOND TO THAT THEM. AS WORKS
OF.
THAT AMERICA WAS YOU SEE TO COME
UP AND WITHOUT GETTING INTO A
BACK AND FORTH SPEECH AND DEBATE
ACTUALLY THAT'S WHAT WE'RE DOING
IS WE'RE HAVING SPEECH AND
DEBATE AND THAT IS WHAT.
THE INTENT OF FREE SPEECH IS IS
TO LISTEN AND TO BE ABLE TO HAVE
A RESPECTFUL DISPUTE DEBATE
UNFORTUNATELY THAT'S NOT WERE
SEEN BUT I DO WANT TO CLARIFY
DID NOT LEAD WITH SAYING. THAT
OUR UNIVERSITIES ARE UNDER
ATTACK I SAID THAT I SPEECH IT
UP FREE SPEECH IS ALIVE AND WELL
AND WE'VE SEEN MANY EXAMPLES OF
THAT ACROSS THE COUNTRY AND EVEN
ON OUR. COLLEGE CAMPUSES AND I
ONLY SAY THAT BECAUSE I. AS I
NOTED THERE THERE ARE
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS TO
SPEAK OUT I THINK SOME OF THE
FEAR HAS BEEN ESCALATION AND
THAT THESE AREN'T TURNING.
JEALOUS DISCUSSIONS BUT MORE
RELATED TO VIOLENCE AND THAT'S
WHERE WE AGREE I CERTAINLY A
WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE
HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY HERE.
HERE SPEAKERS THEY WANT TO HEAR
OR NOT HERE MUST THEY DON'T WANT
TO THAT'S ALSO A CHOICE THEY
HAVE MUCH TO ESCALATE INTO
VIOLENCE OR SHUTTING SOMETHING
DOWN JUST BECAUSE YOU DON'T
AGREE. WITH THE TOPIC CERTAINLY
THAT'S
WHERE I AGREE WITH YOU SO IT'S A
COMPLEX TOPIC AGAIN I WISH WE
HAD MORE OF OUR COLLEAGUES HERE.
RIGHT NOW TO DISCUSS SAID AND.
.
BUT THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THAT.
FORWARD.
NUMBER TO GO TO. DOCTOR FRENCH
AND IF YOU WOULD. IDENTIFY
YOURSELF AND I'M CALLING YOU
HERE IS REPRESENTATIVE OF YOU
SEE AND IF YOU COULD.
TRIED TO CLARIFY UC'S POLICIES
IN REGARDS TO.
CHRIS SPEECH IF YOU CAN'T.
Q..
KAREN FRIEND I'M OF LEGISLATIVE.
AFFAIRS OF BOARD UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
AND I'VE DONE SOME WORK ON THE
FREE SPEECH ISSUES I SHOULD SAY
I'M NOT.
OF A FREE SPEECH LAWYER.
AND.
I CAN'T SPEAK TO THE SPECIFIC
INSTANCES ON THE UC BERKELEY
CAMPUS.
IN TERMS OF FACTUALLY WHAT
HAPPENED.
WORD AND I ALSO UNDERSTAND THAT.
LOOK THERE'S LITIGATION ON THE
ISSUE SO.
PALM.
I CAN TELL YOU THAT THE UC
POLICIES.
.
HAVE BEEN EVOLVING OVER THE LAST
YEAR BUT THE GOAL. HAS HAS BEEN
AND CONTINUES TO BE. DEAD WE
CONFORM TO THE REQUIREMENTS OF
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
AND IF THAT.
OUR CAMPUSES ARE NOT WIDE OPEN
WITH EVERY PUBLIC SPACE
THERE ARE AREAS OF THE CAMPUSES
THAT OUR TRADITIONAL PUBLIC
FORUMS AND WE HAVE. TIME SPACE
AND MANNER.
RESTRICTIONS THAT CAN BE
IMPOSED.
WHERE? THE GENERAL POLICY ON ON
DAHLE.
THE.
SHOULDN'T EVENT BE SHUT DOWN IS
WHERE THERE'S A.
IMMINENT PUBLIC SAFETY THREAT.
AND WE'RE CONCERNED WITH THE
SAFETY OF.
OUR EMPLOYEES OUR STUDENTS ARE
FACULTY AND THE GENERAL PUBLIC
BECOME ON THE CAMPUSES.
THANK YOU.
NOT SEEN ANY OTHER WITNESSES
EITHER IN SUPPORT OR IN
OPPOSITION.
.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE A CLOSING
COMMENT.
MELENDEZ.
YES I WOULD THANK YOU MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND.
THANK YOU MEMBER QUIRK SILVA
FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION IN THE
DISCUSSION I APPRECIATE THAT I
WISH THERE WERE MORE DISCUSSION
TODAY ON SUCH AN IMPORTANT
TOPIC.
DOCTOR FRENCH'S.
.
COMMENTS WERE A BIT SURPRISING
TO ME BECAUSE WE'VE HAD MANY
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE UC'S I'M
THE CSU SYSTEM YOU SEE
SPECIFICALLY SAID THAT THEY WERE
NEUTRAL ON THIS ISSUE SO.
IMAGINE MY SURPRISE WHEN THEY'RE
LOBBYIST COMES FORWARD AND WITH
SEVEN COMMENTS THAT ARE CONTRARY
TO WHAT WAS DISCUSSED IN MY
OFFICE BUT. BE THAT AS IT MAY.
I THINK.
I I THINK DOCTOR FRENCH AND AND
NOW WE'D HEAR SHOULD HAVE A
CONVERSATION AND SHE SEEMS.
I THINK WOULD BE HELPFUL FOR HER
TO HEAR DIRECTLY FROM MY
STUDENTS THERE AND PERHAPS YOU
CAN PASS THAT ON TO. AND DOES
THE OTHER MEMBERS AT THE UC'S
ADAM BOARD THAT WHAT EXACTLY IS
GOING ON SO BUT I APPRECIATE
THAT DAVINCI CAME FOR AT LEAST.
AND EXPRESSED POINT OF VIEW.
.
HERE'S THE DEAL. OKAY.
WELL.
PEOPLE CAN SAY ALL DAY LONG THAT
THERE IS NO PROBLEM WITH FREE
SPEECH ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES THEY
CAN SAY THAT TO LOOKOUTS COME
HOME IN THE DOESN'T MAKE IT TRUE
BECAUSE WE KNOW THAT IT'S NOT
TRUE. IT'S NOT ON EVERY CAMPUS
THERE'S SOME CAMPUSES ARE
HANDLING THIS JUST FINE AND THEY
DON'T HAVE ANY IN THE THEY HAVE
NO PROBLEMS.
THERE ARE OTHER CAMPUS CAMPUSES
LIKE UC BERKELEY THEY'RE HAVING
GREAT GREAT DIFFICULTY AT
ALLOWING ALL STUDENTS TO
EXERCISE THEIR FREE SPEECH
RIGHTS.
.
I DON'T UNDERSTAND HOW WE GOT
HERE. A BUT WE'RE HERE TODAY
THIS IS THE SITUATION THAT
EXISTS FOR MY CHILDREN UMP FOR
YOUR CHILDREN GRANDCHILDREN THIS
IS WHAT THEY'RE GOING TO
EXPERIENCE AND THE LAST THING I
THINK WE NEED TO DO. IS PUT THEM
IN AN ENVIRONMENT WHERE THEY
FEEL THAT THEY SPEAK UP.
THEY'RE GOING TO BE HARMED
AND THAT IS WHAT IS HAPPENING.
THAT'S.
GO TALK TO SOME OF THESE COLLEGE
STUDENTS THAT'S STORY AFTER
STORY AFTER STORY HAS BEEN DONE
TEACHERS ARE NOW CHANGING THE
CURRICULUM SO THAT STUDENTS
DON'T HAVE TO READ A PARTICULAR
TAX OR AT LEAST. PASSAGES FROM
ATTACKS BECAUSE IT'S OFFENSIVE
TO THE STUDENTS THESE OR TALKING
ABOUT.
CLASSICAL LITERATURE HERE OKAY
WEEK.
ONE WHAT ARE WE DOING TO OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE WE ARE SENDING THEM
THERE TO LEARN OR SENDING THEIR
TO MATURE WERE SENDING THEIR TO
NOT ONLY LEARN AND THE. BIGGEST
SKILLS AND GAIN THE KNOWLEDGE
THEY NEED FOR A PARTICULAR
INDUSTRY BUT TO MATURE AS ADULTS
THEY CAN'T DO THAT IF WE ARE.
WRAPPING THEM IN A NICE WARM
BLANKET AND SAYING YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LISTEN TO THIS YOU DON'T
HAVE TO LISTEN TO THAT IN
ANYTHING THAT'S OFFENSIVE TO
YOU.
ARE YOU ARE UNCOMFORTABLE WITH
OR YOU DON'T AGREE WITH.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO LISTEN TO AND
NOR DOES ANYONE ELSE GET TO
LISTEN TO.
THEY DON'T GROW THAT WAY THEY DO
NOT GROW IN MISTER CHAIRMAN OF
ALL PEOPLE MY GOODNESS COMING
FROM EDUCATION YOU KNOW THAT
BETTER THAN ANYONE ELSE.
YOU HAVE TO THE THE BRAIN HAS TO
BE EXERCISED A HAS TO BE
CHALLENGING THE HOUSES SO THAT
THEY KNOW WHO THEY ARE AND WHAT
THEY BELIEVE IN AND WHY.
AND I'M ASKING YOU THOUGH THERE
WAS NOT MUCH DISCUSSION TODAY.
I AM ASKING YOU TO MOVE THIS
BILL FORWARD SO THAT WE CAN
CONTINUE TO HAVE THIS DISCUSSION
BECAUSE OTHERWISE WE'RE GOING TO
HAVE AN ENTIRE GENERATION
THOUSANDS. OF YOUNG PEOPLE WHO
ARE GOING INTO THE WORKFORCE AND
OUT INTO THE WORLD AND HAVE NO
IDEA.
HOW TO HOW TO ADDRESS IN AMMAN
CITY HOW TO DEAL WITH SOMEONE
YOU WORK WITH?
WITH HIM YOU DON'T AGREE.
OR WHO HAS IDEAS THAT YOU FLATLY
REFUSED WHERE IN THE WORLD ARE
WE GOING TO END UP AS A SOCIETY
IF WE JUST WALL EACH OTHER OFF
YOU GO IN THIS CORNER YOU
BELIEVE THIS YOU GO ON THAT
CORNER AND YOU BELIEVE THAT AND.
NEVER SHOT WE COME TOGETHER IN
THE MIDDLE AND MEET.
THAT'S THAT'S JUST
BUT THAT'S NOT A GOOD FUTURE FOR
US FOR AS CALIFORNIANS SO WITH
THAT I RESPECTFULLY ASK REWRITE
VOTE.
THANK YOU.
BUT I I WANNA THANK.
MISS QUICKSILVER FOR HER
COMMENTS AND FOR THE WITNESSES
AND YOUR DISCUSSION.
AND YOU ALLUDED TO ME AS AN
EDUCATOR SIGH I WANNA RESPOND
LITTLE BIT AS AN EDUCATOR.
AND THAT IS THAT AS A TEACHER.
AND I KEEP SAYING THE NUMBER.
OF THIRTY FOUR YEARS IN MY
CLASSROOM EXPERIENCE I NEVER
BACKED AWAY.
FROM KNOWLEDGE
NEVER.
RIGHT WHETHER IT WAS
CONTROVERSIAL TAX.
CONTROVERSIAL LANGUAGE IN THE
TEXT.
YOU KNOW.
PRESENTED TO STUDENTS.
AS IT WAS.
AS THE TAX WAS HISTORY DOESN'T
NEED TO BE CLEANED UP.
RIGHT PRESENTED TO STUDENTS IT
IS AND STUDENTS.
MY EXPERIENCE STUDENTS.
I HAVE A CRITICAL MIND.
THAT ARE ABLE IN THE CLASSROOM
TO ANALYZE AND LOOK AT.
FACTS AND OPINIONS
AND TO MAKE A DIFFERENCE.
YOU KNOW WHETHER THEY AGREE OR
DISAGREE.
WE LIVE AND AN OPEN SOCIETY.
WERE I DO BELIEVE.
BECAUSE I I FEEL IT.
EXPERIENCE IT EVERYDAY.
AS OTHERS HERE I THINK WOULD AS
WELL.
THAT WE ARE CONSTANTLY.
IN THE METS
OF FOLKS WHO AGREE WITH SOME OF
OUR OPINIONS BUT DISAGREE WITH
OTHERS.
AND I CERTAINLY DON'T SHY AWAY.
FROM LISTENING OR HEARING OR OF
BEING IN CONTACT.
A EVEN WITH OPINIONS
THAT I DISAGREE WITH AND. YOU
KNOW AS AN INDIVIDUAL WE WE COME
INTO CONTACT THAT WITH THOSE.
AS FAR AS FREE SPEECH.
BUT I I BELIEVE AS YOU DO THAT
THE FIRST AMENDMENT ARE.
IS AN IMPORTANT.
I GUARANTEE TO OUR FREEDOM IN
THIS COUNTRY.
SO MUCH SO.
THAT
YOU NO OUTSIDE THE UNIVERSITY
NOT THAT IT DOESN'T EXIST WITHIN
THE UNIVERSITY BUT SO MUCH SO.
THAT.
AS MS QUIRK SILVA POINTED OUT.
WHEN.
NEO* CAME TO MY CITY.
NOT FAR FROM MY OWN HOME.
AND WE'RE ABLE TO MARCH IN
FRONT.
OF.
OUR LOCAL SYNAGOGUE ON A FRIDAY
NIGHT.
DURING SERVICE THAT THEY WERE
ALLOWED TO DO THAT.
AND THAT THEY HAD THE
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT TO DO THAT.
AND I SAY THAT BECAUSE USING AN
EXAMPLE OF OF A GROUP WHERE ARE
A.
.
THAT I JUST VERY STRONGLY
DISAGREE WITH.
BUT I RECOGNIZE THAT THEY HAVE
BOTH THE RIGHT AND THAT WE IN
THIS COUNTRY HAVE THE FREEDOM TO
EXPRESS. UNPOPULAR IDEAS AND
BELIEFS.
SAME GROUP WENT AND.
.
PROTESTED IN FRONT OF THE.
A DAY CARE RAMPS ARE THESE
THE.
.
DAY LABOR.
WHERE DAY LABORERS GATHER AND
THE NEO* WENT TO?
?
PROTESTS THERE.
HUNDREDS.
OF PEOPLE CAME OUT ENCOUNTER
PROTESTS BUT AGAIN.
THEY WERE ALLOWED.
TO
SPEAK
A IN IN THE CITY AND SO THEY
SHOULD.
I MAY DISAGREE WITH YOUR
PREMISE.
THAT FREEDOM OF SPEECH IS.
IN DANGER.
IN OUR UNIVERSITIES CAMPUSES.
AND THAT WE MAY JUST DISAGREE.
DIFFERENCE OF OPINION.
AND AGAIN AS AN EDUCATOR I
BELIEVE AND.
.
ALLOWING IN CLASSES.
OUTSIDE OF CLASSES FOR STUDENTS
TO EXPRESS THEIR OPINIONS AND
DON'T DISAGREE WITH YOU AND THE
VALUE OF STUDENTS HEARING
DIFFERENT OPINIONS.
BUT AS IT GOES TO THIS BILL.
I I WOULD SAY THAT WHILE IT'S
IMPORTANT FOR COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES TO ENSURE.
STUDENTS ARE AWARE OF THEIR
FREEDOM OF SPEECH I CAN'T
SUPPORT THIS BILL.
THE REASON FOR I FIND THE BILL
TO BE TOO PRESCRIPTIVE.
AND I BELIEVE OF ENACTED IT
WOULD RESULT IN TOO MANY
UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCES.
ADDITIONALLY IS NOT THE PRACTICE
OF THIS COMMITTED TO PASS OUT TO
BILLS. TO ADDRESS THE SAME ISSUE
AND A LITTLE BIT FURTHER WE'RE
GONNA HEAR A. B. TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FOUR. WHICH I FIND TO BE
BETTER POLICY
FOR APPROACHING.
ADDRESSING FREEDOMS SPEECH ON
OUR CAMPUSES SO I WON'T AT THIS
TIME BE SUPPORTING THIS BILL.
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU COULD
CALL THE ROLL.
WE DON'T HAVE A CORE.
BUT THANK YOU FREER
PRESENTATION.
AND WE WILL LEAVE IT ON CALL
WHEN WE HAVE A CORE.
NEXT ITEM.
I DON'T THIRTEEN.
WE HAVE THE AUTHOR.
YES
THURMOND.
WELCOME.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR. FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY AND MEMBERS AND
STAFF EFFORT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB TWO FIVE FIVE FOUR
AND FOR THE WORK THAT YOU AND
YOUR STAFF HAVE PUT INTO THIS
MEASURE. AB TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
FOUR WOULD ENSURE THAT QUALIFIED
FAMILY MEMBERS
OF CALIFORNIA FEDERAL
FIREFIGHTERS WHO DIED IN THE
LINE OF DUTY CAN ATTEND PUBLIC
HIGHER EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS
YOU SEE CSU COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
AT NO CHARGE.
CALIFORNIA'S FEDERAL
FIREFIGHTERS RISK EVERYTHING.
PROTECT OUR STATEMENT FIRES IN
DISASTER STANDING SHOULDER TO
SHOULDER. WITH OUR STATE AND
LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS NEARLY FIFTY
YEARS AGO. WE APPROVE THE ALLEN
PATTY SCHOLARSHIP BACK TO WAVE
PUBLIC HIGHER EDUCATION TUITION
AND FEES FOR A SPOUSE OR CHILD
OF A DECEASED LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICER OR FIREFIGHTER.
WHO PASSED AWAY IN THE LINE OF
DUTY THIS BENEFIT IS IN
RECOGNITION? OF THE SIGNIFICANT
SACRIFICES MADE BY FAMILIES
BY THE FAMILIES OF OUR
FIREFIGHTERS HE'S CURRENTLY
GUARANTEED.
THE FAMILY OF FALLEN STATE AND
LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS INCLUDES.
THE FAMILY OF FEDERAL
FIREFIGHTERS LIVING AND WORKING
IN CALIFORNIA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR
I'VE OUT. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
YES I'VE MAY CONSUMERS
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS THE
SPONSOR OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN BIRDS
AS THE OTHER STATED MEGAN SUPERS
ON BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
PROFESSIONAL FIREFIGHTERS AND WE
ARE THE SPONSORS OF THE BILL. AS
THE AUTHOR ALSO MENTIONED THIS
IS BEEN A A TUITION AND FEE
WAIVER THAT'S BEEN AFFORDED TO
KEPT FOLLOWING UP TO THE
SURVIVORS OF PHONE FIREFIGHTERS
AND LAW ENFORCEMENT. IN
CALIFORNIA FOR FIFTY YEARS AHMED
APPLIES TO STATE AND LOCAL
FIREFIGHTERS BUT THIS IS NOT
EXTENDED TO OUR FEDERAL
FIREFIGHTERS WHO LIVE AND WORK
IN CALIFORNIA THESE ARE
FIREFIGHTERS TO WORK AT A MOST
OF THE TIME THE MILITARY BASES
FOR EXAMPLE CAMP PENDLETON DOWN
IN SAN DIEGO COUNTY.
AND WE REALLY THINK THAT THIS
BILL.
IS IMPORTANT I THINK YOU KNOW
THE FEDERAL FIREFIGHTERS IN
CALIFORNIA ARE INTEGRAL TO OUR
MUTUAL AID SYSTEM. THERE'S NO
BETTER EXAMPLE ABOUT THEM THE
RECENT FIRES FROM THE FALL AND
WINTER OF TWENTY SEVENTEEN WE
THINK IT'S REALLY IMPORTANT THAT
THE.
TUITION WAIVER THAT IS AFFORDED
TO THE FAMILIES OF OUR STATE AND
LOCAL FIREFIGHTERS ALSO AFFORDED
TO OUR FEDERAL FIREFIGHTERS AND
FOR THOSE REASONS YOU ASK YOUR
SUPPORT TODAY THANK YOU. OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
PAMELA LOPEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA STATE FIREFIGHTERS
ASSOCIATION IN SUPPORT.
AND THE OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
I MISTER CHAIRMAN MANY BEERS FOR
PLAIN SAN JOSE EVER WHICH DO WE
DON'T WE'RE WAITING
FOR A QUORUM.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISTER
BONTA.
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT TODAY OB I THINK THIS IS
SOMETHING THAT WE SHOULD BE
DOING FOR THE FAMILIES OF
FEDERAL FIREFIGHTERS TO TO
REMEDY A. ARM AT A CURRENT.
THE FACT IN THE LAW AND THIS
WITH A GREAT DIFFERENCE TO THE
FAMILIES AND. I WOULD REALLY
APPRECIATE AYE VOTE AT THE
APPROPRIATE TIME THANK YOU I
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND BELIEVE
THE SURVIVORS OF FEDERAL
FIREFIGHTERS WHO WERE CALIFORNIA
RESIDENT SHOULD RECEIVE THE SAME
BENEFITS AS THEIR COUNTERPARTS
FROM STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENTS.
AND ONCE WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL
TAKE A LOOK
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR THANK YOU
COLLEAGUES THANK YOU STAFF.
WE'RE GONNA GO OUT OF ORDER.
AND A CALL OF.
PATTERSON ITEM FOURTEEN.
SO THAT HIS STUDENTS
CAN.
THE UPPER.
SO ITEM FOURTEEN A. B. TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY THREE.
I CAN. APPRECIATE THAT.
YEAH.
AND TO MISTER HARBOR IS WELL
BURKE FOR FACILITATING AS WELL
THANK YOU.
IT WILL BE WILL BE QUICK OUT.
THE OFFER SO I OP APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT WE HAVE A S. SUPPORT
SUPPORT BILL HERE. ALSO WANT TO
SAY THANK YOU TO.
THE CHAIRMAN TO THE STAFF AND
OTHERS FOR WORKING THROUGH THIS.
BOB BUT THAT UP VERY QUICKLY YET
CURRENT LAW PROVIDESCAL GRANTS
INFILL GRANTS TO ELIGIBLE
STUDENTS.
UNDER THE ADMINISTRATION OF THE
STUDENT AID COMMISSION AND
FEDERAL STUDENT.
A COMMISSION EACH INSTITUTION
HAS DISCRETION TO VOLUNTARILY.
PARTICIPATE IN THE CAL GRANT
TELL GRANT PROGRAMS AND UPON
RECEIVING THE GRANT FUNDS ITS
RESPONSIBILITY UNIVERSITY TO
DISTRIBUTE. THE FUNDS DIRECTLY
TO THE STUDENTS.
FOUND HOWEVER.
FOR SOME ELIGIBLE STUDENTS AND
WE'LL HEAR.
.
FROM SOME OF THE CONCERNS FROM
PRESENT STATE STUDENTS.
THEY RECEIVED PELL GRANT A CAL
GRANT FUNDS AFTER THE START OF
INSTRUCTION.
MANY THEY MAY NOT RECEIVE THEIR
SYSTEMS FOR COSTLY TEXTBOOKS
UNTIL.
WEEKS AFTER THEIR SEMESTER
BEGINS.
IT'S PROBLEMATIC FOR STUDENTS
WHO CANNOT AFFORD REQUIRED
READING INSTRUCTION MATERIALS
FOR THEIR ROLLED.
CLASSES AB.
ABOUT TWO FIVE SIX THREE SIX TO
AID STUDENTS WHO FALL INTO THIS
CATEGORY.
BY REQUIRING UNIVERSITIES TO
EXTEND A LINE OF CREDIT TO
STUDENTS.
THE PURPOSE OF PURCHASING
REQUIRED BOOKS AND EDUCATIONAL
MATERIALS AT LEAST ONE WEEK
BEFORE THE START OF CLASSES.
THE BOOKSTORE WOULD REPORT BACK
TO THE UNIVERSITY THE AMOUNT OF
THE CREDIT. USED BY THE STUDENT
THE AMOUNT USED BY THE STUDENT
WOULD THEN BE CREDIT AGAINST
THEIR INCOMING. GRANT FUNDS ARE
SO FOR EXAMPLE IF A STUDENT IS
SET TO RECEIVE FOUR THOUSAND
DOLLARS. AFTER ONE SEMESTER THEY
USED TO HAVE IT AT THE BOOKSTORE
DEAL WHERE THEY WILL SUBSEQUENT
RECEIVES THREE THOUSAND SEVEN
HUNDRED.
THE IDEA FOR THIS BILL CAME FROM
A SUCCESSFUL PILOT PROJECT IN
SANTA ANA COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
WE SEEK TO EXPAND THIS FOR ALL
STUDENTS WHO ARE DELAYED FROM
RECEIVING ANY FORM OF FUNDING
ADMINISTERED BY THOSE
UNIVERSITIES THAT PARTICIPATE
INSTATE FEDERAL GRANT.
FUNDING PROGRAMS.
ALSO.
DO APPRECIATE THE.
.
INTEREST IN THE CAN THE
COMMITTEE AND THE WORK AND.
ACTUALLY MAKING THIS A MUCH
MUCH BETTER BILL QUITE FRANKLY
THAN I ORIGINAL INTENTION. AND
WE'RE GRATEFUL FOR THAT AS WELL.
UP TO HAVE WITH ME SEBASTIAN.
BUT WHEN THREE A CURRENT STUDENT
AT CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
FRIEND UP PRESIDENT EMERITUS SO
SHE'D STUDENTS INCORPORATED CLUB
HE'S HERE TO TESTIFY IN SUPPORT
OF THE BILL.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN I
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AND SOME A
MENTOR AYE PATTERSON
APPRECIATE YOUR TIME TODAY AND
THE OPPORTUNITY TO COME AND
SPEAK WITH YOU. UP MY NAME IS
SEBASTIAN WENT THE I'M A THIRD
YEAR STUDENT AT FRESNO STATE I'M
ALSO AN ELECTED REPRESENTATIVE
PARTS OF OUR STUDENT BODY
GOVERNMENT. AND DURING THE THREE
YEARS THAT I SPENT IN OUR
STUDENT BODY GOVERNMENT ONE OF
THE.
BIGGEST ISSUES THAT I WAS HER
COMPLAINTS ABOUT AND ONE OF THE
MOST.
ANNOYING ISSUES FOR STUDENTS IS
THE TARDINESS OF FINANCIAL AID
PAYMENTS AS WELL AS NOT BEING
ABLE TO AFFORD A CERTAIN ITEMS
THAT AT THAT THE SCHOOL AND SO.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I WANT TO
EXPLAIN WHY THIS IMPACTS
STUDENTS A RATHER NEGATIVELY AND
WHY I SUPPORT AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE. I I BELIEVE THAT.
.
AT AT FRESNO STATE WE REALLY DO
HAVE EIGHTY PERCENT OF STUDENTS
WHO RELY PARTLY AT LEAST ON
FINANCIAL AID ABOUT SIXTY
PERCENT. WHO RELY ENTIRELY ON
FINANCIAL AID IN ORDER TO A
PURCHASE THEIR BOOKS AS WELL AS
PAY FOR THEIR TUITION AND OTHER
THINGS? I'M UNFORTUNATELY. WHEN
THEY RELY ON A SYSTEM THAT IS
SUPPOSED TO. CONSISTENTLY
DELIVER PAYMENTS ON TIME AND
THAT.
THAT SYSTEM FAILS THEM THEN
THEY'RE STUCK OUT WITH BILLS
THEY CAN'T PAY AND SO WE HAVE TO
FIND SOLUTIONS WHEN THAT
HAPPENS.
UP THIS BILL WOULD OPEN A LINE
OF CREDIT FOR STUDENTS AT THE
CAMPUS BOOKSTORES AND ALLOW THEM
TO PURCHASE THE MATERIALS THAT
THEY NEED. IN ORDER TO SUCCEED
IN CLASS OUT THIS WOULD ALLOW
THEM TO NOT GET BEHIND IN CLASS
IT WOULD. GET RID OF THOSE
FINANCIAL WORRIES AND THAT
REALLY UNDUE STRESS FOR SOME
STUDENTS WERE WORKING JOBS OR
ALL THE DIFFERENT STRESSES THAT
COME WITH COLLEGE LIFE IN
ADDITION FINANCING THAT
EDUCATIONAL EXPERIENCE OUR
SYSTEM IS REALLY IN PERFECT BUT
EACH DAY WE HAVE TO TAKE STEPS
TO MAKE IT A LITTLE BIT BETTER.
THIS IS A SMALL STEP BUT I
THINK IT'S AN IMPORTANT ONE FOR
STUDENTS THAT WILL HELP
COUNTLESS UP. STUDENTS ACROSS
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES.
ALL OVER THE STATE.
THANK YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
NOPE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS.
I I WANT TO THANK THE STUDENTS.
AND MISTER PATTERSON FOR
BRINGING FORWARD WHAT I THINK IS
A VERY GOOD COMMON SENSE.
APPROACH.
AND DOESN'T LIKE THE STUDENTS
SAID THAT THIS WILL HELP.
STUDENTS HAVE MORE AXES
QUICKER.
TWO BOOKS THAT THEY NEED FOR
THEIR CLASSES ALSO.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR BRINGING
THAT'LL FOR A CRESCENTA AND ONCE
WE HAVE A QUORUM WILL TAKE A
CLOSER.
WE'LL GO TO ITEM NUMBER THREE
MISTER HARPER.
.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY ONE.
THAT'S ACTUALLY ITEM NUMBER
ELEVEN.
WELCOME MISTER HARPER.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS.
I WOULD LIKE TO START BY
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS
AND I THINK IT TO THE I
COMMITTEE FOUGHT FOR HEARING
THIS ISSUE.
THESE SET OF ISSUES WHICH I
CARE DEEPLY ABOUT TO MENTAL
HEALTH. EYES WILL A SUICIDE.
TODAY I'M HERE PRESENT AB TWENTY
NINE.
TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE WHICH
REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY AND COMMUNICABLE GE'S
AND REQUEST THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA AND CALIFORNIA'S
PRIVATE HIGHER LEARNING
INSTITUTIONS.
TO INCLUDE THE PHONE NUMBERS FOR
SUICIDE PREVENTION AND PUBLIC
SAFETY ON STUDENT IDENTIFICATION
CARDS.
COLLEGE STUDENTS ARE SUPPOSED TO
BE AN ENRICHING ENVIRONMENT FOR
STUDENTS
YET GOING TO COLLEGE CAN BE VERY
DIFFICULT FOR MANY STUDENTS
SINCE IS THE FIRST TIME THAT
MANY ARE OFTEN LIVING ON THEIR
OWN.
IN ADDITION TO THE STRESS OF
MAINTAINING A GOOD GPA AND BEING
ON THEIR OWN. MANY COLLEGE
STUDENTS CONTEND WITH THE HIGH
COST OF LIVING IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
SOME STUDENTS HAVE TROUBLE
PAYING THE RENT STRUGGLING WITH
FOOD AND SECURITY. OR EVEN BEING
ABLE FOUR TO COAT OUGHT TO BE
ABLE STAY WARM IN THE WINTER.
OTHER STUDENTS DEAL WITH THE
PAIN OF BEING A VICTIM OF A
CRIME ON CAMPUS.
TRAGICALLY MORE STATEMENT MORE
STUDENTS ARE FEELING THAT THE
PERMIT SOLUTION TO DEALING WITH
LIFE'S TEMPORARY PROBLEMS.
TO TAKE THEIR OWN LIFE.
SUICIDE IS CURRENTLY THE SECOND
MOST COMMON CAUSE OF DEATH AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS AGED TWENTY
FIVE TO THIRTY FOUR. AND THE
THIRD LEADING CAUSE OF DEATH
AMONG FIFTEEN TO TWENTY FOUR
YEAR OLDS.
BY INCLUDING EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
SERVICES AND PUBLIC SAFETY PHONE
NUMBERS ON STUDENT
IDENTIFICATION CARDS WE GET
EVERY COLLEGE STUDENT CALIFORNIA
PLACE TO TURN. WHEN THEY NEED
HELP.
THERE ARE TWO EFFECTIVE PHONE
NUMBER STUDENTS CAN USE TO HELP
GET.
.
TO HELP HANDLING THE STRESS OF
COLLEGE. AND OFTEN YOUNG LIFE.
FOR STUDENTS WHIP OUR PREFERRED
A TEXT ABOUT THEIR FEELINGS
THERE'S A CRISIS TEXT LINE.
WHICH IS A FREE CONTROVERSY LA
CONFIDENTIAL TWENTY FOUR HOUR
SUPPORT SERVICE THAT STUDENTS
CAN CONTACT ANYTIME VIA TEXT.
OFTEN THE PREFERRED A METHOD OF
COMMUNICATION AMONG MANY YOUNG
PEOPLE.
FOR THOSE WHO PREFER TO TALK ON
THE PHONE OLD SCHOOL LIKE
MYSELF.
THERE IS A NATIONAL SUICIDE
PREVENTION HOTLINE.
WHICH PROVIDES FREE AND
CONFIDENTIAL EMOTIONAL SUPPORT
TO PEOPLE IN SUICIDAL CRISIS OR
EMOTIONAL DISTRESS TWENTY FOUR
HOURS A DAY SEVEN DAYS A WEEK
ACROSS THE UNITED STATES.
IN ADDITION HAVING A PHONE
NUMBER CAMPUS POLICE OR A LOCAL
NON EMERGENCY NUMBER GIVES
STUDENTS A DIRECT LINE. TO
PROTECTION AND HELP WHENEVER
THEY NEED IT.
THIS BILL IS NEEDED SO STUDENTS
HAVE A VALUABLE RESOURCE TO TURN
TO WHEN THEY FEEL LIKE THEY HAVE
NO OTHER OPTIONS LEFT.
WITH ME HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE.
IS CORDONED AUDI OF THE AMERICAN
FEDERATION OF SUICIDE
PREVENTION.
AND DANIEL SABINO FROM THE
ASSOCIATION OF REGIONAL CENTER
AGENCIES THANK YOU FOR
CONSIDERATION.
OKAY.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS FOR THIS
OPPORTUNIST SPEAK ON THIS VERY
IMPORTANT BILL. THE AMERICAN
FOUNDATION FOR SUICIDE
PREVENTION IS THE NATION'S
LARGEST FOUNDATION DEALING WITH
SUICIDE PREVENTION.
AND ALSO THE LARGEST FUNDER OF
RESEARCH.
S. HE SAID I'M A BOARD MEMBER OF
THE GREATER SAN FRANCISCO BAY
AREA CHAPTER OF A FSP.
I ALSO SERVE ON TO THEIR
NATIONAL COUNCILS.
I'VE STATE SUPERINTENDENT OF
PUBLIC INSTRUCTION STUDENT
MENTAL HEALTH POLICY WORK GROUP.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA AT
SAN FRANCISCO'S
OPPRESSION CENTER ADVISORY
BOARD.
AND THREE COUNTY SUICIDE
PREVENTION COMMITTEES.
FOURTEEN YEARS AGO THIS COMING
FALL THE SOCK COMING OCTOBER.
MY DAUGHTER A COLLEGE FRESHMAN
TOOK HER LIFE.
AMANDA HAD BEEN SUFFERING FROM
DEPRESSION SINCE THE AGE OF TEN.
AND SOMETHING HAPPENED IN HER
FRESHMAN YEAR.
THAT.
DELGADO TO TAKE HER LIFE.
I TRULY BELIEVE ALTHOUGH I CAN'T
UNEQUIVOCALLY SUPPORT IT.
BUT I DO BELIEVE THAT HAD SHE
HAD INFORMATION ON HER STUDENT
D CARD.
FOR RESOURCES
THAT IT WOULD OF POLICE PROVIDED
THE OPPORTUNITY.
FOR HER TO REACH OUT TO GET HELP
IN THAT TIME OF CRISIS.
ELSE WE'VE JUST HEARD. THAT
THERE IS A TREMENDOUS NUMBER OF
SUICIDES AMONG COLLEGE STUDENTS
SUSPEND THEIR SECOND LEADING
CAUSE OF DEATH FOR QUITE AWHILE
NOW.
SUICIDE ITSELF NATIONALLY IS A
TEMPLATING CAUSE OF DEATH THAT
HAS BEEN SO.
FOR THE LAST DECADE.
AND IT'S INCREASED EVERY YEAR.
WE NEED TO DO SOMETHING.
TO TURN THAT AROUND.
I DO BELIEVE WHOLE HEARTEDLY
THAT THIS IS A STEP IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION TO PROVIDE THOSE
RESOURCES.
STUDENTS WILL BE ABLE TO CALL
THE ONE EIGHT HUNDRED TWO SEVEN
THREE TALK NUMBER THE NATIONAL
LIFELINE NUMBER.
IT WILL REVERT BACK TO THE
CLOSEST CRISIS CENTER.
FOR THE NUMBER THAT THEY CALLED
FOR.
SO IF THEY'RE IN AND NINE ONE
SIX AREA CODE. IT'LL COME BACK
TO THE CRISIS CENTER HERE.
OKAY IF THEY'RE IN THE BAY AREA
IT'LL GO BACK TO THAT CRISIS
AND.
STUDENT IDENTIFICATION CARD FOR
X..
STUDENTS ARE VERY EXTENSIVELY
USED ON CAMPUSES VARIETY OF
THINGS SUCH AS FOOD PURCHASES
DISCOUNT TICKETS LIBRARY IT'S
REALLY THERE. THEIR LIFE LINK.
AND IS A CENTRAL ELEMENT TO
THEIR.
STUDENT CAMPUS LIFE.
BY HAVING THOSE PHONE NUMBERS
NONE THE CRISIS FLANK.
READILY AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
CAN HELP SAVE LIVES.
PLEASE DON'T LET THIS BE A
MISSED OPPORTUNITY TO SAY ONE OF
THOSE LIES
WE DO KNOW FOR EVERY LIFE THAT'S
LOS TO SUICIDE THAT THERE IS AT
LEAST TWENTY FIVE ATTEMPTS.
THANK YOU.
DANIEL SO THE NO ASSOCIATION OF
REGIONAL CENTER AGENCIES
CALIFORNIA'S TWENTY ONE
NONPROFIT REGIONAL CENTERS AMONG
OTHER THINGS COORDINATE SERVICES
FOR OVER THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND
INDIVIDUALS WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES. INCLUDING
HONORABLE CHAIR IN YOUR DISTRICT
A INLAND REGIONAL CENTER.
.
REALLY WORTH NOTING THAT A
RECENT STUDIES ON THIS ARE
STILL.
DIGGING IN TO THE QUESTION OF
THE CORRELATIONS THAT RELATE TO
TO DEVELOP ALISON YLIDES AND
BULLYING BUT. LOST TWENTY
THIRTEEN OF.
PUBLICATION IN RESEARCHING
AUTISM SPECTRUM DISORDERS FINDS
A MASSIVELY HIGHER LIKELIHOOD OF
CHILDREN SPECIFICALLY WITH
AUTISM.
HAVING SUICIDAL IDEATION OR
ATTEMPTS
A THE CORAL ITS THAT. COME INTO
PLAY HERE INCLUDE AMONG OTHER
THINGS BULLYING AND WELL WE KNOW
THAT BULLYING DOESN'T STOP ONCE
YOU LEAVE.
ELEMENTARY SCHOOL IT CAN
PURCHASE FOR YEARS AND THE
CAUSES OF THAT.
I DON'T CHANGE EITHER PULLING ON
COLLEGE CAMPUSES THEREFORE IS
EMINENTLY REASONABLE TO ASSUME
AS.
A LIKELY BECAUSE OF THE
INCREASED RISK OF SUICIDE FOR AN
INDIVIDUAL WITH DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
SO TO SEE SOMEONE WITH A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY IN OUR
SYSTEM MANAGED TO ATTAIN COLLEGE
ENTRANCE
BUT REALLY ONE OF THE GOLD
STANDARDS OF A SUCCESSFUL
OUTCOME TO SEE SOMEONE AND UP IN
A COLLEGE EXPERIENCE.
TO HAVE THEM AT THAT HEIGHTENED
RISK AND NOT HAVE AN OPTION.
A PLACE TO TURN TO SUCH AS A
PHONE NUMBER ON A STUDENT ID
THAT PRETTY MUCH EVERY STUDENT
CARRIES ALMOST ALL THE TIME.
EYES AGAIN A HUGE MISSED
OPPORTUNITY WERE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL BECAUSE IT
VERY SIMPLY CRATES ACCESS TO
THAT.
OPPORTUNITY TO REACH OUT.
LIKE IT'S ON A PERSONAL LEVEL A
DEAR FRIEND OF MINE. A KILLED
HIMSELF SEVERAL YEARS AGO AND
THERE WERE A NUMBER OF ATTEMPTS
PRIOR. AND THERE'S ALWAYS PART
OF ME THAT WONDERS IF.
HE HAD HAD.
A A NUMBER.
IF THERE IS SOMETHING MORE
READILY ACCESSIBLE FOR HIM.
WOULD HE STILL BE HERE.
IT'S A QUESTION THAT I HOPE THAT
NOBODY AT ALL TO EVER HAVE HOUSE
HAS TO ASK AND.
I THINK THIS BILL IS AN
EXCELLENT OPPORTUNITY TO HELP
CREATE THAT OPPORTUNITY FOR
FOLKS TO REACH OUT IN THAT
MOMENT OF CRISIS.
RICHARD STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON DOCTOR IOSCO FOR
COULD I'M A PEDIATRICIAN SAN
FRANCISCO SPEAKING FOR AP
CALIFORNIA THAT REPRESENTS FIVE
THOUSAND PEDIATRICIANS ACROSS
THE STATE. AYE WE STAND IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THANK YOU.
EIGHT YOUR HONOR ADDRESS ON
BEHALF OF THE STEINBERG
INSTITUTE. A NONPROFIT DEDICATED
TO THE ADVANCEMENT OF SOUND
PUBLIC POLICY IN THE AREA BRING
HEALTH WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
IT'S QUIRK SILVA.
GONNA BE MISSED TALKIE TODAY NO
I I DO LIKE THIS BILL IT'S IT'S.
YOU KNOW NOT A MASSIVE
UNDERTAKING BUT IT'S AN
IMPORTANT ONE AND SOMETIMES IT'S
JUST THE INFORMATION AND AS YOU.
NOTE UP WE HAVE MANY STUDENTS
WHO LEAVE HOME FOR THE FIRST
TIME IN CAN FILL VERY VERY
ISOLATED AND. WITH THAT CAN COME
DEPRESSION ANOTHER THING SO
BEING ABLETO HAVE SOME TYPE OF
INFORMATION THAT THEY'RE USING
REGULARLY I THINK IS A REALLY
GOOD. A WAY FOR THEM TO KNOW
THAT THERE'S.
UP HELP OUT THERE.
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING UP.
NO OTHER COMMENTS.
MISTER HARPER WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND
THAT IN ANTICIPATION OF OTHERS
MAY HAVE QUESTIONS I THINK IT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW. AYE THAT THIS
BILL WOULD NOT.
REQUIRES THE REPLACEMENT OF
EXISTING STOCK OR IF THERE WAS A
STOCKPILE OF PREPRINTED PARTS OF
ID'S. UP THIS SET A BILL HAS
BEEN.
ARE WRITTEN IN A WAY TO BE ABLE
TO ACCOMMODATE THIS THIS IS
GOING FORWARD I INTENDED AS A
STEP TO GO POOR BUT.
YOUR IDEAS ON YOU ESPECIALLY AS
A STUDENT UP ALL THE TIME.
AND BEING ABLE TO HAVE THAT
INFORMATION RIGHT AT THE
FINGERTIPS.
AS A SAID BOTH TO BE ABLE TO
TALK AND TO BE ABLE TO TAX.
I THINK IS ONE OF THE MOST
IMPORTANT WAYS WE CAN OUTREACH
WELL IT WON'T SOLVE EVERY
SUICIDE. OR POTENTIAL MENTAL
HEALTH PROBLEM.
I THINK IT WILL DEFINITELY HELP
I IN TERMS OF A STATE WITH THE
FORTY MILLION PEOPLE. AND WITH
THE LARGEST UNIVERSITY SYSTEMS
ARE IN THE ENTIRE WORLD.
THAT.
WE CAN OUTREACH TO A TO SO MANY
PEOPLE AND TO BE ABLE HOW THAT
RESOURCE AVAILABLE. IT ALSO
DOESN'T SUPPLANT IF THERE'S AN
EXISTING HOTLINE THAT SPECIFIC
TO THAT CAMPUS THAT THEY ALREADY
HAVE. THIS DOES NOT DISTURB THAT
EXISTING RELATIONSHIP FOR A
EXISTING SITUATION AYE IT ALL SO
I WOULD LIKE TO URGE.
MEMBERS OF THE COMMITTEE TO
PLEASE US SUPPORT THIS EFFORT.
BY AND LET'S MOVE FORWARD IN
TERMS OF KEEPING PEOPLE IN TOUCH
AND BEING ABLE TO ADDRESS THE
SITUATION. OF SUICIDE AMONG
COLLEGE STUDENTS THANK YOU THANK
YOU MISS HARPER AYE I THINK I
MAY HAVE FAILED DUE TO ASK THE
QUESTION THAT YOU YOU HAD AGREED
TO THE AMENDMENTS IS PRETTY I
SAID AND AND. INITIALLY THAT I
THINK YOU THE AND I VERY MUCH
STRONGLY SUPPORT THIS BILL.
HAVEN'T BEEN A COLLEGE STUDENT
AND WITNESS.
YOU KNOW THE THE HARD TIMES
THAT SOME OF MY FELLOW STUDENTS.
I HAD
AND WE'VE HEARD FROM STUDENTS AT
HOW DIFFICULT.
IN A LACK OF A LITTLE HEALTH
FACILITIES AND KNOWING OF
PERSONALLY FAMILY MEMBERS WHO.
HAD A VERY DIFFICULT TIME AS
MISS QUIRK SILVA SAID OF BEING
FAR AWAY FROM HOME AND ISOLATED.
I THINK THIS IS A A GREAT BILL
THAT YOU BROUGHT FORWARD SOME
VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT IT. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIRMAN MISTER
CHAIRMAN MANIC ADDITIONAL
COMMENT IF I ALSO WANT TO POINT
OUT THAT THIS ONE EIGHT HUNDRED
TWO SEVEN THREE TALK.
NUMBER AS WELL AS THAT THE TEXT
LINE.
IS AVAILABLE FOR FOLKS YOU DON'T
HAVE TO BE IN CRISIS TO USE THAT
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT A FRIEND
A FAMILY MEMBER. CALL AND GET
ADVICE THANK YOU.
WILL HOLD IT AND.
WILL HAVE THE VOTE WHEN WE HAVE
A COURT THANK YOU AGAIN MISTER
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU.
FILE ITEM NUMBER FOUR. OF THE
ARROW.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FORTY ONE.
WELCOME.
YOU MAY BEGIN.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I PLEASED TO PRESENT AB
TWENTY FORTY ONE. WHICH URGES
THE REGENTS OF THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA.
TO REQUIRE THE OFFICE OF THE
CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICER OF YOU
SEE INVESTMENTS WHICH MANAGES
OVER A HUNDRED AND SEVEN POINT
TWO BILLION DOLLARS.
TO ADOPT INTERNAL AND EXTERNAL
POLICIES AND INVESTMENT
STRATEGIES THAT ENCOURAGE
DIVERSITY IN THE HIRING OF STAFF
IN THE SELECTION OF INVESTMENT
PARTNERS. WERE YOU SEE
INVESTMENT.
ACTS AS A LIMITED PARTNER
PARTNER INVESTOR IN CAPITAL
INVENTOR CAPITAL PRIVATE EQUITY
LEVERAGED BUYOUTS AND OTHER
FUNDS.
FIRST I WANT OF KNOWLEDGE ALL
BUT THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
HAS DONE TO PROMOTE DIVERSITY
AND INCLUSION AMONGST ITS
STUDENT POPULATION EMPLOYEES AND
FACULTY.
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
CAMPUS LEVEL IS EXCELLING AT
STUDENT DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
PRO PROGRAMS
FIVE CAMPUSES ARE RECOGNIZED AS
HISPANIC SERVING INSTITUTIONS.
ANY TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN A
NUMBER OF UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA CAMPUSES RECEIVED THE
HIGHER EDUCATION EXCELLENCE IN
DIVERSITY AWARD FROM INSIGHT IN
INTO INTO DIVERSITY MAGAZINE.
DIVERSITY IN CAMPUS EMPLOYMENT
AS HAS ALSO BEEN A FOCUS AT THE
UNIVERSITY AND IN ITS TWO
THOUSAND FIFTEEN ACCOUNTABILITY
REPORT.
THE UNIVERSITY ACKNOWLEDGES THAT
THE RATIO OF MINORITY STAFF IS
LOWER AMONG SENIOR POSITIONS AND
THE PROPORTION OF MINORITY
ACADEMICS IS HIGHEST IN THE NON
FACULTY POSITIONS.
AFRICAN AMERICAN AND LATINOS
MAKE UP TWELVE PERCENT OF THE
MANAGERS AND SENIOR
PROFESSIONALS ACROSS ALL
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA. FOR
NEW CAMPUSES AND JUST SIX POINT
SIX PERCENT OF NON FACULTY
ACADEMICS.
FROM LOOKING AT THE UC
INVESTMENTS ONLINE STAFF DIRECT
DIRECTORY IT APPEARS AT UC
INVESTMENTS EMPLOYS
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY THREE PEOPLE
NOW IT'S NOT SCIENTIFIC. BUT IT
TELLS A STORY.
OUT OF THOSE SIXTY THREE PEOPLE
FORTY JOBS ARE PROFESSIONAL OR
EXECUTIVE TYPE POSITIONS WITH
SENIOR MANAGER DIRECTOR OFFICER
CHIEF IN THE JOB TITLE.
JUST SIX OF THE FORTY EXECUTIVE
LEVEL JOBS ARE FILLED BY WOMEN.
THIRTEEN WOMEN WORK AT THE UC
INVESTMENTS IN TOTAL.
AND THERE ARE FEW
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES LIKE
VENUS ARE AFRICAN AMERICANS THAT
WORK THERE.
CLEARLY YOU SEE INVESTMENTS DOES
NOT DIFFER DRAMATICALLY FROM THE
UNIVERSITY CAMPUS AND FACULTY
EMPLOYMENT CHARACTERISTICS AND
BOTH SHOW CHALLENGES TO
IMPROVING REPRESENTATION FROM
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
GROUPS.
HOWEVER I WANT TO ACKNOWLEDGE
THAT YOU SEE INVESTMENT DOES
HAVE SOME VERY POSITIVE ELEMENTS
TO ITS INVESTING STRATEGY.
THEIR SUSTAINABLE FRAMEWORK
SHOWS THAT THEY ENVIRONMENT AND
SOCIAL FACTORS CAN BE SIX
SUCCESSFULLY CONSIDERED IN ITS
INVESTMENT PHILOSOPHY.
AND AND AND A WOMAN INVESTMENT
FELLOW REPRESENT TO YOU SEE
INVESTMENTS IN THE THIRTY
PERCENT COALITION WHICH
INDICATES THAT THEY GRASP THE
INHERENT VALUE INTO BURKE AND
GENDER DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE
BOARDS.
IN FACT THE UC REGENTS RECOGNIZE
IN THE RECOGNIZING THE
IMPORTANCE OF CORPORATE
DIVERSITY ARE PARTNERING WITH
CAL STIRS ON THE CALIFORNIA
INITIATIVE. WHICH WILL ENCOURAGE
FIFTY COMPANIES HEADQUARTERED IN
CALIFORNIA WITHOUT WOMEN ON
THEIR CORPORATE BOARDS TO
DIVORCE. DIVERSIFY THEIR BOARD
MEMBERSHIP.
WHICH IS WHY IT IS SURPRISING
THAT YOU SEE INVESTMENTS HAS NOT
YET ADOPTED AN INVESTMENT
STRATEGY THATIMPRINT EMBRACES
DIVERSITY. INTERNALLY NOR WORKS
TO ENCOURAGE ITS INVESTMENT
PARTNERS TO DO SO.
THIS IS MARKEDLY DIFFERENT FROM
THE INVESTMENT STRATEGY.
AB YOU SEE INVESTMENT SISTER
ENTITIES WITH DECADES OF
INVESTMENT MANAGEMENT AND
EXPERIENCE CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS.
THEY SHOULD BE LAUDED FOR THEIR
EXPANSIVE INTERNAL DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION PROGRAMS BREAKING DOWN
BARRIERS IN THE INVESTMENT WORLD
TO WOMEN AND UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES.
THEY'RE LEADING THE WAY.
THEY HAVE SPONSORED CORPORATE
DIVERSITY BOB FUND MANAGERS AND
EXECUTIVE TEAM MEMBERS THROUGH
THEIR OWN HIRING PROCESS AS
WELL.
IF CALPERS AND CAL STIRS OPERATE
WELL THEY OPERATE IS A FUND OF
FUNDS PLACING INVESTMENTS IN AN
ARRAY OF INVESTMENT TYPES AND
WITH DIFFERENT TYPES OF FUND
MANAGERS.
AB TWENTY FORTY ONE URGES THE
REGENTS TO HAVE THE.
CHAU MIMIC THE EMERGING FUND
MANAGER PROGRAMS CALPERS AND CAL
STIRS.
DIVERSITY IS IMPORTANT FOR HIM
IN INVESTMENT PERFORMANCE BOTH
BURKE FOR BETTER FINANCIAL
OUTCOMES AND FOR IMMEDIATE
RATING REST BOTH OF WHICH ARE
REALLY IMPORTANT. A BOMB IN
INVESTMENT.
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN UC
VENTURES A COMPONENT OF YOU SEE
INVESTMENT PUBLISHED ITS PROGRAM
OVERVIEW INDICATING THE VENTURE
CAPITAL FIRMS IT'D PARTNERED
WITH AS OVER HERE AND CHECK YES
CAN I INTERRUPT YOU FOR A SECOND
SO THAT WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM ABSOLUTELY.
THANK YOU.
MEDINA PRESENT.
BAKER ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
CHAVEZ IRWIN KILEY STONE.
LOW PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
SANTIAGO.
WEBER.
WE ARE NOW IN.
A QUORUM PRESENT THEY CHECK YOU
THINK IT WAS GOV WE ARE
ABSOLUTELY.
SO THE TREND AMONG LIMITED
PARTNER INVESTORS HAS BEEN TO
ENCOURAGE MORE DIVERSE
GOVERNANCE BODIES IN INVESTMENT
MANAGERS OR CORPORATE BOARDS FOR
EARLY STAGE STARTUPS TO PUBLIC
COMPANY BOOK COMPANY BOARDS THIS
IS BECAUSE. DIVERSITY DRIVES
BETTER CORPORATE PERFORMANCE AND
THAT'S WHAT WORK WERE ALL ABOUT
IN TWO THOUSAND SIXTEEN YOU SEE
VENTURES A COMPONENT OF YOU SEE
INVESTMENTS PUBLISHED ITS
PROGRAM OVERVIEW. INDICATING THE
VENTURE CAPITAL FIRMS AT A
PARTNER WITH AS STRATEGIC
PARTNERS AND IN A LOCAL FUND
STRATEGY. THE PRINCIPLES OF EACH
OF THOSE FUNDS WERE PUBLISHED IN
THE UC VENTURES PROGRAM OVERVIEW
AND A HUNDRED PERCENT ARE MALE.
SURELY THE REGION'S CAN REQUEST
THE SAME LEVEL OF ACTIVE
COMMITMENT TO DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION WITHIN YOU SEE ITS OWN
INVESTMENT OFFICE AS IT DOES TO
COMPANY'S HEADQUARTERS IN
CALIFORNIA THROUGHOUT THE.
CALIFORNIA INITIATIVE AND SURELY
THE REGION'S CAN REQUEST THAT
YOU SEE INVESTMENTS LAUNCH
EMERGING FUND MANAGER PROGRAMS
EQUAL TO HIS SISTER FINDS
CALPERS AND CAL STIRS EFFORT.
WITH ME HERE IN SUPPORT OF AB
TWENTY FORTY ONE TODAY SHARON
WINE BAR A PART PARTNER AT A
WOMAN FOUNDED. SAN FRANCISCO
BASED VENTURE CAPITAL FIRM AND
JESSICA STRAUSS
PAST VICE PRESIDENT OF THE
NATIONAL VENTURE CAPITAL
ASSOCIATION AND A CURRENT COUGH
KAUFMAN FELLOW.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE BEGIN. SIR THANK YOU
MISTER CHAIRMAN ASSEMBLY MEMBERS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO.
I HAVE PARTICIPATED IN THE
START UP IN VENTURE CAPITAL
ECOSYSTEM FOR THE LAST TWENTY
YEARS AS AN EXECUTIVE A C. E. O.
OF ENTRY PAVEL INVESTOR IN A
PRIVATE INVESTOR MY NAME IS
SHARON ONE BAR.
AND LAST WEEK TECHCRUNCH WHICH
IS A LEADING BLOG ON TECHNOLOGY
INVENTOR CAPITAL PUBLISHED AN OP
ED THAT I WROTE WITH ADVICE TO
LIMITED PARTNERS INVESTORS LIKE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA.
INVESTMENT OFFICE ON HOW THEY
CAN.
TAKE SIMPLE STEPS TO INCREASE
THE DIVERSITY IN BOTH THE
MANAGERS THAT THEY BACK THE
PARTNERS THAT THEY WORK WITH AS
WELL AS THE COMPANIES IN WHICH
THEY INVEST.
TWENTY YEARS AGO VENTURE CAPITAL
WAS A VERY SMALL CLOSED CLUB.
OF A A LIMITED HAND FULL OF
GUYS MAINLY WHO'D GONE TO
STANFORD WORKING ON SAN TOLL
ROAD INVESTING IN A SMALL GROUP
OF ENTREPRENEURS.
IN THE SEMICONDUCTOR BUSINESS
THAT'S WHY WE'RE CALLED AND
SILICON VALLEY.
BUT TODAY THE VENTURE CAPITAL
BUSINESS AND ENTREPRENEURIAL
BUSINESS HAS CHANGED
DRAMATICALLY AND IT REFLECTS A
MUCH BROADER SWATH OF AMERICAN
ENTERPRISE IN FACT VENTURE
BACKED COMPANIES.
ARE RESPONSIBLE FOR TWENTY
PERCENT OF THE GDP IN THE UNITED
STATES TODAY SO IT REALLY
TOUCHES EVERY ASPECT OF OUR
LIVES.
AND VC BACKED COMPANIES.
ARE LEADING NOT ONLY IN IN NEW
TECHNOLOGIES AND CHANGING
MARKETS BUT THEY'RE LEADING IN
DIVERSITY.
TODAY.
SEVEN HUNDRED ENTREPRENEURS FROM
SOME OF THE BEST START UPS IN
THE U. S..
ANNOUNCED THAT THEY WOULD NOT
TAKE VENTURE CAPITAL INVESTMENT
FROM FIRMS THAT WERE MADE UP
ONLY OF WHITE MEN.
THEY WANT AND THESE
ENTREPRENEURS ARE NOT ALL WOMEN
NOT ALL PEOPLE OF COLOR THERE.
EVERY KIND OF ENTREPRENEUR.
BUT THEY WANT TO SEE THE
PARTNERS WHO ARE INVESTING WITH
THEM AND HOPE IN THEIR COMPANIES
GROW REFLECT THE DIVERSITY OF
THE MARKETS THAT THEY SERVE.
AND THIS IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA INVESTMENT MANAGER
PARTNER LIST IS EXCLUSIVELY
WHITE MEN TODAY'S SO THEY'RE CUT
OFF FROM OF THE IS BEST
ENTREPRENEURS.
IN ADDITION AS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
COUNTY ARE SAID.
THE SISTER ORGANIZATIONS CALPERS
AND HOLSTERS HAVE REALLY LED THE
WAY FOR SHOWING HOW LIMITED
PARTNERS CAN CREATE PROGRAMS
WITHOUT IMPLEMENTING QUOTAS.
THAT LEAD TO NOT ONLY GREAT
DIVERSITY IN THEIR INVESTMENT
PARTNERS AND COMPANIES BUT GREAT
RETURNS.
AND IT'S REALLY THE THE SEEKING
OF RETURNS THAT HOPES DRIVE UP
THIS CHANGE THAT'S HAPPENING SO
WE URGE THE UNIVERSE UNIVERSITY
OF CALIFORNIA TO ADOPT THE
MEASURES THAT THE ASSEMBLY
WOMAN.
IS PROPOSING TO REALLY GIVE
THEM ACCESS TO THE BEST KINDS OF
COMPANIES AND TO HELP REFLECT
THE ENVIRONMENT THAT WE'RE ALL
LIVING IN.
THANK YOU.
AT THANK YOU TO THE COMMITTEE
MY NAME IS JESSICA STRAUSS.
I HAVE SPENT THE PAST TEN YEARS
OF THE INTERSECTION OF PUBLIC
POLICY AND INNOVATION WORKING IN
THE US CONGRESS AND.
MORE RECENTLY WITH THE NATIONAL
VENTURE CAPITAL ASSOCIATION THE
TRADE GROUP REPRESENTING U. S.
VENTURE CAPITAL INVESTORS. WHERE
WE WORK TOGETHER IN TWENTY
FIFTEEN TO LAUNCH THE FIRST
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION
INITIATIVE FOR THE VENTURE
INDUSTRY?
AND THEN WHEN WE DID THAT.
WE PARTNERED TOGETHER WITH
FORTY VENTURE CAPITAL FIRMS MANY
OF THEM HERE IN CALIFORNIA TO
LAUNCH A DIVERSITY PLEDGE.
TO PLEDGE TO DO MORE TO CHANGE
HIRING PRACTICES WITHIN VENTURE
FIRMS AND TO BE TRANSPARENT
ABOUT ON THE DIVERSITY
STATISTICS WITHIN THE FIRMS AND
ITS THAT SPIRIT THAT REALLY
GUIDES.
THIS BILL A. B. ON TWENTY FORTY
ONE.
SPONSORED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CABALLERO WHICH ADDRESSES A KEY
CHALLENGE THAT'S FACING OUR
VIBRANT INNOVATION ECOSYSTEM
HERE IN CALIFORNIA WHICH IS THE
LACK OF DIVERSITY AND VENTURE.
AND MORE BROADLY THE CRITICAL
ROLE THAT OUR PUBLIC
INSTITUTIONS PLAY IN ADVANCING
DIVERSITY AND VENTURE CAPITAL.
BUDGET CAPITALIST HAVE THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF STEWARDING
INSTITUTIONAL CAPITAL IN ORDER
TO BENEFIT OF. THE STATE IN THIS
CASE THE UC SYSTEM ITS
CONSTITUENTS THROUGH ECONOMIC
GROWTH AND JOB CREATION AND
VENTURE CAPITALISTS ARE VERY FEW
IN NUMBER THEIR NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY VENTURE CAPITAL FIRMS.
IN THE U. S. AND.
ONLY ELEVEN PERCENT OF THE
PARTNERS OF THOSE FIRMS ARE
WOMEN AND FEWER THAN TWO PERCENT
ARE PEOPLE OF COLOR.
THEREFORE WITH THIS LEVEL OF
CONCENTRATION IT'S THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE LIMITED
PARTNERS TO LEARN HOW TO DO MORE
TO SUPPORT THE INCREASED
DIVERSITY OF THE INNOVATION
ECOSYSTEM.
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION AS
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO SAID.
DRIVE INNOVATION BOTH THROUGH
THE DEVELOPMENT OF NEW PRODUCTS
AND SERVICES ANSWER INCREASE
REVENUE.
SO IT'S IT'S MY BELIEF THAT ON
THE PATH TOWARD CHANGE IS
PARTNERSHIP
AND THAT'S WHAT THIS BILL AB
TWENTY FORTY ONE REALLY SUCCEEDS
IN DOING.
YOU SEE VENTURES ON THE BROADER
UC SYSTEM CAN DO MUCH MORE TO
TAKE ACTION TO ENSURE THAT OUR
DYNAMIC AND DIVERSE CALIFORNIA
INNOVATION ECOSYSTEM. BENEFITS
YOU SEE STAKEHOLDERS TO A
GREATER EXTENT.
AND IT IS ABOUT.
NOTION THAT YOU SEE VENTURES
CAN CAN DO MORE TO BOTH BENEFIT.
I'M COULD BE VENTURE CAPITALISTS
OF THE QUALIFIED MEN AND WOMEN.
COLOR WHO COULD BE MANAGING THE.
UC'S INSTITUTIONAL CAPITAL TO
BENEFIT AND THE STATE AND ITS
CONSTITUENTS.
SO I WOULD ARGUE THAT THE
CALIFORNIA STATE ASSEMBLY HAS AN
ENORMOUS OPPORTUNITY CALIFORNIA
IS THE HEART OF THE VENTURE
CAPITAL ECOSYSTEM IN THE WORLD.
THE STATE VENTURE CAPITAL FIRMS
IN THE STATE MANAGE MORE
INSTITUTIONAL CAPITAL THEN FIRMS
IN ANY OTHER STATE AND DEPLOY
MORE INSTITUTIONAL CAPITAL TO
START UPS IN THE STATE.
THEREFORE BY TAKING ACTION AND.
MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS BILL I
THINK WE HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO
TAKE THE RIGHT COMMON SENSE
STEPS.
TO WORK IN PARTNERSHIP WITH UC
VENTURES AND ITS UNDERLYING
PORTFOLIO TOWARD GREATER
DIVERSITY AND INCLUSION.
SO.
MATT ASK YOU I I BELIEVE I SAID
AT THE BEGINNING TWO MINUTES TO
WITNESSES THAT I DID HAVE MY
TIMER HERE BUT I.
THANK YOU.
FOR THAT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MISS
GOVERNOR OR WE HAVE WITNESSES
AND.
TWEETERS.
WINNERS COME ON UP.
MISTER CHAIR AND MEMBERS JASON
MURPHY ON BEHALF UNIVERSAL
CALIFORNIA WE ARE NOT OPPOSED
THIS BILL.
.
WELL GUESS WE ARE TWEENER IN THE
GREATEST SINCE THE WORD.
WE DO APPRECIATE THE
OPPORTUNITY TO BE HEARD THEY
TALK ABOUT THIS IMPORTANT TOPIC.
AND ARE I THINK.
LOOK FORWARD THIRTEEN TO HAVE
THIS BE A CONVERSATION STARTER
FOR US WITH RESPECT TO. THESE
IMPORTANT ISSUES IN FACT I THINK
IN IN LIGHT OF THE. SIGNIFICANT
ISSUES WE FACE HERE.
WE WANT TO BRING OUR KEY FOLKS
FROM THE UC OFFICE OF THE CIO
HERE TODAY TO SPEAK WITH YOU
DIRECTLY ABOUT SOME OF THE
ACTIVITIES THAT ARE. UNDER WAY
WITHIN THAT OFFICE AND I LIKE TO
TRANSFERRED OVER FIGHT COULD.
THE BALANCE OF MY TIME TO MY
COLLEAGUE.
ARTICLE MARRIES FROM THE OC I
WAS OFFICE HE'S A CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER THE FURTHER
SHARE SOME OF THOSE PERSPECTIVES
AND VIEWPOINTS.
THANK YOU AN APOLOGY TO HAVE MY
BACK TO YOU BUT.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MARROW
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CABALLERO. CHAIR
MEDINA COMMITTEE MEMBER STAFF.
WE APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY
COME AND TALK TO YOU ABOUT AB
TWO ZERO FOUR ONE.
MY NAME'S ARTHUR THE BETA
DIMINISH I AM THE CHIEF
OPERATING OFFICER OF WHAT I'LL
CALL YOU SEE INVESTMENTS.
I LIKE START TO BEGIN.
SAY THAT WE ARE STRONGLY IN
SUPPORT OF DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION NOT SIMPLY AS IT
PERTAINS TO OUR OFFICE BUT AS
THE INDUSTRY AS A WHOLE.
SO WHO IS ARE OFFICE WE MANAGE A
HUNDRED EIGHTEEN BILLION DOLLARS
ON BEHALF OF OUR PENSIONERS ARE
RETIREMENT SAVERS. ARE FIFTY
SEVEN HUNDRED ENDOWMENTS AS WELL
AS OUR TEN CAMPUSES
AND FIVE MEDICAL CENTERS.
OUR STAFF IS SIXTY PEOPLE
TO BE VERY CLEAR WE ARE SMALL
THAT'S BY DESIGN.
WE.
.
GIVING CREDIT TO MISS CABALLERO
WE ARE FIFTY THREE PERCENT
UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITIES BUT
THE BALANCE THE STRONG BALANCE
OF THAT. WOULD BE ASIAN AND
PACIFIC ISLANDERS.
BUT ALSO LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT.
OR HIRING PRACTICES VERY MUCH
ALIGNED WE ARE PART OF THE UC
OFFICE OF THE PRESIDENT IT'S OR
HIRING PRACTICES ALIGNED WITH
OUR HUMAN RESOURCES TEAM WHO'S
RESPONSIBLE FOR. POLICY AND
PRACTICE AS IT PERTAINS TO.
HIRING AND DIVERSITY IN THE
DIVERSITY OF POOLS.
I'D LIKE TO JUST HAVE AND I KNOW
MY TIME IS LIMITED BUT I'D LIKE
TO HAND THIS OUT AND AGAIN THANK
YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER COVER YOUR
FOR POINTING IT OUT. BACK IN
TWENTY FIFTEEN.
WE CAME OUT WITH OUR
SUSTAINABILITY FRAMEWORK.
OUR CHIEF INVESTMENT OFFICER
JAGDEEP SING THE CHAIR.
STARTED ALMOST FOUR YEARS TO THE
DATE AND WITHIN A YEAR HE HAD
WORKED WITH UC REGENTS TO.
BASICALLY COME UP WITH THE
SUSTAINABILITY FRAMEWORK.
I AM INTERESTED TIME I'LL JUST
POINT OUT PAGE TWELVE VERY
CLEARLY.
POINTS OUT DIVERSITY AS A KEY
VALUE.
PACIFIC CLEARLY SAY.
DIVERSITY ENHANCES ECONOMIC
SOCIAL AND ENVIRONMENTAL
OUTCOMES FOR BUSINESS AND
SOCIETY.
THAT IS AN INTERNAL VIEW OF WHAT
WE DO EXTERNALLY. AS POINTED OUT
BY ASSEMBLY PERSON COVER EUROPE
WE WORK WITH
THE CALIFORNIA COALITION WE ARE
ON THE THIRTY PERCENT.
WORKING VERY CLOSELY WITH THEM
IN AN INTERESTING STAT IS IN
THEIR WORK SINCE TWENTY TWELVE.
HUNDRED AND FIFTY WOMEN IN
COMPANIES THEY'VE ENGAGE WITH
HAVE NOW BEEN ELECTED TO THAT
BOARD.
PROXY VOTING IS SOMETHING WE
DON'T OFTEN TALK ABOUT BUT I
WANNA SPEND A MINUTE BECAUSE
YOU'RE ALL ELECTED OFFICIALS AND
YOU GET YOUR OWN CONSTITUENTS TO
COME A REMIND YOU KNOW YOU ONLY
HAVE TWO MINUTES SO I'LL BE
QUICK. WE OWN FIFTY FIVE BILLION
DOLLARS THE PUBLIC EQUITY.
EACH OF THOSE
SHARES GIVE US ABILITY TO VOTE.
SO IT'S INCREDIBLY IMPORTANT FOR
US IN INSTITUTIONAL INVESTORS TO
VOTE PROPERLY.
WE VOTE WITH AN INSTITUTION CALL
I ASSESS WHO MANAGES OUR PROXY
VOTING.
AND WE USE A WHAT'S CALLED SR I
SUSTAINABLE.
INVESTMENT FRAMEWORK
AND WHAT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
OF THAT IS THAT IN THIS YEAR
PROXY SEASON IS COMING UP
THEY'VE CHANGED THE WAY THEY
VOTED. FOR BOARDS
SO IF THERE'S NOT A WOMEN.
AND UNDERREPRESENTED MINORITY
AND THIRTY PERCENT ON THAT BOARD
THEY WILL VOTE NO.
WE WILL VOTE NO IF THERE'S NOT
DIVERSITY ON CORPORATE BOARDS.
IN THE INTEREST OF TIME AND AND
TO SHARE SOME FEEDBACK AND.
THAT MAY BE CONCERNS WITH THE
BILL ONE POINT IS CLEARLY IT
EXTENDS.
MOST OF OUR MANAGER OUTSIDE
CALLS.
CLEARLY THIS WOULD BE EXTENDING
BEYOND OUR JURISDICTION AND THE
ABILITY TO PRACTICALLY IMPLEMENT
THAT MAY BE CHALLENGING.
AS POINTED OUT BY THE SPEAKERS
THIS BILL TARGETS VENTURE
CAPITAL.
WHICH WE AGREE WITH THERE IS A
A PROBLEM IN VENTURE CAPITAL
VENTURE CAPITAL OF LESS THAN ONE
PERCENT OF OUR PORTFOLIO.
AND ALL THOSE MANAGERS THIRTY
PERCENT ARE UNDER REPRESENTED
MINORITIES.
LET ME JUST CLOSE WITH SAYING
THAT TO BE CLEAR WE BELIEVE
DIVERSITY INCLUSION MATTERS.
WE FEEL THAT THREE YEARS AGO WE
WERE AT THE LEADING EDGE AND WE
HAVE AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE VERY
THOUGHTFUL.
WE'RE VERY PROUD OF WHAT WE
DON'T KNOW THE PAST FOUR YEARS
WE MANAGE HUNDRED EIGHTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS WITH SIXTY
PEOPLE. THAT'S ABOUT FOUR
BILLION DOLLARS PER INVESTMENT
PROFESSIONAL VERSUS AN INDUSTRY
AVERAGE OF ONE WE DO ALL THAT
FOR THREE BASIS POINTS THAT ZERO
POINT ZERO THREE PER.
I ONLY TELL YOU THAT.
BECAUSE WHAT THE COSTS ARE
IMPORTANT IT'S A SMALL TEAM.
WE CAN COME TOGETHER AROUND
THINGS THAT WE BELIEVE ARE
IMPORTANT OUR CULTURE AND OUR
FABRIC WHICH INCLUDE CLIMATE%
CHANGE
WHICH INCLUDE DIVERSITY
INCLUSION THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
MISS COVER YOUR WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE.
YES I OUTLOOK FOR TO WORKING
WITH THAT AND YOU SEE
INVESTMENTS IN DISCUSSING THIS
FURTHER THE BELL IS ON HIS. UP
ADVICE MEANT THEIR
RECOMMENDATION IT. OBVIOUSLY WE
CAN'T TELL THEM WHAT TO DO. UP
AND DIE IF IN FACT DIVERSITY AND
INCLUSION MATTERS THEN IT SHOULD
SHOW UP.
IN TERMS OF HOW.
.
THAT THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
ACTUALLY DOING THE WORK IN THAT
ARE ARE MAKING.
V. INVESTMENTS FOR IT FOR THE
ORGANIZATIONS I RESPECTFULLY ASK
YOUR AYE AYE AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
MADAM CHAIR FEEDING SECRETARY
VIEWED LIKE IF YOU WOULD PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SCHABAS.
SCHABAS NO IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
STONE.
STONE I LOW PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
SEVEN TO YOUR BILL IS OUT WE
WILL KEEP THE ROLE OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH THANK YOU DISCOVER YOUR.
NECKS.
ITEM TWELVE.
MISS RUBIO.
AND AS MS RUBIO COMES UP.
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND DO THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
I KEEP.
COULD HAVE A MOTION FOR THE
CONSENT CALENDAR.
MOVE BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY
MISTER ARAMBULA.
AND SECRETARY.
MEDINA AYE. MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER AYE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM. BLOOM AYE
CHAVEZ
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY
STONE.
STONE AYE LOW BAKER I'M SORRY
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO WEBER.
WEBER I.
NINE ZERO THE CONSENT CALENDAR
IS APPROVED WILL KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
IS RUBIO WELCOME.
THANK YOU GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE TODAY UMBEL FIRST BY
WOULD LIKE THINK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW FOR BEING A JOINT AUTHORING
CONTINUE TO FIGHT WITH ME. ARE
ON OUR AYE FOR ARE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS
TODAY I'M PRESENTING AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN A BILL THAT
WILL DESIGNATE A DREAM RESOURCE
LIAISON THAT CALIFORNIA PUBLIC
HIGH SCHOOLS COLLEGES AND
UNIVERSITIES.
IT IS ESTIMATED THAT EACH YEAR
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY FIVE
THOUSAND UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS
GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOLS AND
WHILE CALIFORNIA HAS TAKEN THE
LEAD ON AND ACTING LEGISLATION
TO PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR ARE
UNDOCUMENTED YOUTH. WE ONLY SEE
TWENTY PERCENT OF THE STUDENTS
ATTENDING COLLEGE ARE
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENTS ACROSS THE
STATE TALK ABOUT THE LACK OF
INFORMATION. ON THEIR TEACHERS
PROVIDE WHEN IT COMES TO
RESOURCES FOR UNDOCUMENTED
YOUTH.
SINCE THE IMPLEMENTATION OF AB
FIVE FORTY THE CALIFORNIA DREAM
ACT AND OTHER PIECES OF
MEANINGFUL AT THAT LEGISLATION
ACCESS AND AFFORDABILITY TO
HIGHER EDUCATION IS NOW
ATTAINABLE. FOR ARE UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENT POPULATION.
GIVENTHE CURRENT FEDERAL ARE
CLIMBING AROUND DHAKA CONCEPT
PUSHED BACK FROM THE DC
ADMINISTRATION AND RECENT
REMARKS FROM THE PRESIDENT ON
EASTER SUNDAY WE AS LEGISLATORS
NOW MORE THAN EVER MUST DO MORE
TO HELP OUR UNDOCUMENTED
STUDENTS AND THEIR FAMILIES.
I AM PROUD TO SAY THAT I I WAS
BORN IN MEXICO MOST OF YOU KNOW
MY STORY.
I CAME TO THE UNITED STATES AS
A YOUNG CHILD AND WAS DEPORTED I
SENT BACK TO MEXICO AND CAME
BACK AND WAS UNDOCUMENTED UNTIL
I WAS THIRTEEN YEARS OLD.
.
WITH HARD WORK AND MAINLY
EDUCATION I WAS ABLE TO I GET A
DEGREE BECOME A TEACHER AND NOW
BE SITTING HERE IN FRONT OF YOU
PRESENTING THIS BILL.
ARE THE STUDENTS THESE STUDENTS
LIKE ME ALSO CAME TO THE US FOR
A BETTER LIFE AND A BETTER
OPPORTUNITY IT IS OUR DUTY TO
OUR CREATE POLICIES THAT WILL
LEAD TO SUCCESSFUL. OF FUTURE.
ARE DREAMERS WILL GROW UP TO
PURSUE HIM POST SECONDARY
EDUCATION AND BETTER PREPARED
THEMSELVES TO ENTER CALIFORNIA'S
DEMANDING WORKFORCE ARE DREAMERS
HAVE MADE CALIFORNIA BETTERING
CONTINUE TO AMAZE ME. WITH THEIR
COUNSEL ADVOCACY EFFORTS UNDER
THE FEDERAL ADMINISTRATION.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ARE COUPLE
STUDENTS AND I WANT TO SHARE
THAT WANT TO SHARE THEIR STORIES
RAZA RICK ROSS PSYCHIATRY GET
STUDENT IRVINE OF VALLEY CITY
COLLEGE. AND WHO THE SUBWAYS ARE
MARIST AND I STANISLAUS STATE
AND CHRISTOPHER SUCH AS
REPRESENTING COALITION FOR HUMAN
AYE FOR CHURCH.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
THINK YOU CHAIR AND MEMBERS ON I
AM JULIE SADRIST AMATUS.
AND MY PARENTS WERE THE ORIGINAL
DREAMERS.
AS AN IMMIGRANT YOUTH I HAVE
FACED DAILY CHALLENGES AND FEAR.
AND I HAVE SEEN THESE CHALLENGES
AND FEAR MANIFESTED AND OUR
FAMILIES OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
CHILDREN.
APPLYING FOR COLLEGE I HAD NO
RESOURCE.
NO RESOURCES OR KNOWLEDGE OF
RESOURCES TO HELP AID ME IN MY
EDUCATION WITH MY CURRENT
STATUS.
I CAN APPLY FOR SCHOLARSHIPS OR
INTERNSHIPS EVEN WITH MY FOUR
POINT OH GRADE POINT AVERAGE
SIMPLY BECAUSE I WASN'T A
CITIZEN.
I HAD NO KNOWLEDGE OF THE
RESOURCES THAT WERE ACTUALLY
AVAILABLE FOR ME AND BECAUSE OF
THAT I WAS LIMITED TO MY
EDUCATION.
AS AN IMMIGRANT YOUTH LEADER I
NOW SEE THESE CHALLENGES WITH MY
COLLEGE COMMUNITY.
AT CSU STANISLAUS WE HAVE NO
DREAMS CENTER AND NO DREAMER
RESOURCE LIAISON TO AID US WITH
OUR NEEDS.
IT TOOK MONTHS OF PROTESTING OUR
UNIVERSITY ADMINISTRATION
ATTENDING MEETINGS ORGANIZING
INFORMING AND EDUCATING IN ORDER
TO GET A CENTER WHERE YOU. CAN
BE SAVED WITHOUT FEAR OF
RETALIATION AND WHERE WE CAN
GET.
SOME SORT OF RESOURCES FOR OUR
NEEDS.
A WORK IN PROGRESS ARE SMALL
DIVERSEY CENTER IS RUN BY
STUDENT VOLUNTEERS WHO DO THE
WORK THE UNIVERSITY IS BEING
PAID FOR.
WE HAVE BECOME ARE ONLY RESOURCE
THAT WE CAN GO TO.
THE MORE SCHOOL MOST SCHOOLS ARE
NOT THAT LUCKY.
OUR STUDENTS NEED OUR HELP
THROUGH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN AND BY
SIGNING A DREAMER RESOURCE
LIAISON WE CAN DO THIS AND SO
MUCH MORE. SOURCE STUDENTS CAN
GO TO SCHOOL WITHOUT FEAR SO
THEY CAN BECOME AWARE OF
RESOURCES AVAILABLE TO THEM AND
SO THEY CAN BECOME OUR FUTURE
LEADERS AND PROFESSIONALS. THINK
YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIR COMMITTEE.
MY NAME IS A DRUG CZAR RATHER.
I'M A PUBLIC HEALTH POLICY MAJOR
THIRTY YEAR IRVINE VALLEY
COLLEGE
IDC OFFERS FREE PROGRAMS AND
PARTNERSHIPS THAT ALLOW STUDENTS
TO FULFILL THEIR EDUCATIONAL
GOALS.
HOWEVER THE CAMPUS HAS LEFT IN
THE SHADOWS SEVEN HUNDRED OF ITS
STUDENTS.
IN THE SOUTHERN ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT SEVEN
HUNDRED STUDENTS.
MAJORITY OF WHICH ARE KOREAN ARE
UNDOCUMENTED
YET THERE IS NO ADVISER OR
SUPPORT GROUP.
DESIGNATED ON CAMPUS TO AID THE
LARGE POPULATION.
I AM ONE OF THOSE SEVEN HUNDRED
AMONG DOCUMENT AND ALTHOUGH MY
CAMPUS HAS MANY SOURCES AND
CENTERS AYE SOLTERO STRUGGLE TO
FIND A PLACE OF BELONGING. AND A
PLACE WHERE I FEEL SAFE ON
CAMPUS
ESPECIALLY WITH THE POLITICAL
CLIMATE THAT WE ARE EXPERINCING
TODAY.
ONE OF THE MAIN STRUGGLES AS AN
UNDOCUMENTED STUDENT IS HAVING
TO GO AROUND CAMPUS EXPLAINING
MY SITUATION.
TELLING THOSE AT THE DESK THAT I
AM UNDOCUMENTED SO THAT THEY CAN
TELL ME THE INFORMATION I NEED
WHEN IT COMES TO THE FINANCIAL
AID PROCESS PAYMENTS AND
ADMINISTRATION. APPLICATIONS.
IT MAY NOT SEEM LIKE A BIG DEAL.
BUT WHEN YOU'RE UNDOCUMENTED
TELLING THE WRONG PERSON YOUR
STATUS CAN COST YOU THE LIFE YOU
BUILT IN THIS COUNTRY.
OFTEN THE WORKERS DON'T HAVE THE
EXPERIENCE WITH THE CASES LIKE
MINE. ESPECIALLY SOME THINGS ARE
ALWAYS CHANGING REGARDING BAKA.
THERE ARE MOMENTS OF FRUSTRATION
WHEN NO ONE ON CAMPUS IS REALLY
SURE ON HOW TO HELP YOU SO
INSTEAD OF GETTING ONE TO HOPE
IN PERSON. ANSWER.
ANSWERS FOR YOUR CAMPUS ARE
USUALLY.
GIVEN TO YOU BY TELLING YOU TO
DIAL A ONE EIGHT HUNDRED NUMBER.
WHERE AN OPERATOR WILL GUIDE YOU
THROUGH THE PROCESS?
THIS WAS THE CASE FOR ME IN MANY
SITUATIONS.
SPECIFIC QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM I'M DURING MY
FIRST YEAR AT IBC COULD NOT BE
ANSWERED BY THE FINANCIAL AID
OFFICE.
AND I WAS FORCED TO HUNT FOR
THOSE ANSWERS ON MY OWN.
IT WAS EVEN MORE SURPRISING WHEN
IRAN INTO STUDENTS WHO DIDN'T
KNOW THAT THERE WAS
OPPORTUNITIES OUT FOR THEM
BECAUSE THEY WERE TOO AFRAID. TO
EVEN ASK SOMEBODY FOR HELP ON
CAMPUS AND SHARE THEIR STORIES.
BEEN UNDOCUMENTED AND FIRST
GENERATION COLLEGE STUDENT MADE
THE TRANSITION EVEN MORE
CHALLENGING AND ALTHOUGH I
EVENTUALLY FOUND THE ANSWERS I
WOULD HAVE FELT MORE CONFIDENT
OF WHAT I WAS DOING IF I HAD A
PROFESSIONAL TO TALK TO ABOUT MY
DOUBTS.
THESE STUDENTS DESERVE TO HAVE
SOMEONE ON CAMPUS WHO WILL BE
THERE TO HELP THEM.
TO INFORM THEM SOMEONE THEY CAN
TRUST AND BUILD THE BOND WITH
GET CONCRETE ANSWERS AND NOT
JUST THE NUMBER TO DIAL.
HAVING SOMEONE WHO SPECIALIZES
WITH WORKING WITH STUDENTS AND
THE SITUATIONS IS CRUCIAL FOR
THEIR SUCCESS.
THESE STUDENTS PAY THE SAME
AMOUNT OF FEES AND TUITION AND
AT TIMES EVEN MORE IF THEY DON'T
QUALIFY FOR AB FIVE FORTY.
THEREFORE IT IS UNDER THE
RESPONSIBILITY OF THE COLLEGE
THAT THE STUDENTS DON'T GO
UNNOTICED.
AND GIVEN THE RESOURCES TO BE
SUCCESSFUL.
AND THE RESPONSIBILITY OF THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA TO LEAVE
THAT MOVEMENT.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
CHRIS FIRST ON TO THE CHAIR OF
THE COALITION FOR HUMANE
IMMIGRANT RIGHTS IN THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK OUR
COLLEGIATE ORGANIZATION PROUD TO
BE A SPONSOR FOR THIS OP IS
LEGISLATION HERE FOR TECHNICAL
SUPPORT IF YOU HAVE ANY
QUESTION.
IF YOU.
ROTH ORINDA FROM CHELAN THE
CALIFORNIA JIM NOW WORK IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
PLUS THE ABYDOS WITH THE
CALIFORNIA DREAM NETWORK AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA DAVIS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
RUBIO VIA WITH THE UNIVERSITY OF
CALIFORNIA RIVERSIDE SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
GLORIA AROUND REPRESENTATIVES
WHO SOUNDS AWESOME SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
THEN ARIANNA FROM REAL HONDA
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
THREE SEVEN SILENCE FROM ELITE
THREE PICKED IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
I HAD A LETTER FROM EAST LOS
ANGELES COLLEGE SUPPORT THIS
BILL.
MARY CHRIS AT THE CALIFORNIA
IMMIGRANT POLICY CENTER IN
SUPPORT OF THE SPELL.
GET ME OUT OF A LOAN FROM LOS
ANGELES TRADE TECHNICAL SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL.
WELL ABOVE PERCENT OPUS FROM CSU
SCIENCE STANISLAUS IN SUPPORT OF
THIS BILL.
AS MY NASHER FROM CSU STANISLAUS
IN SUPPORT OF THIS BILL.
GEN ED EDITABLE STILL IN SUPPORT
OF THIS BILL FROM THE CALIFORNIA
DO NETWORK.
IF YOU KNOW IT ASIAN AMERICANS
ADVANCING JUSTICE CALIFORNIANS
TRANSPORT.
JERRY DUSA WHAT THE CELTICS IN
ASSOCIATION WESUPPORT THE BILL
AND CONCEPT AS WE'VE SUPPORTED
MEASURES LIKE THIS BEFORE AND WE
WILL BE SUPPORT OF SAN.
MELISSA BARDO WITH THE
CALIFORNIA STING AID COMMISSION
AND SUPPORT OF THE BILL.
MANDY A SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF
THE SAN JOSE EVERGREEN CAN
COMMITTEE BECAUSE HISTORY CAN
SUPPORT I BELIEVE THIS IS THE
NOW WE GET TALK POLICY BUT ALSO
ON APPROPRIATIONS.
THANK YOU.
LYDIA ONE REPRESENTING AMERICAN
ACADEMY OF PEDIATRICS CALIFORNIA
DIVISION AND SUPPORT.
AYE TYLER AYE YOU ARE IN BEHALF
OF THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
IN SUPPORT.
SIMILAR CHAIR OF THE ACADEMIC
SENATE OF THE CSU WE SUPPORT IN
CONCEPT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN MEMBERS JEFF
FROST REPRESENTING KATEE SOL
WHICH REPRESENTS OVER THREE
THOUSAND ESL TEACHERS.
IN CASE TWELVE ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IN SUPPORT.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM.
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
THIS RUBIO VIA LIKE THE CLUB
THANK YOU I'M THANK YOU FOR
LISTENING TO THE SENATE STORY
THEN THANK YOU TO THE STUDENTS
BECAME SOME OF THEM CAME FROM.
LOS ANGELES AREAS I REALLY
APPRECIATE YA BUT THE TIME AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE.
THANK YOU MISS RUBIO I THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD
AND AS WE'VE SEEN WITH THE UC.
THE ATTORNEYS THAT ARE IN PLACE
AND ALL THE UC CAMPUSES.
SPECIFICALLY FOR THE DREAMERS I
THINK ARE DOING GOOD WORK I VERY
MUCH.
SUPPORT THIS BILL AND.
.
THANK YOU AGAIN FOR BEING HERE.
AND MADAMS.
WE HAVE A MOTION.
MOVED BY MISTER CHAVEZ.
SECOND BY MISTER RUMBULA.
AND OF SECRETARY OF YOU'D CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE. MEDINA
I. MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
SHOP IS I IRWIN. IRWIN AYE KILEY
STONE.
LOW.
PATTERSON.
QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
NINE ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
THANK YOU.
RUBIO YOU HAVE A SECOND BILL
ITEM SIXTEEN. ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR.
I AM PRESENTING AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE A BILL THAT WILL
HELP INSURE OUR LACTATING
STUDENTS ARE PROVIDED WITH THE
BASIC NEEDS NECESSARY TO ACHIEVE
ACADEMIC SUCCESS.
A GROWING NUMBER OF HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS ARE
PROVIDING ADEQUATE LACTATE
LACTATION SPACES FOR THEIR
STUDENT BODY.
HOWEVER INADEQUATE SPACES OR
UNSANITARY LOOK LACTATION
ACCOMMODATIONS WITHIN OUR HIGHER
EDUCATION INSTITUTIONS STILL
EXIST AND HAVE BEEN IDENTIFIED
AS A SERIOUS HAD SERIOUS HEALTH
AND GENDER INEQUITY ISSUE.
UNFORTUNATELY THE LACK OF
DESCRIPTIVE SYSTEM WIDE POLICIES
REGARDING LACTATION
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR STUDENTS
LIMITS ACCESS TO BASIC STUDENT
NEEDS HERE WITH ME TODAY I HAVE.
MY YEAH RAM WITH THE WOMEN'S
POLICY INSTITUTE IN. AND THE
ORGANIZATION THAT IS SPONSORING
THE BILL. AND FOUGHT LARA AND ME
MEANS MEANS IF THEY HAVE TO HELP
ME NOTHING A CURRENT STUDENT
LONG BEACH CITY COLLEGE WHO HAVE
BEEN ADVOCATING FOR LACTATION
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR OVER A YEAR.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN NINA AND
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS MY
NAME IS MEYER ROB AND I AM AN
UNDERGRADUATE STUDENT AT UCLA A
PART OF THE REPRODUCTIVE JUSTICE
TEAM AND THIS YEAR'S WOMEN'S
POLICY INSTITUTE CLASS.
THE WOMEN'S POLICY INSTITUTE IS
A PROGRAM OF THE WOMEN'S
FOUNDATION OF CALIFORNIA WE ARE
PROUD TO SPONSOR AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE.
UNDER CURRENT LAW STUDENTS IN
CALIFORNIA'S HIGHER EDUCATION
INSTITUTIONS ARE NOT GUARANTEED
ACCESS TO THE LACK TEACHING
ACCOMMODATIONS THEY NEED AND
DESERVE.
UPON SURVEYING THE SEVENTY TWO
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS AND ALL CSU CAMPUSES
OUR TEAM HAS FOUND MANY
INCONSISTENCIES AND LACTATION
ACCOMMODATIONS FOR STUDENTS
ACROSS CAMPUSES.
WE'VE HEARD STORIES OF STUDENTS
PUMPING MILK AND TINY BATHROOM
STALLS A STUDENT HAVING TO WALK
TO THEIR CARS TO NURSE OR PUMP
IN BETWEEN CLASSES.
AND OF STUDENTS BEING PENALIZED
FOR LEAVING CLASS EARLY TO PUMP
MILK AND RELIEVE DISCOMFORT.
THIS IS WRONG.
A STUDENT'S ABILITY TO PURSUE
HIGHER EDUCATION WHILE MAKING
THE BEST CHOICES FOR THEIR
FAMILIES SHOULD NOT BE DEPENDENT
ON THE LOCATION OF THE CAMPUS.
ADDITIONALLY STUDENTS TO HAVE
ACCESS TO LIKE TEACHING
ACCOMMODATIONS INDICATE THROUGH
TWELVE SYSTEM.
HE SHOULD CONTINUE TO HAVE
ACCESS WHEN THEY GRADUATE AND
ENTER COLLEGE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE TO
ENSURE THAT ALL STUDENTS ARE
ABLE TO NURSE AND PUMP MILK FOR
THEIR CHILDREN IN SPACES THAT
MEET BASIC NEEDS WITHOUT
JEOPARDIZING THEIR ACCESS TO
EDUCATION.
ACCORDING TO A REPORT BY BREAST
FEED LA ONE OUT OF THREE
INDIVIDUALS IN LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WHO STOP BREASTFEEDING
EARLIER THAN PLANNED CITED THAT
IT WAS TOO DIFFICULT TO CONTINUE
BREASTFEEDING WANTS A RETURN TO
SCHOOL OR WORK.
ADDITIONALLY OF LOS ANGELES
COUNTY WOMEN WHO EXPERIENCE
BREASTFEEDING DISCRIMINATION ONE
OUT OF FIVE INDIVIDUALS STATED
THAT THEY EXPERIENCED BITS
DISCRIMINATION IN A SCHOOL
SETTING.
WITHOUT THE ACCOMMODATIONS
PROPOSED IN THIS BILL STUDENT
PARENTS ARE FACED WITH THREE ON
JUST OPTIONS.
DO SO AN UNCOMFORTABLE SPACES
DISCONTINUE NURSING OR PUMPING
ALTOGETHER. OR LEAVE COLLEGE.
MAKE NO MISTAKE THIS IS AN ISSUE
OF GENDER JUSTICE IMPACTING
PARENTING WOMEN TRANCE BOTH AND
GENDER NON CONFORMING
INDIVIDUALS.
THE CURRENT INCONSISTENCIES
REPRESENT A DISCRIMINATORY
BARRIER THAT STANDS IN THE WAY
OF CREATING EQUITABLE AND
SUPPORTIVE ENVIRONMENTS FOR ALL
STUDENTS AT COMMUNITY COLLEGES
AND CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES.
I HOPE THAT YOU WILL CONSIDER
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO SUPPORT
PARENTS STUDENTS.
AND WE APPRECIATE THE SUPPORT WE
HAVE THANK YOU.
IT OFTEN CHEN MEDINA AND
HONORABLE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
MY NAME'S LARA MUNCHIES I'M IN
ANTHROPOLOGY STUDENT AT LONG
BEACH CITY COLLEGE AND I'M A
PARENT.
I WAS NINETEEN YEARS OLD.
AND PREGNANT WITH MY DAUGHTER
WHEN ALL OF MY FRIENDS WERE
GOING TO COLLEGE.
I COULDN'T GO BECAUSE COLLEGES
DIDN'T HAVE FACILITIES FOR
STUDENTS LIKE ME.
I AM AS PARENTING STUDENTS WE
WORK WE JUGGLE FAMILY LIFE AND
WE STUDY.
THIS IS WHAT MAKES COMMUNITY
COLLEGE IS THE RIGHT PLACE FOR
US THIS IS WHY THERE ARE SO MANY
OF US ON COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUSES HOWEVER. IN MY
EXPERIENCE OUR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES DON'T REALLY GO OUT OF
THEIR WAY.
TO SUPPORT OR.
WELCOME STUDENTS LIKE ME.
I'VE BEEN WORKING TO GET
LACTATION FACILITIES ON MY
CAMPUS FOR OVER EIGHTEEN MONTHS.
AND DURING THIS PERIOD OF SPOKEN
TO SO MANY STUDENTS HAVE TAKEN A
SMALL BREAK WHILE I NEED TO GIVE
BIRTH. AND THEN NOT COME BACK.
I'M.
THEY DON'T COME BACK
BECAUSE THE CAMPUS FACILITIES
MAKE IT VERY DIFFICULT FOR THEM
TO BE BOTH PARENTS AND STUDENTS.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
OFFICE VERY SMALL CHANGE WITH AN
OUTSIZE IMPACT.
LACTATION FACILITIES ON CAMPUS
WOULD MEAN THAT THE STUDENTS
DON'T HAVE TO STOP STUDYING IN
THE FIRST PLACE.
BUT THE IMPACT OF THIS BILL GOES
FURTHER THAN THAT. STUDIES HAVE
SHOWN THAT. THE MULTI
GENERATIONAL IMPACT OF COLLEGE
EDUCATION IS MOST EFFECTIVE WHEN
THE CHILDREN OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
YOUNG AND ACTIVELY INVOLVED IN
THE PROCESS.
M. IF THESE WITH THE DISEASE HAD
BEEN AVAILABLE WHEN I WAS
NINETEEN. I WOULD HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO GO TO COLLEGE JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE.
THIS IS AN EQUITY ISSUE.
LEGISLATORS HAVE TO MAKE THIS
CHANGE SO THE PARENTING STUDENTS
LIKE MYSELF DON'T HAVE TO FIGHT
FOR IT.
I WORK MULTIPLE JOBS A STUDY
FULL TIME AND I MANAGEMENT
FAMILY RESPONSIBILITIES.
IT'S VERY DIFFICULT FOR ME AND
FOR STUDENTS LIKE MYSELF
TO FIGHT THESE BATTLES BUT
SOMEBODY HAS TO.
THERE ARE THE PARENTS OF
STUDENTS WHO DON'T NECESSARILY
BENEFIT FROM THE SAME PRIVILEGE
I HAVE.
WHO DON'T KNOW WHO TO ASK
WHERE TO LOOK WE DON'T FEEL
COMFORTABLE QUESTIONING THOSE IN
POSITIONS OF AUTHORITY?
STUDENTS SHOULDN'T HAVE TO HEAR
THAT THEIR CONCERNS ARE
RIDICULOUS FROM THIS SCHOOLS
TITLE MINOR UP LIKE I HAVE.
THEY SHOULDN'T HAVE TO CORNER
THE COLLEGE PRESIDENT IN THE
HALLWAY AT TEMPLE HAIKAI DID.
WE SHOULDN'T HAVE TO FIGHT SO
HARD FOR FACILITIES WHICH WE
HAVEN'T ACTUAL PHYSIOLOGICAL
NEAT.
WE VERY RECENTLY GOT LACTATION
FACILITIES ON OUR CAMPUS AND I'D
LIKE TO TELL YOU JUST A VERY
LITTLE BIT ABOUT HOW SOMEWHAT
QUESTIONABLE VICTORY.
OUR LACTATING STUDENTS AT LBC
SEE ARE ALLOWED TO PUMP IN AN
EXAM ROOM IN THE STUDENT HEALTH
CENTER IF. AND ONLY IF THAT ROOM
IS NOT IN USE PREVIOUSLY.
THERE ARE LOTS PUMP IN A SPACE
WITH SIX STUDENTS SEEK TREATMENT
FOR CONTAGIOUS ILLNESSES. THAT
THESE MOTHERS THEM CARRY HOME TO
THE VULNERABLE INFANTS.
THEY'RE ALLOWED TO PUMP DURING
OFFICE HOURS AND ON WEEKDAYS
ONLY. THESE ARE TIMES WHEN
STATISTICALLY THERE ARE FEWER
PARENTS ON CAMPUS AND ANY OTHER
THE SCHOOLS VITAL TO PARENT
PARTICIPATION ON COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
THIS BILL SAYS WE SEE YOU.
IT SAYS YOU'RE WELCOME HERE AND
I'M VERY GRATEFUL THAT YOU
CONSIDERING IT TODAY THANK YOU.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WHICH ISN'T
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON KIDDIE ANDREW
CHILDREN NOW IN SUPPORT.
BRENT IN MARCH WITH THE
CALIFORNIA MEDICAL ASSOCIATION
HOUSE ON SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON SHIPMENTS WITH
RALLY ON BEHALF OF THE AMERICAN
ASSOCIATION OF UNIVERSITY WOMEN
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
I INGRAM'S ACLU IN SUPPORT.
IF YOU'RE BORN AMERICAN ACADEMY
OF PEDIATRICS IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE DOT ON BEHALF THE
FACULTY ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGES IN
HIS FOR THIS BILL.
CHAU GIVENS OF THE COUNTY HEALTH
EXECUTIVES ASSOCIATION OF
CALIFORNIANS PART.
STEEN MILLER CHAIR OF THE
ACADEMIC SENATE OF THE CSU WE
ARE IN FULL SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL.
BRIAN HOW WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS OR AS
PART.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
SEEING NONE ANY QUESTIONS
COMMENTS MISS BAKER.
I JUST WANT TO SAY THANK YOU FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY THANK YOU FOR THE
BELL.
I'M YOU COULD HAVE SAID IT
BETTER THAN ANYBODY ELSE AND SO.
AND IF YOU NEED TO PUT THAT IN A
LETTER TO ANYBODY WHO MIGHT SIGN
THIS BILL I HOPE YOU WILL.
BUT IT'S NOT JUST AN ISSUE OF
WELCOMING ITS CONTINUING ON IN
THE PROGRESS OF ONE'S EDUCATION
HAVING A HEALTHY ENVIRONMENT IN
WHICH TO DO SOMETHING IT'S
COMPLETELY NATURAL AND
PHYSIOLOGICALLY NECESSARY.
AND TO MAKE THOSE.
CHOICES AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS
AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IT I ALSO
THINK IT'S A MATTER OF EQUITY
FOR WOMEN WHO WANT TO RETURN TO
THE WORKPLACE AND SOMETIMES OUR
WORKPLACES. GOING TO SCHOOL.
AND WE TALK A LOT APPEAR ABOUT
HOW WE CAN MAKE SURE THERE'S
WORKPLACE EQUITY FOR WOMEN THAT
DOES NOT ONLY INCLUDE PAY EQUITY
BUT SO MANY OTHER WAYS. AND THIS
RIGHT HERE IS ONE OF THE MOST
FUNDAMENTAL WAYS THE HARDER YOU
MAKE IT FOR PEOPLE TO COME BACK
FROM HAVING CHILDREN TO THEIR
WORKPLACE ENVIRONMENT OR
STUDYING OR WHATEVER IS.
BETTERING THEM ON THEIR CAREER
TRAJECTORY THE THE MORE
HYPOCRITICAL WE WOULD BE BEING
ABOUT. SUPPORTING WORKPLACE
EQUITY SOME VERY PROUD YOU'RE
DOING THIS VERY GRATEFUL FOR IT
I WILL JUST ADD THAT SOMETIMES
WE PUT REQUIREMENTS.
ON OUR EDUCATION SYSTEM AND WE
DON'T FIND IT OR WE DON'T
SOMEHOW TRY TO FACILITATE IT.
AND I HOPE THAT IF THIS BECOMES
AN ISSUE I I HAVEN'T HEARD IT
FROM OF THE TESTIMONIES IT CAME
UP FROM IN.
ITV AFFECTED ENTITIES BUT IF IT
BECOMES AN ISSUE WE WE NEED TO
HAVE THAT CONVERSATION I'M SURE
JUST OPEN THE DOOR FOR THAT.
A BUT I I THINK YOU TERRIFIC
TESTIMONY IMPROPER SUPPORT BILL.
MR WOULD.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR.
WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE YES
THANK YOU NOT EVERY CAMPUS HAS.
SOMEONE LIKE LARA FIGHTING FOR
THEIR PEERS ABILITY TO PUMP AND
NURSE AND.
FOR ME I AM A MOTHER OF TWO
TRYING TO JUGGLE LEGISLATING AND
AND PARENTING I CANNOT IMAGINE.
HOW WOULD BE? IF I DIDN'T HAVE
THE RESOURCES OR THE UP PROPER
HELP.
AT HOME I WOULD NOT BE ABLE TO
DO THIS AND THE RESOURCES THAT
THAT THE STUDENTS NEED IS
CRITICAL TO THEIR SUCCESS AS
WELL SO I THINK YOU AND I I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU IMAGE RUBIO YOU
DID ACCEPT THE AMENDMENT SAYS
INFOS.
AS A TWO TWO COMMENTS THANK YOU
FOR BRINGING IT FORWARD VERY
MUCH NEEDED LEGISLATION.
.
TWO TWO COMMENTS YOU MIGHT WANNA
MAKE SURE THAT MOVING FORWARD.
TO MAKE SURE THAT WE SPECIFY YOU
SEE AS WELL SUBNET THINKING
ABOUT.
AND THE OTHER ONE IS I WOULD.
URGE YOU TO KEEP WORKING.
.
TO CLARIFY THE.
RENOVATION PART OF THE BILL
ABSOLUTELY WE ARE ARE CURRENTLY
WORKING WITH.
THE ADVOCATES OF WORKING I'M
WILL CLARIFY THAT LANGUAGE TO
WORK WITH THE PREPARATIONS ON
THAT ISSUE SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
SUGGESTIONS AND THE AMENDMENT
THAT THE COMMITTEE AND I CAN'T
DO STRONGLY SUPPORT THE BILL SO
THE.
MOTION OF MOVE BY.
BUT THIS IRWIN AND SECOND BY
MISS BAKER. OF THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED.
IT MOTIONS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SCHABAS
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY STONE. LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO OF THE BILL IS OUT LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH APPRECIATED.
WHILE.
MISS IRWIN COMES TO THE DESK
WE'RE GONNA GO AHEAD AND VOTE ON
THE.
MOTIONS THAT WE HEARD. FOR.
THE THE BILLS THAT WE'VE HEARD
BEFORE WE'RE GONNA GO AND TAKE A
VOTE ON THOSE.
AB TWENTY EIGHTY ONE WE NEED A
MOTION AND A SECOND.
RIGHT NOW.
MOVED BY MISTER CHAVEZ. SECOND
BY MISTER PATTERSON.
MADAM SECRETARY IF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THAT MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE.
MEDINA.
NO.
MEDINA NO BAKER.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM NO. CHAVEZ.
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN NOT VOTING.
KILEY.
STONE.
STONE NO LOW.
LOW NO PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA NO SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO NO WEBER.
WEBER NO
SO THE VOTE WAS TWO SEVEN WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
YEAH SO.
ITEM THIRTEEN.
OKAY A. B. TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
FOUR WE NEED A MOTION AND A
SECOND.
MOVE BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY
MISTER BLOOM.
MISTER STONE ALRIGHT THANK YOU.
AND THEM SECRETARY VEHICLE THE
VOTE THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
SCHABAS I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
STONE.
STONE I LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA I SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
TEN ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE FIFTY FOUR IS OUT WE WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE WE
NEED A MOTION AND A SECOND.
MOVE MY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY
THIS QUIRK SILVA. MEMSIC
ATTRIBUTE CALLED VOTE.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I SCHABAS CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
STONE.
STONE I LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE.
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
TEN ZERO A. B. TWENTY THREE
NINETY ONE IS OUT LEAVE IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
NEXT AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE
MADE A MOTION AND A SECOND.
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE.
NUMBER FOURTEEN NUMBER FOUR.
THE MOTION AS DO PASSED TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THAT
WAS MOVED BY.
THE WEBER DOCTOR WEBER AND
SECOND BY BILL QUIRK SILVA.
MADAM SECRETARY OF YOU WOULD
CALL THE ROLL. MEDINA AYE MEDINA
AYE BAKER. ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY STONE.
STONE I LOW. LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO.
ASSEMBLY BILL
TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE IS OUT
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
WE'RE GONNA GO TO ADD ONS FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
LOW A LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE SANTIAGO.
CONSENT CALENDAR.
SANTIAGO AYE.
TWELVE ZERO THE CONSENT COUNTERS
THAT
.
TO ADD ON. ITEM NUMBER FOUR A.
B. TWENTY FORTY ONE.
KILEY.
LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO.
SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE.
THREE
THE BILL TWENTY FORTY ONE.
OUT.
WE WILL.
IT OPENED HER IN THE ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN.
KILEY.
STONE.
STONE I LOW. LOW AYE.
PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING.
ELEVEN ZERO EIGHT BE
BEFORE SEVENTY SEVEN IS OUT WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
I DON'T.
SIXTEEN A. B. TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
KILEY.
STONE.
STONE I.
TWELVE ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE IS OUT.
WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AND
THE SERVANT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
PATIENCE.
CERTAINLY.
WELL I GOOD AFTERNOON MISTER
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS LAST
YEAR I AUTHORED.
AB SEVEN OH FIVE WHICH REQUIRED
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO USE OF THE
BEST OF MULTIPLE MEASURES TO
PLACE STUDENTS IN TWO CLASSES
WHAT WE FOUND IS THAT STUDENTS
THAT WERE PLACED IN REMEDIAL
CLASSES. PAT WERE MUCH LESS
LIKELY TO GRADUATE IN A TIMELY
MANNER FUND.
COMMUNITY A COLLEGE AND SO WE
HAVE TWO BILLS THAT ARE
FOLLOWING UP ON THAT.
.
THE NEW BILL.
A. B. EIGHTEEN OH FIVE.
PROVIDE STUDENTS WITH EASILY
UNDERSTANDABLE PLACEMENT
POLICIES FOR COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PLACE IN POLICIES AT COLLEGES
CAN BE INCONSISTENT AND
CONFUSING FOR INCOMING STUDENTS
THRESHOLD SCORES FOR PLACEMENT
TESTS VERY AND STUDENTS.
OF AND COLLEGES WILL DECIDE
AMONG MANY.
DIFFERENT TYPES OF MULTIPLE
MEASURES WHICH THEY WILL USE FOR
THEIR CAMPUSES THIS BILL INFORM
STUDENTS OF HOW THEY WILL BE
PLACED INTO THESE TRANSFER LEVEL
CLASSES IT WILL ALSO REQUIRE
COLLEGES TO SUBMIT THEIR.
PLACEMENT POLICIES TO THE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE AND PUBLICLY
POST
THE PLACEMENT RESULTS A
DISAGGREGATED BY RACE AND.
ETHNICITY WE ALSO WANT TO GIVE
THE COLLEGES FLEXIBILITY ONE
COMPLYING WITH THIS LAW SO WE
HAVE A INCLUDED THE
IMPLEMENTATION OF THIS BILL TO
MATCH AB SEVEN OH FIVE I WILL
ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE AMENDMENTS
THAT CLARIFY PLACEMENT POLICIES.
SHOULD BE PROVIDED ON A WRITTEN
COMMUNICATIONS BETWEEN A COLLEGE
COUNSELOR AND STUDENTS WITH ME
HERE TO SPEAK ABOUT THE RESEARCH
BEHIND THIS BILL ARE OLGA
RODRIGUEZ FROM PP I SEE. AND IN
SUPPORT OF SIERRA ARTS SAY.
FROM CAMPAIGN FOR COLLEGE
OPPORTUNITY.
OKAY.
THINK GARY LAND AT IT'S A
PLEASURE TO BE HERE THIS
AFTERNOON TOM I MEAN IS A LOT OF
THE S. SUMMER RESEARCH FELLOW AT
PP A SEAT. AND PPACA IS A
NONPARTISAN UP POLICY RESEARCH
ORGANIZATION AND DOES NOT TAKE
POSITION ON BELL SO WHAT I'M
GONNA DISCUSS AND PRESENT HERE
TODAY. IT'S BASED ON THE
RESEARCH WILL I AM WE CONDUCTED
ON CALIFORNIA'S COMMUNITY
COLLEGES.
I'M SO EVERY YEAR CALIFORNIA'S
COMMUNITY COLLEGES IDENTIFY
HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
STUDENTS AS NOT READY FOR
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES IN MATH
AND ENGLISH.
AND SINCE THESE COURSES ARE
REQUIRED FOR STUDENTS WHO WISH
TO TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
COLLEGE.
STUDENTS WHO ARE DIFFERENT
DEEMED UNDER PREPARED OUR REPORT
VERY FOR TO A SEQUENCE OF
COURSES.
ALSO NO NO NO STILL MENTAL
REMEDIAL BASIC SKILLS COURSES
THAT DOES NOT COUNT TOWARDS A
DEGREE.
.
AND SO THESE PLACEMENT DECISIONS
HAVE VERY PROFOUND IMPACT ON
STUDENTS TRAJECTORY ONCE THEY'RE
IN SCHOOL.
OUR STUDY FINDS THAT EIGHTY
PERCENT OF STUDENTS COMING INTO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES ARE DEEMED
UNDER PREPARED AND REFER TO
THESE CORSETS.
AND VERY FEW OF THE STUDENTS
ACTUALLY END UP COMPLETING THE
TRANSFER LEVEL OF MATH AND
ENGLISH REQUIREMENT THEY NEED
ARM AND EVEN FEWER OF THEM I.
AND UP TRANSFERRING TO A FOUR
YEAR COLLEGE.
I AM SO DESPITE THIS CRITICAL
ROLE OF ASSESSMENT EMPLACEMENT
AND AND. HISTORICALLY.
IT'S NOT MUCH IS KNOWN OF OF
HOW ACTUALLY COLLEGES ARE
APPROACHING THIS ASSESSMENT
PLACEMENT PROCESS.
FOR MATH ENGLISH AND YOURSELF
AND THE OVERWHELMING MAJORITY OF
COLLEGES DO NOT PUBLICLY REPORT
THIS INFORMATION ON THEIR
WEBSITES ARE ON.
OR CATALOGS.
AND SO TO HELP FILL THIS
INFORMATION GAP AND BECKONS
TWENTY FIFTEEN WE WE AND TWENTY
SIXTEEN WE SURVEYED COLLEGES.
TO TRY TO BETTER UNDERSTAND HOW
HOW HOW THE ASSASSIN PLEASE
STUDENTS I HUNDRED EIGHTY TWO OF
THE HUNDRED AND THIRTEEN
COLLEGES PARTICIPATED IN THIS
SURVEY.
AND THE REPORTED ON POLICIES
AND PRACTICES USED TO ASSESS
SOMEPLACE STUDENTS I'M INTO
TRANSFER LEVEL MATH AND ENGLISH
COURSES AS WELL AS TO IN THE
HIGHEST LEVEL OF YES SOUTH.
I'M. SO THE BROAD PULL THIS
SURVEY WAS TO PROVIDE POLICY
MAKERS AND PRACTITIONERS WITH
THE DESCRIPTIVE LANDSCAPE. AND
TO HELP UNDERSTOOD HELP IMPROVE
THE UNDERSTANDING OF THE
POLICIES USED ACROSS THE SYSTEM
TO WITHOUT SIMPLY STUDENTS INTO
MAPPING QUESTION YES OF COURSE
IT'S.
AND THIS BILL THE RESULT OF THE
RESEARCH WERE ALSO.
WHERE ALSO IMPORTANT IN
PROVIDING A BASELINE OF HOW
COLLEGES WERE APPROACHING THESE
POLICY THE IMPACT THAT THIS?
PRIOR TO REFORMS ASSOCIATED.
LIKE THE ONE THAT JUST.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER IRWIN AND
COLLEAGUES HAVE STARTED TO WORK
ON SOME REFORM SO WE WANTED A
BASS LINE HOW COLLEGES ARE DOING
PRIOR TO THE CHANGE.
SO UP NEXT TO SUMMARIZE US SOME
OF ARMY FINDING. IT IN JUST A
REMINDER THE PRESENTERS THAT WE
SAID AT THE OUTSET THAT. TO ME
TOO MANY.
SO JUST GIVE THE HIGHLIGHT IT.
AND IT DOES ENJOY SUPPORT.
OKAY.
OKAY IT SO SO I ONE OF THE
THINGS IS.
WE FOUND THAT COLLEGES ARE ARE
HEAVILY RELYING ON PLACEMENT
TESTS ON TO ASSESS SIMPLY
STUDENTS INTO THE COLLEGE THE
INTO COLLEGE LEVEL COURSES. I'M
AND EVEN THOUGH COLLEGES ARE
USING THE SAME TEST THE MAY BE
SETTING DIFFERENT CUT SCORES SO
WHERE STUDENT GO AND ENDS UP IN
ROLENE LARGELY DETERMINES
WHETHER OR NOT A STUDENT IS
GOING TO HAVE ACCESS TO THESE
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES. AND WE
FOUND THAT I'M STILL
UNDERREPRESENTED STUDENTS AND
ESPECIALLY.
AFRICAN AMERICAN STUDENTS HAD.
EVEN MORE RESTRICTIVE ACCESS TO
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES
ESPECIALLY IN MATH THAT JUST BY
VIRTUE OF ATTENDING COLLEGES
THAT SET HIGHER CUT SCORES.
.
AND SO THIS LACK OF CONSISTENCY
EVEN ONE COLLEGES USE THE SAME
TASK OF THE SAME MEASURES.
HOW?
IS IT'S VERY DETRIMENTAL
BECAUSE THEY THOUGHT IT IS
CONFUSING FOR A STUDENT ARE
ENROLLING IN ONE COLLEGE THAT
GOOD DEFINITION OF BEING COLLEGE
READY IS STIFF.
AND IT HAS A AND THIS IS
ESPECIALLY A CRITICAL BECAUSE
FORTY PERCENT OF STUDENTS
ENROLLING MORE THAN ONE COLLEGE.
SO THEY MIGHT EVEN WITHIN THE
THING DISTRICTS THEY MAY BE
CONFRONTED BY DIFFERENT
DIFFERENT EMPLACEMENTS.
YEAH I WON BECAUSE THEY MAY BE
REFERRED TO REMEDIATION AND THE
OTHER ONE THERE ANY MAYBE REFER
TO TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES IT I'M
GONNA STOP YOU THERE THAT'S
OKAY.
IT IS OF THAT WE HAVE TIME FOR
THE OTHER PRESENTERS FEDERAL.
THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN MEDINA
AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS I WILL TRY
TO BE QUICK US THERE ARE C. ON
BEHALF OF THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY. WE ARE
BROAD BASED BIPARTISAN COALITION
THAT WORKS TO ENSURE COLLEGE
ACCESS AND SUCCESS.
AND WE SUPPORT AB EIGHTEEN OH
FIVE IT WOULD LIKE TO THINK THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FOR HER
LEADERSHIP ON THIS ISSUE.
AS YOU JUST HEARD FOR THE
MAJORITY OF COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENT'S PLACEMENT IS DESTINY.
UNFORTUNATELY MOST STUDENTS ARE
AWARE OF ASSESSMENT EMPLACEMENT
POLICIES ON A CAMPUS THEREFORE
THEY NEVER HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
TO UNDERSTAND HOW THOSE POLICIES
MAY IMPACT THEIR COLLEGE
PATHWAY.
THIS INFORMATION IS EITHER
CONFUSING ARE NOT FRIENDS
PARENTS TO TRANSPARENT TO
STUDENTS. MANY COMMUNITY COLLEGE
STUDENTS HAVE SHARED WITH US
JUST HOW CONFUSING AND
FRUSTRATING IT IS TO LEARN ABOUT
THAT PLACE BUT POLICIES VERY
FROM CAMPUS TO CAMPUS. EVEN
WITHIN THE SAME REGION WITH NO
EASY WAY FOR A STUDENT TO GATHER
THAT INFORMATION AND MAKE AN
INFORMED CHOICE ABOUT WHICH
COLLEGE IS BEST POSITIONED TO
HELP THEM SUCCEED RIGHT OUT OF
THE GATE.
LAST YEAR THE CAMPAIGN IS PROUD
TO STAND ALONGSIDE THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER IN SUPPORTING LEGISLATION
THAT REPRESENTS A FUNDAMENTAL
SHIFT IN HOW COLLEGES. A WILL
ASSESS STUDENT READINESS
ALLOWING FOR THE MAJORITY OF
STUDENTS TO ACCESS TRANSFER
LEVEL COURSES IMMEDIATELY UPON
STEPPING ONTO A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE CAMPUS. SO AB EIGHTEEN
OH FIVE IS A CRITICAL NEXT STEP
BY ENSURING THAT STUDENTS ARE
MADE AWARE OF THEIR RIGHTS UNDER
THIS NEW POLICY BUT ALSO THAT
CAMPUSES ARE MORE TRANSPARENT
WITH STUDENTS ABOUT THEIR
PLACEMENT POLICIES. AND
PRACTICES
BUT TRANSPARENCY EMPLACEMENT
POLICIES AND PRACTICES AND
COMMUNITY COMMUNICATING THIS
INFORMATION AND STUDENT FRIENDLY
LANGUAGE WILL HELP STUDENTS MAKE
INFORMED DECISIONS AND HELP THEM
UNDERSTAND THEIR OWN COURSE
PLACEMENT. FOR THESE REASONS WE
URGE YOU TO SUPPORT A. B.
EIGHTEEN OH FIVE THANK YOU THANK
YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
MISTER CHAIRMAN JEFF FROST
REPRESENTING VF THREE THOUSAND
ESL TEACHERS
I'M KITTY SOL.
I WERE VERY SUPPORTIVE OF THIS
BILL WERE ALSO WORKING WITH THE
AUTHOR. TO ENSURE THAT THERE'S
LANGUAGE THAT COVERS STUDENTS
THAT ARE IN ENGLISH LANGUAGE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS THANK YOU
THANK YOU.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE THANK YOU AGAIN.
MISTER WENT FOR.
.
BEEN A CHAMPION OF STUDENT
SUCCESS AND I KNOW HOW IMPORTANT
THIS BILL IS.
WE HAD OF FIRST A MOTION BY.
MR LOW SECOND BY.
DOCTOR WEBER
THE MADAM SECRETARY BUTTE CALL
THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ
CHAVEZ I IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY
STONE.
STONE I LOW. LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
ZERO
IS OUT.
WE LEAVE IT OPEN FOR.
ITEM TWO ASSEMBLY BILL NINETEEN.
.
Q. AGAIN AS I MENTIONED.
LAST YEAR SEVEN OH FIVE PASSED
WHICH WILL PLACE MANY MORE
STUDENTS DIRECTLY INTO
TRANSFERRED LEVEL CLASSES.
OF THE BEST CHANCE THAT THEY
HAVE FOR SUCCESS IS TO OFFER
TUTORING ALONGSIDE OF THE
TRANSFER LEVEL CLASS STUDIES
CONDUCTED BY SAMBAR MEDINA
VALLEY COLLEGE A COLLEGE OF THE
CANYONS FOUND THAT STUDENTS WHO
PARTICIPATED IN TUTORING. HAD
HIGHER SUCCESS RATES.
THEN CAMPUS WIDE AVERAGE SO
RIGHT NOW COLLEGES ONLY RECEIVE
FUNDING FOR.
TUTORING AND BASIC SKILLS
COURSES AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE.
FUNDING FOR TUTORING OF DEGREE
APPLICABLES OR TRANSFER LEVEL
CLASSES.
AND I ACCEPT THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS TO CLARIFY COLLEGES
WILL STILL RECEIVE FUNDING FOR
TUTORING IN BASIC SKILLS HERE
WITH ME TODAY IN SUPPORT IS LARA
MATTOON. FIGHTS CHANCE A CHANCE
SIR FOR EXTERNAL RELATIONS AT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CHANCELLOR'S OFFICE.
THANK YOU. BUT TO.
THANK YOU LAURA MATTOON
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES BOARD OF
GOVERNORS FOR THE SPONSORS OF AB
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE.
IN DECEMBER OF TWENTY SIXTEEN
CHANCELLOR OAKLEY ASK HE
PRESIDENT'S OUR OF OUR ONE
HUNDRED AND FOURTEEN COLLEGES TO
HELP IDENTIFY COMMON BARRIERS TO
STUDENT SUCCESS.
OVERWHELMINGLY LEADERS RESPONDED
THAT THE EXISTING PROHIBITIONS
ON THAT LIMIT THE USE OF
SUPERVISORS TUTORING ARE A
BARRIER. OUR OFFICE CONDUCTED A
REVIEW OF SUPERVISED TUTORING
EFFICACY. AND OF THE STATUTORY
AND REALLY GET REGULATORY
BARRIERS.
THAT EXIST AND THAT RESULTED IN
THE BILL BEFORE YOU TODAY AB
NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE.
SUPERVISE TUTORING IS A METHOD
OF INSTRUCTION THAT INVOLVES A
TRAINED TUTOR A QUALIFIED
FACULTY MEMBER AND STUDENTS WHO
NEED JUST A LITTLE BIT OF
ADDITIONAL SUPPORT AND MASTERING
THAT SKILL OR SUBJECT AREA. AS
WAS MENTIONED NUMEROUS STUDIES
SHOW THAT STUDENTS WHO RECEIVE
SUPERVISE TUTORING HAVE HIGHER
GPAS HIGHER RETENTION RATES. A
STUDY OUT OF SAN BERNARDINO
VALLEY COLLEGE FOUND IN FACT A
SEVEN PERCENT HIGHER RETENTION
RATE FOR STUDENTS THAT HAD
PARTICIPATED IN SUPERVISE
TUTORING.
THIS BILL WOULD EXPAND THE USE
OF SUPERVISED TUTORING FROM JUST
BASIC SKILLS WORTH AUTHORIZED
CURRENTLY TO INCLUDE TRANSFER
LEVEL AND DEGREE APPLICABLE
COURSES.
WE WILL ALSO BE MAKING
REGULATORY CHANGES TO ALLOW
STUDENTS TO SELF SELECT INTO
SUPERVISE TUTORING RIGHT NOW
THEY HAVE TO BE REFERRED BY A
FACULTY MEMBER OR A COUNSELOR. A
WITHOUT WE ASK FOR YOUR SUPPORT
OF THIS IMPORTANT MEASURE THANK
YOU.
OTHER WHICH JUST DOESN'T
SUPPORT.
SARAH RC WITH THE CAMPAIGN FOR
COLLEGE OPPORTUNITY IN SUPPORT.
ANDREA HERERO WITH SMALL TOUGH
THE MEXICAN AMERICAN LEGAL
DEFENSE AND EDUCATIONAL FUND ITS
PORT.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE FOOTHILL DE ANZA
LAS RIOS PERALTA SAN DIEGO. SAN
FRANCISCO COLLEGES ON SUPPORT.
BRIAN HOW WITH CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS WERE IN
SUPPORT.
ASHLEY WALKER WITH NAS MEN ON
BEHALF OF NORTH ORANGE COUNTY
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICT IN
SUPPORT.
MAYBE IT SOUNDS A EVER DRINKING
BECAUSE OF IN SUPPORT.
CRIME ATLANTA AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SEVENTY TWO
COMMUNITY COLLEGES DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
SEEING NONE.
SIR WHAT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
I JUST WANNA SAY BOTH OF THESE
BILLS.
ARE TO ADDRESS AN ISSUE THAT
HAS HAS LONG BEEN A PROBLEM IN
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES STUDENTS
BEING STUCK IN A REMEDIAL
CLASSES AND.
ODDS ARE EVENTUALLY THEY DROP
OUT SO THAT IS A HUGE LOSS OF
HUMAN RESOURCES AND HOPEFULLY
THROUGH THE SET OF BILLS WHERE
WE'VE WORKED WITH ALL THE
DIFFERENT STAKE HOLDERS WILL
START TO SEE STUDENTS MOVING
THROUGH. COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FASTER.
INTO EITHER A FOUR YEAR SCHOOL
OR WITH.
ASSOCIATE DEGREE AND AND THAT'S
WHAT WE NEED FOR OUR ECONOMY
GOING FORWARD AND FOR THOSE
STUDENTS TO ATTAIN A BETTER
LIFESTYLE.
I'D I JUST WANNA SAY AS A FORMER
COMMUNITY COLLEGE TEACHER.
AND AS A TRUSTEE I KNOW HOW
IMPORTANT THAT THESE MEASURES
ARE SO THANK YOU FOR BRINGING
FORWARD. A AYE I ALSO WANT TO
NOTE THAT SENATOR WILK HAS A
SIMILAR BILL. AND JUST WONDERED
IF HE'D HAD ANY CONVERSATION
WITH HIM.
OF.
HAVE WE HAD CONVERSATIONS WITH.
WE WE WE DO THAT SINCE SINCE
AND SINCE YOU DO. IT.
GOOD IDEA AND HOPE THAT YOU
CONTINUE TO TALK.
IT'S THERE SIMILAR BILLS.
SO WE HAVE A MOTION BY.
DOCTOR WEBER SECOND BY MISTER
BLOOM AND MADAM SECRETARY WOULD
CALL THE ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DO PASS AS AMENDED
TO THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
BLOOM. BLOOM AYE SCHABAS.
SCHABAS AYE IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY
STONE.
STONE I LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
ELEVEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT WILL
LEAVE IT OPEN FOR.
AND MEMBERS.
MISTER SANTIAGO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO PRESENT.
FILE ITEM.
NINE
SO WHERE IT FILE ITEM NINE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE OH
SIX.
WELCOME.
BUT MR WILL MAKE US A QUICK
TWENTY MINUTES.
THANK YOU FOR LONG THINK OF THAT
AGE MY MY.
THANK YOU FOR ALLOWING US TO
PRESENT ON.
AB TWENTY THREE OH SIX THAT
WOULD INCREASE THE ACCOUNT AND
ELIGIBILITY FOR FULL TIME
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. STUDENT FROM
A FOUR YEAR TO SIX YEAR PERIOD
AYE THIS WOODEN AT THIS WOULD
NOW MATCHED THE.
THE PELL GRANT THAT IS NOW.
.
IN EXISTENCE AND WE BELIEVE
THAT THIS WILL HELP TO ENCOURAGE
STUDENTS TO TAKE THE CAL GRANT
EARLY EIN ULTIMATELY WOULD
INCREASE OUR THE SUCCESS RATE OF
STUDENTS. ARE WHO CAN CONTINUE
TO GO TO A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OUT
WITH FINANCIAL AID AT THE CAL
GRANT AND THEN CONTINUE INTO
THEIR FOUR YEAR UNIVERSITY.
.
I HAVE HERE A WITNESS WITH US
THE CHANCE OF LOS ANGELES
COMMUNITY COLLEGE. I MIGHT ADD
WHERE I SERVED ONCE AND I'M ALSO
THE LARGEST COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN
THE NATION.
WELCOME TO GET.
THANK YOU SO MEMBER SENT
THAT'LL.
GERMANY NOT ANIMAL MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE TAG COULD
AFTERNOON WHEN A STATE OF THIS
SAN FRANCISCO BUT I GUESS.
THE CHANCE OF THE LOS ANGELES
COMMITTEE COLORS DISTRICT.
AND WE ARE THE SPONSOR OF AB
TWENTY THREE ALL SIX AUTHORED BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANTIAGO.
AS WAS MENTIONED AB TWENTY THREE
OF SIX WOULD EXTEND CAL GRANT
ELIGIBILITY FOR COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO SIX YEARS OF
FULL TIME ENROLLMENT.
THEREBY ALIGNING THE CAL GRANT
PROGRAM WITH THE FEDERAL PELL
GRANT PROGRAM.
THIS YEAR'S.
EXISTING LAW ONLY PERMITS
STUDENTS TO RECEIVE THE CAL
GRANT AWARD FOR FOUR YEARS OF
FULL TIME ATTENDANCE.
AN UNDERGRADUATE PROGRAM.
EXTENDING CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
TO SIX YEARS WOULD RESULT IN
MORE CAL GRANT ABOARD HE'S
ACTUALLY UTILIZING MORE THE
ELIGIBILITY.
WHILE AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
AND.
TO MORE OTHERWISE ELIGIBLE
COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENTS
LIKELY TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE CAL
GRANT PROGRAM WHILE ATTENDING.
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
AS NOTED IN YOUR COMMITTEE
ANALYSIS WE HAVE FOUND THAT
TYPICALLY ARE COMMITTEE COLLEGE
STUDENTS TAKE FOUR YEARS OR
MORE.
TO TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION AND UPON
TRANSFERRING MOST TAKE ANOTHER
THREE OR FOUR YEARS TO GRADUATE.
SPIKE ARE LARGE AND SIGNIFICANT
LOW INCOME STUDENT POPULATION AT
LACC DE OVER TWO HUNDRED
THOUSAND STUDENTS.
NINE COLLEGES AND ABOUT FIFTY
PERCENT OF SO LIVE AT OR BELOW.
OF THE PARTY LINE THERE IS A
SEVERE UNDER UTILIZATION OF THE
CAL GRANT AWARD BECAUSE STUDENTS
FEEL OBLIGATED TO SAVE THEIR CAL
GRANT FOR THE HIGHER UNIVERSITY
TUITION.
THIS CAUSES ARE STUDENTS TO
UNNECESSARILY EXTEND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE UNDERGRADUATE
PROGRAM BECAUSE THEY OFTEN
INCREASED THEIR WORK HOURS AND
ARE REDUCE THEIR COURSE LOADS.
WITH THE PASSAGE OF AB TWENTY
THREE ALL SIX.
OUR STATE CAL GRANT PROGRAM
ALIGNS WITH THE FEDERAL PELL
GRANT PROGRAM TO SIX YEARS AS
WAS MENTIONED. AND IN DOING SO
MORE COMMITTEE COLLEGE STUDENTS
WILL APPLY FOR EXCEPT THE USER
WORK HOURS INCREASED OUR COURSE
LOADS AND TAKE ADVANTAGE OF THE
ADDITIONAL INCENTIVE GRANTS THAT
ARE AVAILABLE IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA THROUGH FINANCIAL
AID.
THAT'S.
TRANSFER MORE QUICKLY TO THE
UNIVERSITY AND BECOME MORE
ACADEMICALLY SUCCESSFUL.
THE LOS ANGELES COMMITTEE
BECAUSE DISTRICT IN STRONG
SUPPORT OF AB TWENTY THREE ALL
SIX
BECAUSE IT ALLOWS MORE COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS TO RECEIVE. A
CAL GRANT WHILE COMPLETING THEIR
COMMITTEE COLLEGE PROGRAM ENABLE
STUDENTS TO HAVE SUFFICIENT
REMAINING CAL GRANT ELIGIBILITY
AT THE FOUR YEAR COLLEGE
UNIVERSITY.
I'M VERY PLEASED THAT THIS BILL
HAS RECEIVED STRONG SUPPORT FROM
THE CALIFORNIA'S TO NATE
COMMISSION.
I COMMITTEE BECAUSE LEAGUE OF
CALIFORNIA THE FACT ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES
AND NUMEROUS TOO MANY COLORS
DISTRICTS THROUGHOUT THE STATE.
I RESPECTFULLY URGE YOUR AYE
VOTE ON THIS BILL.
THANK YOU ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON AARON HUDDLES IN
REPRESENTING THE STUDENT AID
COMMISSION WE ARE IN SUPPORT.
STEPHANIE DOT ALL OF THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND WE ARE IN
SUPPORT.
RANMA CONTINUED THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA ON
BEHALF OF CALIFORNIA SEVENTY TWO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS IN
SUPPORT.
THANK YOU MARK MCDONALD ON
BEHALF OF THE FOOTHILL DE ANZA
LOS RIOS PERALTA SANDIEGO AND
SAN FRANCISCO COMMUNITY COLLEGE
DISTRICTS ALL IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL.
MAYBE AS REPRESENTS SOUNDS A
EVERGREEN CAN CAUSE HAS VERY
MUCH IN SUPPORT THANK YOU.
SOME OF ONTARIO.
RUSS I DEANDRE WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AYE WE TYPICALLY SUPPORT
BILLS THAT EXPAND FINANCIAL AID
OPPORTUNITIES FOR STUDENTS WERE.
STILL BETTING THE BILL IS GOING
THROUGH A PROCESS SO.
WILL BE OUT WORKING ON THE
SPELL.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
ANY QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE.
AS BAKER THANK YOU OUT OF.
S. TRYNA PLAY A LITTLE BIT
BETTER HOW MAKING THIS.
IT'LL HAPPEN IN SIX YEARS.
WILL.
HELP SOMEONE FINISH SOONER OR
HELP THEM BECAUSE THEY DON'T
GET.
THE OPPORTUNITY AND I MEAN AS
NEGATIVE AN INCENTIVE TO TO GET
THROUGH THE COMMUTER BECAUSE
PARTING GET TO WHEREVER YOU WANT
TO TRANSFER TO POTENTIALLY AND.
TRYING TO UNDERSTAND HOW THIS
HELPS SOMEONE GET IT DONE
SOONER.
SIR.
THEY ARE TO HAVE AN INCENTIVE TO
LIKE.
SHOULD I SPECIAL IF THEY'RE NOT
CAN FINANCIAL HELP.
FOR SIX YEARS INSTEAD OF FOUR
THREATENING I APPRECIATE THAT
QUESTION YEAH I'LL GIVE EXAMPLE
MYSELF IT WHEN I WAS GOING TO
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE WERE ALWAYS
TOLD THAT YOU APPLY TOWARD THE
END FOR FINANCIAL AID. SO THAT
YOU CAN USE SOME OF THAT WHEN
YOU GET TO A UNIVERSITY.
AND YOU LOOK THE WHEN YOU TAKE
A LOOK AT MOST WORKING CLASS.
COMMUNITIES AND PARTICULARLY OF
FOLKS ARE STRUGGLING GOING
THROUGH COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
THERE IS A THERE IS A TENDENCY
FOR SOME STUDENTS TO TAKE NON
CREDIT COURSES A REMEDIATION
COURSES THAT MAY BERNIE YEAR TO
THAT WAS THE CASE FOR ME.
AND THEN CERTAINLY WE WANT TO
GIVE THEM THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES THEY CAN ACTUALLY STAY
IN SCHOOL.
SO IF IT GIVEN THE ABILITY TO
USE FINANCIALLY EARLIER YOU CAN
ACTUALLY STAY IN SCHOOL. AND
ACTUALLY.
FINISH WHICH IS WHAT THIS WHOLE.
AT WHICH IS WHAT WE'RE TRYING
TO HEAR.
BUT WOULDN'T CHANGE APPRECIATE
THAT IT WOULDN'T CHANGE IF
YOU'RE GOING TO. AS YOU SAY
BERNIE YEAR ON REMEDIATION.
BECAUSE YOU'RE GOING TO DO THAT
YEAR ANYWAY BUT I I I WOULD
THINK.
I'M
AND.
I I.
I'M I'M STRUGGLING WITH THIS
BECAUSE AYE I WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT AS MUCH AS POSSIBLE IS
AVAILABLE TO STUDENTS IN THE
PATHWAYS OPEN BUT ALSO KEEP
THAT.
THAT ABILITY TO SUPPORT HIM TO
COMPLETE AS QUICKLY AS POSSIBLE
WITHOUT POTENTIALLY CREATING. IT
IN THE OPPOSITE IN FACT.
WILL LOOK BECAUSE LOOK WE
STRUGGLED WITH THIS TO WRITE IN
TERMS OF MOST OF THE ARGUMENTS
THAT COME TOWARDS US WHAT WE
WERE DOING FREE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE WE FACED.
WE FACED SIMILAR ARGUMENTS WERE
FULL TWENTY TO PUSH US TO DO
FIFTEEN UNITS.
PER SEMESTER IN ORDER DO FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE WE PUSHED
BACK.
ENDED TWELVE UNITS
THE SAME ARGUMENT WAS I'M
ASSUMING YOU'RE A AND THE
UNDERLYING ARGUMENT IS ONE TO
ONE INCENTIVIZE THEM TO DO IT
SHORTER BY IT BY GIVING MORE
FINANCIALLY IF IT WAS SHORTER.
AND IF YOU'RE MAKING A LOT MORE
FINANCIAL AID YOU WOULD ACTUALLY
DECREASE SOMEBODY'S POSSIBILITY
OF.
PURPOSE OF EDUCATION IN
PARTICULAR COMMUNITY COLLEGES IS
THE GET SOMEBODY TO BE
SUCCESSFUL. AND IF THIS IS A
TOOL THAT ACTUALLY PROVIDE
SOMEBODY BELIEVE IT COMPLETE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE.
I WOULD I WOULD USE THIS DATA
TO THE EXTENT POSSIBLE AYE ONE
WANTS TO MISS THE FALLOUT AND
THAT'S REALLY THE THE DANGER AND
NOT GIVING FREE COMMUNITY ONSITE
NOT DOING COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR A
FIGHT CALTRANS FOR US. FOR SIX
YEARS AND THE CASE IN POINT IS A
PROGRAM FOR USE FOR SIX YEARS.
.
AND SO WE WANT TO LINE IT UP TO
TO STANDARDS THAT WE BELIEVE
WILL MAKE A STUDENTS SUCCESSFUL.
OKAY AND HERE'S THE OTHER THING
TO.
OKAY JAMMIN MORE STUDENTS UP
WITH MORE CLASSES.
OR TRYING TO GET HIM TO DO IT IN
A SHORTER AND SHORTER TIME FRAME
ALL ULTIMATELY ENDS UP
POTENTIALLY HURT IN THE GREAT IF
THEY'RE HAVING TO RUSH TO
CLASSES. AND INSTEAD OF GETTING
AN A YOU GET A BEER YOU GET TO
SEE IN YOU ACTUALLY. YOU
ACTUALLY DID TORAH STUDENTS
POSSIBILITY OF GETTING IN THE IN
A BETTER POST GRADUATE SCHOOL.
FOR GETTING INTO POSTGRADUATE
SCHOOL SO THERE'S A. WILL
THERE'S A WAY WE CAN CONTINUE ON
THE ARE ON ON THIS CONVERSATION.
BUT ULTIMATELY IF I TAKE A LOOK
AT A COMMUNITY COLLEGE OR AN
EDUCATION SYSTEM AS THE ULTIMATE
GOAL TO MAKE A STUDENTS
SUCCESSFUL MAN MEANS COMPLETING
GRADUATING AND GOING ON. EITHER
GET A JOB REPORTS GRADUATE AND I
THINK THESE ARE.
GOOD TOOLS TO CONTINUE THAT YEAH
AND I I'M I. I APPRECIATE THE
AM.
CONVERSATION AT THE. POINT YOU
YOU'RE SAYING IS IF THE ARGUMENT
IS SIMILAR TO WHAT IT WAS WITH A
FREE TUITION AND THAT'S NOT MINE
AYE SPIES THAT MAY HAVE. FUNDS
AND WE WANNA MAKE SURE OPTIMALLY
SUPPORTING STUDENTS.
SO I APPRECIATE THAT PART THAT
IT'S IT'S NOT ONLY JUST TO GIVE
THEM AN INCENTIVE SOME OF THE
POINTS YOU'VE RAISED ARE GOOD
ONES ARE JUST ONES THAT TO ME
ARE GOING TO SPEED UP THE
PROCESS FOR THE STUDENT AND
MAKE.
MAKE IT ANY MORE LIKELY THAT
THEY CAN COMPETE ARE COMPLETE IN
THE TIME FOR ME THAT WE WOULD
WANT THEM TO.
AND
SPECIAL BECAUSE THOSE DOLLARS
ARE GOING TO COME FROM SOMEWHERE
HOW CAMINO ABSOLUTE HELP THEM TO
COMPLETE MY CONCERN ALSO IS I I
DO HAVE.
UP FIRST MUCH AS OF SUPPORTED
MORE FUNDING FOR SCHOOLS AND
EVERY TIME WE SAY IS. REALLY PUT
MORE INTO CAL GRANT THERE'S A
LOT OF INEQUITIES IN THE CAL
GRANT WE STILL HAVE DEFECTS
THAT'S COMING FROM SOMEWHERE.
AND I WANT TO MAKE SURE THE
STUDENTS ARE ABLE TO FINISH AND
HAVE SUPPORT TO FINISH ON TIME
AND MOVE ON TO THE NEXT AREA AND
I'M NOT SURE.
THE.
WHERE THE WHOLE IS RIGHT NOW
BASED ON WHAT YOU'VE MENTIONED
YOUR GOOD POINTS WILL JUST DON'T
KNOW WHAT HOLD THIS IS FILLING
LET ME PUT THE CONVERSATIONAL OF
IT? A LITTLE BIT AT A.
A LITTLE BIT TIGHTER HERE.
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT TWO
DIFFERENT POPULATIONS OF PEOPLE
YOU'RE TALKING ABOUT A
POPULATION OF PEOPLE WHO COULD
POTENTIALLY BE OR ALREADY ON A
TRACK THAT SUCCESS WE'RE TRYING
TO SHORE SHORTEN THE TIME LIMIT.
THAT SOMEBODY ELSE THAT
SOMEBODY'S GONNA PUT US RIGHT
ISSUES AND I'M SORRY I'M NOT
TRYING TO SHORTEN THE TIME LIMIT
STUDENTS I WANT I WANT TO KEEP
THEM ON THE PATHWAY THERE ON I
DON'T SEE HOW THIS. THAT THAT
HELPS THEM COMPLETE THAT A GROUP
OF STUDENTS HAS ALREADY A
PATHWAY TOWARD SUCCESS WE WERE
TALKING ABOUT A PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS WHO WERE NOT ON A
PATHWAY TO SUCCESS THAT WE WANT
TO MAKE SUCCESSFUL.
I THINK YOU AND I APPRECIATE THE
ANSWERS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS DOCTOR
WEBER.
YEAH YEAH I APPRECIATE THE BILL
COMING FORWARD AND I UNDERSTAND
IT AND I THINK.
OFTENTIMES DIFFICULT TO WRAP.
SOME OF OUR MINDS AROUND THE THE
THREE SYSTEMS THAT WE HAVE AN IN
THE COMMUNICATIVE SYSTEM ISN'T
VERY DIFFERENT KIND OF SYSTEM.
A AND OFTENTIMES PEOPLE THINK
AND I'VE HAD LOTS OF STUDENTS
WHO SPENT MANY YEARS THE
COMMUTER COLLEGES WHO'VE BEEN TO
TRANSFER TO THE UNIVERSITY. ARE
AND SOMETIMES WE LOOK AT AND
THINK GEE THEY SHOULD OF DONE
THE FASTER THEY SHOULD HAVE DONE
IT. CLEANER THEY SHOULD UP
WHATEVER AND AND.
WITHOUT A RECOGNITION THAT
OFTENTIMES THE STUDENTS WHO
ENTER THE COMMUNICABLE IS TO
SYSTEM NUMBER ONE WE KNOW THEY
HAVE REMEDIAL ISSUES THAT THEY
HAVE TO DEAL WITH.
TO THEY'RE NOT PROGRAM TO GO TO
COLLEGE MOST OF THEM ARE NOT.
THAT IN THERE BECAUSE THEY THEY
HAVEN'T THEY HAD THEY WOULD HAVE
BEEN THINKING ABOUT IT YEARS
BEFORE AND TAKEN S. A. T. AND
TRY TO GET INTO SOME FOUR YEAR
INSTITUTION I MEAN THEY'RE NOT
THE ONES THAT ARE HITTING. ON
THAT PATH INITIALLY SO YOU'VE
GOT SOME CHALLENGES THERE. WE
ALSO KNOW FROM OUR OWN RESEARCH
YOU THAT THE MOST EXPENSIVE
INSTITUTION WE HAVE IS REALLY
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE. BECAUSE
OF THE FACT THAT MOST OF THEM
ARE STUDENTS EVEN THOUGH THEY
DON'T PAY THE HIGH FEES THEY
HAVE LIVING EXPENSES AND THINGS
THAT ARE NOT ACCOUNTED FOR. AND
SO OFTENTIMES OUR STUDENTS WHO
DON'T GET. MUCH FINANCIAL AID I
DON'T APPLY FOR IT AT THE TIME
BECAUSE THEY THINK THEY WANT TO
SAVE IT FOR THE UNIVERSITY. ARE
OUT ARE BECAUSE SOMEBODY TOLD
THEM THAT COLLEGE WAS CHEAPER AT
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL AND
IT IS WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE. THE
ACTUAL FEES A PEOPLE PAPER WHEN
YOU GO BEYOND THAT AND START
TALKING ABOUT LIVING EXPENSES
AND SO FORTH AND SO ON IT
BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT AND MOST
OF OUR COMMUNITY BECAUSE
STUDENTS ARE WORKING.
SOME HAVE FAMILIES HAVE ALL
KINDS OF ISSUES THAT ARE THERE
AND BECAUSE THEY THINK IT MAY
HAVE TO SAY FOR THE MORE
EXPENSIVE EXPERIENCES. THREE
FOUR YEARS DOWN THE ROAD THEY
DON'T OFTEN DO FINANCIAL AID.
THAT MUCH AT THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE AND THEY MISS OUT ON AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE THE
FINANCIAL SUPPORT THE KEEP THE
MOVING FORCE SO THEY DON'T HAVE
TO WORK SO MUCH. THEY DON'T HAVE
TO DROP OUT ONE FOR ONE SEMESTER
TO THE NEXT TO MAKE THINGS
HAPPEN THEY DON'T HAVE TO WAIT
TO GET THE BOOKS I MEAN THAT'S
JUST UP A WHOLE LOT OF THINGS
THAT. BECAUSE THEY WANT PROGRAM
FOR THE UNIVERSITIES OF THE
COLLEGES THAT NOT GETTING THAT
KIND OF INFORMATION THAT KIND OF
DIRECTION AND WE LOSE A LOT OF
STUDENTS AND I'VE HAD STUDENTS
TO SAY WHAT TOOK YOU SO LONG.
AND WHEN I ACTUALLY LOOK AT
THEIR JOURNEY IT WAS YOU KNOW
ALMOST LIKE A NIGHTMARE BECAUSE
THEY DIDN'T HAVE MONEY FOR ONE
SEMESTER TO THE NEXT. WE HAD TO
DO THIS I HAD TO DO THAT THEY
WERE PAYING FOR THIS THAT TOP
AND DO THINGS AND SO IT REALLY
IS. QUITE AN INTERESTING JOURNEY
WHEN YOU DEAL WITH COMMITTEE
COLLEGE STUDENTS WHO FINALLY
MAKE IT TO THE FORTY
INSTITUTIONS WERE NOT DEALT WITH
THEM AND THEY DO ABOUT THE TIME
TO GIVE OF THEIR OLDER. THEY
HAVE DEFINITELY BEEN
INCOMMUNICADO JUST OF SEVERAL
COMMITTEE COLLEGES OVER AND OVER
AND SO AND AND THEY DON'T GET
ALL THE INFORMATION ABOUT
FINANCIAL AID IN THOSE KINDS OF
THINGS INTO THE ALMOST AT THE
END. SO I THINK IT'S A DIFFERENT
POPULATION STUDENTS WERE TALKING
ABOUT.
TRYING TO LAND IT WOULD PROGRAM
TO GIVE THEM THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SAY LISTEN YOU CAN ALSO GET SOME
FINANCIAL AID SO YOU DON'T HAVE
TO WORK SO HARD. AND DON'T HAVE
TO DELAY GETTING YOUR BOOKS AND
OTHER KINDS OF THINGS AND YOU
REALLY CAN BE A STUDENT WORKING
PART TIME IN GOING TO COLLEGE SO
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT. T THAT
LEVEL AT NET AT THIS I THINK
WE'VE LEARNED ONE OF OUR.
PROGRAM TO HAVE A COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND AND SEE ISSUES NEW
SEASON WHEN WE WHEN WE TAKE OUT
THE FAT VARIABLE OF. OF OF OF.
TUITION AND LOOK AT THE
EXPENSES AND WE DISCOVER THAT WE
GIVE MORE MONEY FOR SEE ISSUES
MORE MONEY FOR UC'S FOR LIVING
EXPENSES ALMOST NONE FAR
COMMUNICATIVE AND SO AS A
RESULT.
THEY END UP WITH THE WILL OF THE
HIGHER. EDUCATION COSTS THEN THE
OTHER STUDENTS AND SO WE REALLY
REALLY HAVE TO FACTOR THAT IN SO
I APPRECIATE YOU COMING FORWARD
WITH THIS BECAUSE IT IS. IT IS
AN ISSUE WHAT WE HAVE TO DEAL
WITH LONG TERM AND IT WOULD GIVE
WITHIN SOME PROVIDE SOME KIND OF
FINANCIAL SUPPORT AND HELP THEM
THEY. AFFECT THEY SHOULD GET IT
EARLIER WILL BASICALLY BE IT AN
INCENTIVE ENOUGH FOR THEM TO
MOVE FORWARD. I THINK WE TAKE
THINK ABOUT INCENTIVES AS IF TO
SAY GRADUATION ITSELF IS AN AND
SENATE ANDTHAT IS BUT THERE'S A
A DIFFERENT KIND OF JOURNEY THIS
THE. AND THEY HANG IN THERE TO
GET BEER BUT IT'S NOT THIS
TYPICAL BILLION JOE COLLEGE
MENTALITY THAT JUST GOING TO
SCHOOL AND BEING HAPPY EVERY DAY
AND YOU KNOW DO WHATEVER YOU DO
ON WEEKENDS. AND AND GRADUATE IN
FOUR YEARS YOU KNOW THAT'S
THAT'S A MYTH NOWADAYS FOR
ALMOST EVERY STUDENT BUT IT'S A
GOAL BUT IT'S NOT THE STUDENTS
DON'T WANT TO ACHIEVE IT IS DOES
T BECOMES DIFFICULT.
I APPRECIATE THAT I RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR A I SUPPORT YOUR BILL
AND AND.
THE MOVE BY DOCTOR WEBER SECOND
BY MISTER LOW.
YOU'RE SANTIAGO WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE I RESPECTFULLY ASK WHEN
I VOTE AND YET I THINK YOU FOR
COMMENTS AND TAKE YOU FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FORWARD AND
THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
MADAM SECRETARY BUTTE CALL THE
ROLL.
AND THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
MEDINA AYE AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER.
BAKER NO ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ
IRWIN.
KILEY.
KILEY NO STONE.
STONE I LOW. LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NOT VOTING QUIRK
SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO AYE AYE
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
SEVEN TWO.
BILL IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT.
TO KILEY.
SO.
.
ITEM NUMBER TEN.
ITEM TEN.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FOUR.
WELCOME MR GUYS
.
THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR AND
MEMBERS.
TODAY'S BECAUSE RESOLUTION ARE
TODAY'S LEGISLATION THAT BUILDS
ON ASSEMBLY CONCURRENT
RESOLUTION TWENTY ONE I WHICH
WAS ALSO CO AUTHORED OR JOINTLY
AUTHORED BY ME IN ASSEMBLY.
MEMBER QUIRK I WHICH PASSED BOTH
HOUSES UNANIMOUSLY IN WHICH
CALLED ON CALIFORNIA'S
UNIVERSITIES TO ADOPT BRIEF
SPEECH STATEMENTS THAT
REAFFIRMED THEIR COMMITMENT TO
FREE EXPRESSION.
TODAY'S BELL AYE BUILDS ON THAT
COMMITMENT
IT DRAWS ON THE WORK OF TWO
PROMINENT MEMBERS OF THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
FACULTY.
ERWIN CHEMERINSKY DEAN OF UC
BERKELEY LAW SCHOOL AND HOWARD
GILMAN CHANCELLOR OF UC IRVINE.
THE BILL IS SUPPORTED NOT ONLY
BY THOSE SCHOLARS BUT ALSO BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
ITSELF.
DEAN XIN MARIN SKIN CANCER
GILMAN'S BOOK FREE SPEECH ON
CAMPUS
NOTES THAT A DEEP PERSISTENT
IDEOLOGICAL DIVISIONS IN SOCIETY
ARE LEADING MANY TO TREAT
POLITICAL OPPONENTS AS ENEMIES.
SHOUT DOWN CRITICS AND REJECT
COMPROMISE.
BUT UNIVERSITIES MUST STRIVE TO
DO BETTER.
COLLEGE CAMPUSES THE AUTHORS
WRITE
STAND AS MODELS FOR HOW DIVERSE
COMMUNITIES OF PEOPLE WORK
TOGETHER TO ADDRESS IMPORTANT
AND DIFFICULT QUESTIONS.
THEY HAD THAT UNIVERSITIES MAKE
THEIR STRONGEST CONTRIBUTION TO
FREE SOCIETIES
WHAT A LIVELY AND DIVERSE CAMPUS
COMMUNITY SHOWS A GENUINE DESIRE
TO ENGAGE COMPETING
PERSPECTIVES.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK I HAVE
WORKED CLOSELY WITH DEAN CHAMBER
AND SKIN CHANCEL GILMAN
THE CRAFT THOUGHTFUL POLICY
AIMED AT PROMOTING LIVELY AND
DIVERSE CAMPUS COMMUNITIES WERE
FREE SPEECH.
FOR ASH.
THIS BILL HAS TWO PARTS.
THE FIRST CALLS ON CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AND
CALIFORNIA STATE UNIVERSITY
CAMPUSES AND URGES UC CAMPUSES
TO CREATE AND DISSEMINATE FREE
SPEECH STATEMENTS THAT INFIRM
THE IMPORTANCE OF FREE
EXPRESSION.
FOSTERING A CULTURE OF FREE
SPEECH DEPENDS ON CAMPUSES
CLEARLY COMMUNICATING THEIR
COMMITMENT TO FREE EXPRESSION
ACADEMIC INQUIRY THAT PUBLIC
DEBATE. THIS IS THE VERY
PRINCIPLE THAT THE LEGISLATURE
ENDORSED LAST YEAR WHEN IT
UNANIMOUSLY PASSED STR TWENTY
ONE.
THE SECOND COMPONENT OF TODAY'S
BILL LOT CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES AND CSU CAMPUSES AND
WOULD URGE UC CAMPUSES TO
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
TEACHING THE HISTORY AND VALUE.
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
THIS IS THE RECOGNITION AS DEAN
CHEVRON SKI AND A CHANCE R.
GILMAN HAVE EXPLAINED
THAT IN APPRECIATION OUR THE
HISTORIC SIGNIFICANCE AND CIVIC
PURPOSE OF THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
CANNOT BE TAKEN FOR GRANTED.
BY ENSURING THE UNIVERSITIES
PROVIDE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
LEARNING THE HISTORY VALUE OF
THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
THE FREE SPEECH ON CAMPUS ACT
AIMS TO ENGENDER AN APPRECIATION
FOR FREE SPEECH AND CREATE THE
CONDITIONS FOR INCLUSIVE
LEARNING ENVIRONMENTS WHERE
DIVERSE IDEAS CAN BE EXPRESSED
AND DEBATED.
I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR AYE
VOTE AND JOINING ME TODAY IS
TAMMY AT ROSMAN BENJAMIN.
WHO IS DIRECTOR OF ON CUT
INITIATIVE?
HI GOOD AFTERNOON CHAIRMAN
MEDINA AND.
AND MEMBERS.
MY NAME IS TAMMY ROTHMAN
BENJAMIN AND I AM THE DIRECTOR
OF THE UNPUNISHED IF WHICH IS A
NONPARTISAN NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION. DEDICATED TO
MONITORING INVESTIGATING IN
COMBAT IN CAMPUS ANTI SEMITISM
NATIONALLY.
I WAS ALSO A FACULTY MEMBER AT
UC SANTA CRUZ FOR ABOUT TWENTY
YEARS.
OVER THE PAST YEAR THERE'S BEEN
A SHARP SPIKE IN ACTS OF HATRED
AND INTOLERANCE.
TARGETING AFRICAN AMERICANS JEWS
MOSLEMS LGBTQ COMMUNITY MEMBERS
IMMIGRANTS WOMEN AND INDIVIDUALS
WHO HER WHO HOLD DIVERGENT
IDEOLOGICAL AND POLITICAL
VIEWPOINTS AND IDENTITIES.
SADLY WE ARE WITNESSING AN
UNPRECEDENTED UNWILLINGNESS TO
ACCEPT OR MERELY RECOGNIZE AND
RESPECT.
BACKGROUNDS BELIEFS OR BEHAVIOR
THAT DIFFER FROM ONE'S OWN.
OUR MONITORING AND RESEARCH
INDICATE THAT THIS IS MOST
PROBLEMATIC ON COLLEGE CAMPUSES.
WHERE WE FIND THAT ONE GROUP'S
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION IS BEING
USED TO DENIGRATE HARASS
INTIMIDATE AND SHUT DOWN?
THE THE EXPRESSION OF OTHER
GROUPS.
THIS NOT ONLY DEPRIVES
INDIVIDUALS OF THEIR FREEDOM OF
EXPRESSION AND SOCIAL POLITICAL
AND ACADEMIC RIGHTS.
IT UNDERMINES THE VERY MISSION
OF THE UNIVERSITY.
ALTHOUGH OUR ORGANIZATION
FOCUSES PRIMARILY ON PROTECTING
JEWISH STUDENTS FROM INTOLERANT
BEHAVIOR THAT'S ANTI SEMITIC.
WE BELIEVE THE ENTIRE CAMPUS
BENEFITS WHEN ALL STUDENTS
ARE INSURED EQUAL PROTECTION
FROM EXCLUSIONARY BEHAVIOR THAT
WOULD DEPRIVE THEM OF THEIR
FREEDOM OF EXPRESSION. AND FULL
PARTICIPATION IN CAMPUS LIFE.
AND TOWARDS THAT END WE'VE BEEN
WORKING WITH UNIVERSITIES ACROSS
THE COUNTRY TO ENCOURAGE THE
ADOPTION OF ADEQUATE AND
EQUITABLE RESPONSES TO
EXCLUSIONARY BEHAVIOR.
AS WELL AS THE IMPLEMENTATION OF
EDUCATIONAL INITIATIVES THAT CAN
HELP STUDENTS UNDERSTAND THEIR
RIGHTS AND RESPONSIBILITIES WITH
RESPECT TO THE FIRST AMENDMENT.
AND ENCOURAGE TOLERANT AND
RESPECTFUL BEHAVIORS THAT ALLOW
FOR THE EXPRESSION OF A WIDE
RANGE OF OPINIONS AND
IDENTITIES.
THESE ARE THE VERY PRINCIPLES
THAT HAVE BEEN CODIFIED IN AB
TWO THREE SEVEN FOR THE CAMPUS
FREE SPEECH ACT.
A BILL THAT I BELIEVE WILL GO A
LONG WAY TO RESTORING CIVILITY
AND RESPECT WHEN YOU SEE CSU IN
CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY COLLEGE
CAMPUSES.
AND UPHOLDING THE PILLARS OF
HIGHER EDUCATION THAT WILL
BENEFIT OUR STATE. AND OUR
NATION FOR YEARS TO COME THANK
YOU.
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
TYLER I YOU ARMY AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA IN
SUPPORT.
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION.
COMMENTS OR QUESTIONS FROM THE
COMMITTEE.
IT'S BAKER.
A THANK YOU MEMBER KILEY FOR
BRINGING THIS FORWARD. NOT JUST
AS A M.
CAL.
LAW SCHOOL GRAD GO BEARS HAVE TO
GET THE UPPER MICHIGAN THERE
BUT.
ON THE OTHER YOU SEE UNIVERSITY
OF CHICAGO THAT BROUGHT FORWARD
A POLICY AT A VERY CONTENTIOUS
TIME LAST.
TWO YEARS.
ABOUT THE NEED FOR A ROBUST
MARKETPLACE OF IDEAS WHAT I
REALLY LIKE WHAT YOU'VE DONE
WITH THIS YOU'VE ALSO ADDED THE
FIRST AMENDMENT.
OPPONENTS.
THAT THAT THAT BE EMPHASIZED AND
AS PART OF THEIR. TEACHING AND.
ALSO PART THE CONVERSATIONS I
DON'T KNOW THAT YOU ARE BUT IF
YOU TAKE CO AUTHORS I'D BE
HONORED TO HAVE AN OPTION A CO
AUTHOR DOZEN AFTERGLOW NAME BUT.
I JUST REALLY PLEASED TO SEE
THIS AND GLAD THAT.
THE RESOLUTION LAST YEAR WAS
VERY GOOD IT'S EVEN BETTER TO
SEE LEGISLATION WITH EVEN MORE
TEETH TO IT COME FOR THIS YEAR
THANK YOU.
I ALSO WANT TO THANK THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THIS FORWARD AYE I
APPRECIATE THE TESTIMONY HERE
AND SAY THAT WE'VE WORKED
TOGETHER. ON OTHER ISSUES AS
WELL. AND AS I STATED.
PREVIOUSLY IN THIS COMMITTEE.
.
I THINK THE ISSUE OF FREEDOM OF
SPEECH IS VERY IMPORTANT. THAT
IN A SOCIETY AND A ESPECIALLY SO
IN OUR INSTITUTIONS OF HIGHER
EDUCATION.
.
DEAN THE DEAN OF THE LAW SCHOOL
NOW I BELIEVE IT USC. A SOMEONE
I ADMIRE VERY MUCH ADMIRE HIS
WORK AND I AGAIN. THANK YOU THE
AUTHOR FOR BRING IT FORWARD. AYE
I SUPPORT THIS BILL.
OUT WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE I
THINK THE I MEMBERS FOR THEIR
THOUGHTFUL COMMENTS AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR NOT AT.
SO. THE MOTION WAS BY MS BAKER
SECOND BY MISTER LOWE AND MADAM
SECRETARY VIEW WOULD CALL THE
ROLL.
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO THE
JUDICIARY COMMITTEE. MEDINA AYE
MEDINA AYE BAKER. BAKER AYE
ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM AYE SCHABAS.
IRWIN.
KILEY AYE AYE
KILEY AYE STONE.
STONE I LOW LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON AYE QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
GEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT AND WE
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT.
THANK YOU
IF YOU.
ME AND THAT'S IT.
OKAY
.
THANK YOU THIS IS FILE ITEM
THREE A. B. TWENTY TWELVE.
TRIMS SAY WITHOUT MY READING
GLASSES ON SO THAT'S GOOD.
AND.
.
WHENEVER YOU'RE READY MISTER
CHAIR THINK.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS I
AM PLEASED TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL TWENTY TWELVE.
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS COMMUNITY
COLLEGE INSTRUCTORS AND
CLASSIFIED SCHOOL EMPLOYEES.
UP TO TWELVE WEEKS OF
DIFFERENTIAL PAY. BY PROVIDING
THEM WITH THE SAME PAID PARENTAL
LEAVE RIGHTS.
A CERTIFICATED EMPLOYEES.
MY BILL TODAY WOULD SIMPLY
INSURE THAT PART TIME FACULTY
WORKING IN DIFFERENTIAL PAY
DISTRICTS RECEIVE NO LESS THAN
FIFTY PERCENT.
OF HIS OR HER REGULAR SALARY.
FOR THE DURATION OF THE PARENTAL
LEAVE.
A CHILD'S HEALTH AND WELL BEING
IS GREATLY AFFECTED BY THE
PRESENCE OR ABSENCE.
OF CONSISTENT PARENT OR
CAREGIVER.
ESPECIALLY IN THE EARLIEST
STAGES OF DEVELOPMENT. IN THE
FIRST TWELVE WEEKS.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWELVE
ADDRESSES AN INTENDED
CONSEQUENCE.
CURRENT LAW AND I RESPECTFULLY
ASK YOUR AYE VOTE.
HERE WITH ME TODAY ON BEHALF
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWELVE IS
BRIAN HA.
THE CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF TO.
THANK YOU MADAM CHAIR I MADAM
CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE MEMBERS.
WHEN A BEAT THIS IS BRIAN HOW
WITH CALIFORNIA FEDERATION OF
TEACHERS WHEN AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY THREE AN ACT THAT WAS
ENACTED INTO LAW. IT UP THERE
WAS AN OVERSIGHT THAT PREVENT A
CERTAIN TYPE. OF PART TIME
FACULTY MEMBERS FROM RECEIVING
DIFFERENTIAL PAY.
THE ORIGINAL INTENT OF AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY THREE.
THE WAS TO EXTEND THAT THEIR
FRIENDSHIP BENEFIT TO THE
REMAINING K. FOURTEEN EMPLOYEES.
THIS BILL AB TWENTY TWELVE
ADDRESSES THAT OVERSIGHT.
I ASK FOR A AYE VOTE THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON COMMITTEE
MEMBERS.
STEPHANIE DOT WITH THE FACULTY
ASSOCIATION OF CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES.
FOR THE PROUD CO SPONSORS OF
THIS BILL AND WE RESPECTIVELY
REQUEST AN AYE VOTE.
ANY ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT.
NAME AND AFFILIATION PLEASE.
AFTER MADAM CHAIR MEMBERS IT NOT
YOUR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF THE
COMMUNICATION WORKERS OF AMERICA
DISTRICT NINE IN SUPPORT THE
BILL.
GOOD AFTERNOON A BEHIND SHAKE
WITH THE UNIVERSITY PROFESSIONAL
AND TECHNICAL EMPLOYEES CW A
LOCAL NINETY ONE NINETEEN AND
STRONG SUPPORT.
THANK YOU ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION OR TRAINERS.
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
FROM COLLEAGUES.
IF YOU LIKE TO CLOSE MEASURE
RESPECTFULLY ASK YOUR RIVAL.
GREAT WE HAVE A MOTION FROM MISS
WEBER THIS IS A DO YOU PASS TO.
TWO EDUCATION COMMITTEE. TO HAVE
A SECOND.
Q. AND AMPA THANK YOU MISTER
SANTIAGO SECONDS.
OF.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
MEDINA AYE MEDINA AYE BAKER NOW
BAKER NO ARAMBULA.
BLOOM.
BLOOM I CHAVEZ.
IRWIN.
KILEY.
STONE.
STONE I LOW.
LOW AYE PATTERSON.
PATTERSON NO QUIRK SILVA.
QUIRK SILVA AYE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO AYE WEBER.
WEBER I.
SEVEN TWO IT'S OUT.
SHE WILL HAVE MEMBERS OUT ON.
THANK YOU.
AND TO DO THAT WE.
THAT WAS EARLY LAST.
OFFICIAL ITEM IT'S POSSIBLE TO
BEGIN TO.
AND ON MEMBERS.
MARCH GOOD CHAIRS ARRIVING.
CONCERT WITH
.
YOU KNOW A. LITTLE BIT LATER.
DO WE KNOW.
THAT.
YOU DO.
OKAY. KILEY GOODY GOODIES I
PERSONALLY. AND I THINK THAT.
THAT IS JUST KILEY IN A
RELIABLE.
IF THEY HAVE AN IDEA THAT. YOU
HAVE TO ADD ON TO THIS BIG
GROUPS SO QUICKLY WE CAN WE CAN
START FEELING IT YEAH YEAH. YEAH
RIGHT.
OKAY GO DOWN THE FIRE. OKAY.
QUE.
AB EIGHTEEN OH FIVE.
ITEM ONE BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA KILEY.
ELEVEN ZERO A. B. EIGHTEEN OH
FIVE IS OUT WE WILL STILL KEEP
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. ITEM
TO AB NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE.
ARAMBULA.
AND KILEY.
ITEM THREE AB TWENTY TWELVE
CHAVEZ IRWIN.
IRWIN AYE KILEY.
TWENTY TWELVE.
SO A. B. TWENTY TWELVE AIDS TO.
WE SHOULD KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM FOR AB
TWENTY FORTY ONE.
KILEY.
A. B.
TWENTY FORTY ONE STILL NINE
THREE WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS ITEM FIVE AB
TWENTY EIGHTY ONE. BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
KILEY.
ARAMBULA DID YOU WANNA VOTE ON.
.
OR MAYBE NOT.
SO THAT.
WE WERE WE WE WERE JUST CALLING.
ITEM FIVE.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY ONE
I MISS MELINDA'S NOT VOTING
OKAY.
THREE SEVEN.
WE WOULD STILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
BERNIE.
ITEM NINE AB TWENTY THREE OH SIX
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA AYE SHOWBIZ IRWIN.
IRWIN I
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWENTY
THREE OH SIX NINE TWO BILL IS
OUT KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS.
ITEM TEN AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY
FOUR.
ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I.
SHOP IS IRWIN.
IRWIN I.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FOUR TWELVE ZERO WE WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM ELEVEN AB TWENTY THREE
NINETY ONE THAT THE MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED TO THE FLOOR.
BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
KILEY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE
NINETY ONE TWELVE ZERO THE BILL
IS OUT WE WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY FOUR.
BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE
KILEY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FIVE FIFTY
FOUR TWELVE ZERO WE WILL KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS BILL IS
OUT.
ITEM TWELVE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN.
KILEY.
ELEVEN ZERO
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN IS OUT KEEP IT
OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
ITEM FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
SIXTY THREE. BAKER.
BAKER I ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I KILEY.
TWELVE ZERO ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY
FIVE SIXTY THREE IS OUT WE WILL
KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE.
KILEY.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE TWELVE ZERO KEEP IT
OPEN BILL IS OUT KEEP IT OPEN
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS.
THE CONSENT CALENDAR KILEY.
CONSENT CALENDAR STILL TWELVE
ZERO.
IT'S PAST
BUT THAT.
OKAY AB EIGHTEEN NO FIVE
ARAMBULA. ARAMBULA AYE KILEY.
TWELVE ZERO AB EIGHTEEN OH FIVE
IS OUT.
WE KEEP IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS AB NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE
ARAMBULA.
KILEY.
AB NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE TWELVE
ZERO WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS. AND AB TWENTY
TWELVE ARAMBULA.
ARAMBULA I SAW THAT IS.
KILEY.
YOU MISTER AVILA.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY TWELVE.
NINE TWO.
IT IS OUT WILL KEEP IT OPEN FOR
ABSENT MEMBERS.
KILEY.
SENATOR COOPER.
IT JUST WAS NOT.
BUSY GUY.
YEAH I GET IT DONE AND GET IT
DONE ONE OF THOSE DAYS.
WE KNOW HOW IT IS.
ITEM ONE A. B. EIGHTEEN NO FIVE
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
A. B. EIGHT YOU KNOW FIVE
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
I AM TOO IT AB NINETEEN THIRTY
FIVE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
A V. NINETEEN THIRTY FIVE
THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER THREE AB TWENTY
TWELVE CHAVEZ KILEY.
KILEY NO.
A. B. TWENTY TWELVE
NINE THREE THE BILL AS OUT ITEM
FOUR AB TWENTY FORTY ONE KILEY.
KILEY KNOW.
AB TWENTY FORTY ONE.
NINE FOR THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER FIVE AB TWENTY
EIGHTY ONE.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE
.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY EIGHTY ONE.
FOUR SEVEN.
THE BILL FAILS.
ITEM NUMBER NINE AB TWENTY THREE
OH SIX.
CHAVEZ.
ASSEMBLY BILL TWENTY THREE OH
SIX NINE TO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER TEN AB TWENTY THREE
SEVENTY FOUR.
CHAVEZ.
AB TWENTY THREE SEVENTY FOUR
TWELVE ZERO THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM NUMBER ELEVEN AB TWENTY
THREE NINETY ONE.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
AB TWENTY THREE NINETY ONE
TWELVE THIRTEEN ZERO THAT BILL
IS OUT.
I AM TWELVE AB TWENTY FOUR
SEVENTY SEVEN KILEY.
KILEY NO.
AB TWENTY FOUR SEVENTY SEVEN
ELEVEN ONE THAT BILL IS OUT.
ITEM THIRTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE
FIFTY FOUR.
KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
A. B.
TWENTY FIVE FIFTY FOUR THIRTEEN
ZERO THE BILL IS OUT ITEM
FOURTEEN AB TWENTY FIVE SIXTY
THREE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
A. B. TWENTY FIVE SIXTY THREE
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT.
ITEM SIXTEEN AB TWENTY SEVEN
EIGHTY FIVE KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
AB TWENTY SEVEN EIGHTY FIVE
THIRTEEN ZERO THE BILL IS OUT
AND THE CONSENT CALENDAR. KILEY.
KILEY AYE.
SENATE CALENDAR THIRTEEN ZERO
CONSENT CALENDAR IS PASSED.
WERE INJURED